[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect what's up everybody I am
Thomas dool or whatever you want to call
me this is the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Mar O'Neal what's
up guys what up guys we have a very
special episode today I I honestly
believe we could have got like the
entire Grammy Award winners of last year
before we got this fool on the show it's
not true it's like it it was like what
we had to invade another country to get
this man on the show we get all the
Grammy Award winners I think the fans
would have still chose this man over him
okay yeah there there we go guys this is
John The Hash House episode John the dop
is what are we calling you now just John
just John work just John guys John does
a lot of stuff and he's nervous and I
can see it and I love it it's so not
nervous at all guys he's kicking my
shoes underneath just untied my shoe
pretty good huh yeah all right guys this
is it you ready what's up man you ready
finally here yeah it's a little hot it's
not hot oh these lights it's not hot
you're just nervous little bit okay
since we know it's probably well you
know let's let's try our best not to get
age restricted and hurt I say let's
light up all these right now we've had a
couple wholesome episodes in the
row Pome episodes I don't know if fluffy
and like you pick some people before you
to wait for that are like yeah we got
Jeezy on the show before we got John on
the show which
is kind of shocking I I've been waiting
to get
invited yeah we've we actually never
asked John to come on the show this is
going to be like an OG episode where I'm
just calling you out on like that didn't
happen no I'm going calling you out the
whole time John prepar T talk style
speech for us I have it in my phone I'm
gonna it no it's right here guys we're
going to be taking dabs we're going to
be chilling we're gonna be hanging out
and this is going to be stories we're
just going to talk Andor um no arguing
John you can't go like yo that was built
in 1980 nope researching tell you '96
we're not going to argue I think people
would like to see us argue no cuz him
and to you guys have seen our videos
we'll just argue you've seen all the
footage we'll just argue for 90 minutes
arguing's gold right I usually chop it
out but yeah it's gold it's gold for
everyone else but the viewers you should
chop it out no it's gold um sure John
where were you born not New York Where
Were You Raised I was born in New York
Where Were You Raised oh Florida this F
always says where you from New York me
too first eight minutes of my life I was
in New York two years two years first
two years of my life that counts the
first 24 months of my nonverbal life he
couldn't even he built an accent he my
nonverbal life he was in Florida with an
accent I promise you in a New York exit
in New York City uh I was born in Queens
yeah and was two years I was there as
Westchester and then I moved to Florida
what kind of job did you have when you
were in New York you're not hustling
sorry hey baby hey baby hey how long you
been there hey baby that's a Dave
Chappelle's uh stand I I knew that did
you really I did not oh okay
okay at this point he's starting to
learn references from off of us from the
reference i' never even seen it which is
good exactly that's not a bad thing I
think my memory is getting better too it
is getting better I think think what it
isly it's the
exercise I think it's you being like no
I'm not eating past 8 and I'm going to
work out and your brain went yo he's
doing it he's doing it remember when
Peter Pan started flying you know
remember when Peter Pan started flying
like you're doing it you're doing it
that's what happened with this bra like
yo we're going to continue with this
[__] all right and then your brain
kicked in there's like a little piece of
my brain that's like when pu oh your
balls dropped oh his brain dropped like
oh he's catching
up like oh I'm sorry I'm going to talk
[__] continue Marty so what have you
been you've been training kickboxing uh
boxing okay so what's that been looking
like CU you've clearly lost a bunch of
weight you look great thank you thank
you uh I've been boxing basically for
like four months now MH lost about 40
PBS and just been eating right changing
my lifestyle nice are you headed towards
veganism NE never not like a passionate
that could never be so passionate it's
so passionate that I'm going to make
sure Thomas is not a vegan by the end of
this year that's not true no it's
possible your passion bubbles over at
other people yeah yeah yeah people I
care about yeah yeah when we were in uh
what was it Miami mhm he ate a dog when
we were in the street we were walking he
went like a hot dog a dog cat it was a
cat it was a cat this was just eat meat
Goa I mean if you're going to eat meat
why I shaved I shaved the cat before not
the tail why do we discriminate between
different we're about to get pea on us
for talking about this we're about to
get in trouble but still funny I'm
talking about quality for animal eating
you know it definitely did not happen
definitely don't eat cat well like in
The Simpsons when Homer's is talking to
the pig he takes a bite out of him there
we go yeah seven references we're 2
minutes in man about s minutes in with
two
references no it was at least four or
five references how what time are we
in nine minutes no that's not true it
was at 5 minutes when we started we're
at four minutes it's okay we can can we
just smoke some weed already please God
thank God please
God all right John you born in Florida
where's your hair s where's your
hairstyle where's
where's your hairstyle cuz you're from
Boward listen when I first came from
Florida to C I was trying to find
someone to cut my hair and I went to a
bunch of barber shops and I'm like Hey
man can I get a blowout and they're like
what do you mean a blow like polyd so so
in Florida it's called a blowout but
what does that mean you like where the
the the the cbins are faded out and then
this is faded out it's kind of like long
on the
top what do that look like who would
that compare to I guess like a polyd but
not spiked this is a Jersey Shore style
haircut you're
it's kind of like that yeah but there
common the Ai No that no no no no no it
was like the same hair it's just it's
just instead of it being a full fate all
around your head it's just the sideburns
in the back of your head so when I came
here no one knew what that was so I had
to explain it to them and they were like
oh you're not from here and I'm like oh
you're not from here it's called like a
taper fade or something here it's called
something completely different I imagine
that's just you in Florida you know what
everybody I used to spike my hair when I
was in elementary school that's what me
too my hair looked just like that not
spiky like that mine was spiked with
like the wax Vegeta yeah like
Vegeta that's crazy yeah elementary
school I had crazy spiked
hair I didn't know what to do I would
just comb mine down I'd go like this oh
the wave in the front my grandma used to
do that for me she's a yeah I do it in
the front go all right I guess and it's
hard as a rock cuz I use hairspray CU I
was always trying to play basketball I
don't wanted to get my eyes but then
wouldn't the hairspray like sweat it
would that's terrible but just do this
it's better than getting your eye though
that's going to every day every shot
every shot every shot every shot so
Boward it's crazy so Marty has a lighter
you don't have a lighter are you
serious but I don't have a lighter guys
Marty man thank you so much that was
supposed to be on your side was supposed
to be right
yeah it's all right we smoking what are
we smoking here thas lemon poppers the
last the last of my lemon poppers that
pound lasted me not even
I thought it
honestly back out you get you get your
like when you get a pound of weed you
stop dabbing and when you don't have
weed you start dabbing that's true so if
you're not dabbing you're going to smoke
but I threw my back out too a lot of we
I wasn't smoking so it lasted me three
and a half weeks oh that's a long time
weeks yeah it's a long time last me a
month for you but the only weed you're
smoking I'm smoking other weeds did you
like the lemon poppers as much as he did
no no John's not lemon poppers is good I
just I can't smoke it all day like he
can
yeah b c County you're out there you're
chilling what's uh growing up like cuz
you have an older sister younger brother
older sister younger brother um my
sister's 5 years older my brother's six
years younger okay um walk us through
movie oh you were two get out of here
you didn't know what you're talking
about all right well you go to school I
kind of know my we basically uh fled
from my father we were like my mom's
like we're taking the kids and we're
leaving oh really yeah so she just put
us in the car and left and told my dad
when we're were halfway there like Hey
we're going to Florida did he like chase
you no no was yall messed up still yeah
yeah yeah oh okay okay oh really yeah
like you don't know movies like a
Kindergarten
Cop sorry I'm did you have family down
there or oh yeah so my grandfather was
there and my
dad and uh my mom and dad met in New
York at a rehab center shut up so my dad
was there for like hard drugs and my mom
was there for alcohol stop yeah so like
that's that's their that's their meeting
and they're like oh we should for sure
get together let's make kids let's make
kids you you're [__] up I'm [__] up
are you Ser [__] up hold on your
siblings are younger well my brother's
younger sister's older okay yeah so my
sister was in New York for a little
while with them they really yeah yeah
okay is your dad older than your mom
yeah 10 years older oh 10 years old 10
years yeah oh [__] I think my mom I
think she told me that the reason we
left too is my dad worked he was like
the he would like go to the casinos and
empty out the slot machines for the
mafia so he'd go and empty out the slot
machines his best friend was like was
like the son of like dude the dude the
main guy whatever the case may be and uh
he was stealing from the every time my
dad would go there he'd steal a little
bit of what he was emptying you know
because they didn't really know how much
it was and he got caught and the only
reason he got like spared I guess is
because the friend was like such a good
friend of him they basically just told
him like just be done you have nothing
else to go so my mom was like all right
we're leaving I'm get out of here with
them
damn yeah so if that wouldn't happened
you might have grown up in New York City
he would have been wearing Tims I think
here no he be wearing Tims LS calling us
kid what a kid what up God God that
would be John right now you like my
chain kid would have the chain in New
York that's be a whole different a whole
different person you'd be DJ khed I
think no
no who is that who is that um so all
right so you escape route and juked and
and took off yeah yeah took off I like
it and then uh we D over flew we drove
do you remember it not even a little bit
okay I couldn't tell you one one drop of
that at all oh why am I asking you sorry
before we start John has the worst
memory I've ever seen of anybody in my
entire life it's let's continue it's not
the best it's getting better though so I
think that the the crust broke when you
started working out and then it fell off
SL so like 4 months later I could
possibly have all my memory back as a
child wao 4 months later John has his
own show and he's just talking about
everything the wildest stories in that'd
be awesome stor I completely forgot for
sure completely oh your brain probably
did that quick so you take off I didn't
know that damn they
met sick so now I'm looking at both of J
like hey guys bad decision good decision
but come on yeah definitely not not the
smartest so when we came here James
still wasn't little brother still wasn't
here he was uh I think my dad came and
met us at some point I don't remember
the the the middle of it all my dad came
eventually we lived at we been like like
weird like little like uh wasn't
Apartments but it was like I guess it
was an apartment but it's like all it
was like a big circle of apartments one
story apartments like they were all
connected but there wasn't like a second
story or nothing and uh we lived there
for a little while and then my dad like
came back and met us there and then got
my mom pregnant with James and I never
forget they were going to tell us like
oh we have a big news to tell you guys
and me and my sister thought we were
going to Di Disney oh they sat us down
and they're like it's big news big and
we're like we're going to [__] Disney
we don't go anywhere we're poor as hell
we weren't going nowhere I was like yo
this is the time like we're going we're
doing something she like I'm pregnant
I'm like huh less room for you yeah yeah
it was terrible I had to share room with
my sister cuz cuz he was coming it was
actually actually I always share the
room with my sister I lied in that
apartment and then uh and then after
that we my mom my dad split up again
they got remarried three times
damn stop it yeah my dad worked my dad
worked for a church and uh when when she
got and the mafia so in Florida he
started working the church as like a
janitor and he was uh really close with
the pastor and the pastor got my mom
pregnant again the pastor was like you
have to marry her again John you can't
you can't not you can't have a pregnant
wife in the church and not marry her
again like he's God we can't afford it
we can't do that and he's like I'll do
it all for free so we had a whole
another ceremony for them again the last
one and they got married again then the
divorce probably like a year later later
or something like so each kid they
married and divorce yeah super sick
that's kind of awesome That's Unique
they did it for us though right my mom
they did for the kids dad not so much my
dad wasn't there too much my dad would
like just leave all the time like
randomly be
gone wild what's left to Aruba the
country the country right no it was the
The Corner Store yeah yeah yeah and then
he he left there for like two months to
do what he had some sugar mama taking
care everything because if he's broke
that's a flight yeah know he always he
always had a good way of getting around
for
sure damn the dope is Dad out here CH
syrup now
okay I like it I like the origin story
only now drinks syrups that's a only
thing he drinks so he's kind of in and
out of the equation kind of like yeah in
the beginning he was kind of in and out
all the time and then uh there was
basically a time where he was like kind
of I think I was probably I don't like
12 13ish and he was like kind of gone
for since since like out of the picture
for a while and then
um I think uh we moved we moved and mov
into a house my grandpa like that in New
York he's stupid loaded like your
grandpa is millionaire but doesn't so
like he he's taken care of like our
family but like only just like the the
like oh took care of your you got a
house you got a food and that's it so
like we got what we needed yeah it was
sick but at one point he like just took
it all from us
just like yo you guys don't get nothing
no more and took the house from us oh
damn and then your mom's dad yeah my
mom's dad what happened where he was
like yank he came to visit us one time
in the house it was like a really nice
house in Florida and uh he like saw that
it was like the kids Liv there so it was
like kind of dirty and he sign like
little things that like was like
completely normal for being dirty he's
like you guys are trashing my house just
get out oh [__] yeah they have a very
good relationship I never heard you
speak about him yeah yeah I no I don't
ever so he really left her hanging and
just yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah basically
that's it wa and he still owns the house
it's like his vacation house in Florida
oh
[__] yeah [__]
up no way yeah the same situation I was
over here it was the nicest house I ever
lived in for a long time you know cuz we
never lived in any nice house it was
like a twostory huge house on I lived on
a golf course so like I was like you I
was on the 18th hole of the golf course
so like you wow you see the celebration
every celebration you see yeah [__]
yeah yeah what okay okay
so I what he just yanked all right he
yanked the house from you guys which is
wild as hell yeah and you guys haven't
talked or chilled and your mom and them
were like all what the [__] wrong with
you yeah yeah just they just like kind
of went on separate ways so you haven't
talked to him at all no
whoa 15 years I talked a long time yeah
was he like so offended that you like
moved out or you just there's a lot more
like backstory to it like with her like
with the with the past family you know
so I think they have like their own
problems and then we're just like we're
just getting catching it yeah basically
so my mom doesn't [__] with him I don't
[__] with them yeah where'd you go what
happened with you guys school hold on
yeah school have you always been this
loud ass fool yeah okay in in yes always
I was I guess I was like the class clown
in school for sure gotcha okay had fun
at school I had fun I had fun uh what's
the capital of
Nebraska huh exactly he just having fun
couldn't couldn't tell you anything of
school bro I forgot the capital of
Nebraska too Lincoln thanks Marty I used
to do all 50 you want to make us both
feel dumb they gave me a soda he was
like link for saying all 50 capitals I
know I remember my fifth grade you know
you have like that like that like a yeah
United States test or whatever [__]
failed failed a it's not easy you got to
really [__] it process of elimination
[__] easy it was [__] easy process
of El I just didn't care I just care
yeah I feel you if it was memory [__] I
I got it but as soon as equations and
algebra came I failed College oh no see
I was cool with that I was trying to go
to college and didn't get that far we're
not we're not even there yet hold on
hold ready ready 16-year-old you
walks 16-year-old you walks into the
door and goes I'm gonna beat your ass
John do you win or he win I win now yeah
he's hold on before you started train
without boxing four months ago do you
win or he wins he wins oh this this this
boxing is conf this building his
confidence and his memory it's
definitely it's best sh I've been in my
entire life it's because it's
this John's like oh my God repetition
holy [__] and I think that's what it is
huh yeah you do got to know repetition
because you just said for this four
months of box like I beat the [__] out
in that 16year old yeah but like I was I
was in pretty good shape 16 like yeah
but you have what we call older man
strength you're now a full grown man
yeah but I was like a fat old grown man
four months ago real slow I get it the
difference between knowing how to throw
a jab and a cross and not is Lifetime oh
for sure buty 16y old you know I mean he
didn't how to throw F punch either and
if he did then what's going on with your
memory because he forgot how to fight
it's
crazy he definitely wasn't as agile as I
am for sure iess you know that's Rachel
right your wife married just in case
this fool forgot cuz Dam he forgot how
to
fight okay 16-year-old you loses ni
right that's what you want to hear we
always ask that question we we should
have
asked no I didn't want to ask I don't
want to ask why wouldn't you want to ask
him because he's a little guy and he's
80 years old oh I I home 16-year-old me
win [__] that would be a terrible
question yeah um okay all right
16-year-old you so you're a Class Clown
you're going into it what is the first
fight you ever get into in school John
have you ever been into a school fight
like a real one yeah yeah yeah oh wait
you used to fight all the time no no no
no wait you oh no your school was wild
my school fought all the time cuz we're
getting into what grade are you in when
you're get your I I I like I want to
hear this uh so Middle School uh that
was a pretty gnarly school um there was
fights probably at least twice a week
minimum minimum and it was but they
weren't like just like oh we're going to
fight and like roll around like people
are fighting like uh the I think there
was like the like the second or third
day of
of sixth grade and this girl I know she
has you know those like Starbucks
frappuccino cups the hard on like the
hard ones you get the gas station she's
like she was like I'm go hey John come
here real quick I'm G to talk to this
girl I don't [__] with her I was like
okay cool let's go over there she Taps
her shoulder the girl turns around she
cracks her over the eye with it like and
just starts like the girl fall straight
to the floor she just starts just
destroying her we're in sixth grade you
know like little kids still I was like
what what's going on right now it was
the craziest thing that happened to our
school school cuz it was like yo this
girl really doesn't give a [__] like she
just cracked a girl to blast a girl with
a bottles in sixth grades kind I wish I
KN I wish I remembered what the
situation is why she did it but I bet
you was like the most dumbest situation
Betty as [__] M got my iPhone
G uh kid DJ Coleman broke our assistant
Vice principal's jaw in sixth grade
punched him in the [__] face and
snapped his jaw they wired the kid used
to fight the substitute teachers all the
time fight the subs the subs the wait
one kid no all types of kids I thought
you there was a kid that [__] Subs like
kick him out dude but every time a lot
of Subs would have every time there's a
sub like it'd be like I'm sure it's like
everywhere it's a freefor all in the
classroom you know like people are
literally doing whatever they want
yelling at the teacher and like some
teachers are like young and they like
they like want to be slick and rebuttal
so they're like oh yeah they're like
I'll go to jail right now I don't care
and they just will just I've seen throw
desk at the teachers like all types of
[__] really yeah they they didn't care
and they would go they get they they'
like they get handcuffed taken away then
they'd be back the next day or they'd be
suspended and they'd be back the next
day they wouldn't nothing would really
happen though so that's why they didn't
really care like I'm trying to show
everybody I'm like the hardest person
out here yeah okay so John grew up in
prison guys John went to prison
Elementary I was friends with all the
people that were fighting so I didn't
need to fight that was good you ever
seen Stand and Deliver sounds like Stand
and Deliver I know you haven't John hold
on real quick we're gonna fast forward
real quick because you won't remember
that we left here here we go one time we
were in Texas when we realized you do
not have inner dialogue yes yes it's
which is crazy to me which sounds so
stressfree how is that possible he
doesn't have inter dialogue I said John
when you're looking at that wall what
are you thinking I'm looking at the wall
but what are the thoughts if you want me
to do the thoughts I'm not going to look
at the wall I'm just going to be
thinking I go so so like right now do
you like if I sing a song like is that
in your head and then can you talk to me
like no I'm singing the song I go stop
it you don't talk talk to yourself
before you say words like why would I
what you talk in your in your head to
yourself like you don't have a voice in
there no you don't have inner dialogue
and that's when we discovered why you
can't listen he can't multitask if
John's texting I will not ask a question
problem not at all I won't do nothing
I'm like oh not even looking never mind
I will not waste my time for the first
two years I'm like this F's rude as [__]
he's not rude as [__] that text looking
down thing focusing on what I'm Focus on
what's going on for sure or he's just
like would you be an amazing baseball
player and this fool just hyper focus
and crack at home runs I know we should
try it we should try you're born in
Florida you kind of look cute you never
played no baseball play baseball I play
I played baseball soccer football I did
all the sports almost get that little
voice call it's [__] funny it is
funny the voice is hilarious sometimes
like right now you guys both have voices
going on in your head while you guys are
talking I had a SAS Wakka song stuck in
my head the first eight minutes of the
show yeah I did I nine times out of 10 I
got a completely r random song that I
have no control over oning right it
started before I woke up today and it's
just going be so annoying it's the most
annoying thing of all
time and then I just had the cover of
peewee's big adventure in my head
earlier while we were talking this why
my wife gets mad at me a lot because I'm
like super stress Fe and don't worry
about anything how long did it take you
to realize that he wasn't being rude she
still thinks I'm being rude right away
you're like know he's not rude but it's
mindblowing like he can't it's
mindblowing right mindblowing it's crazy
it's kind like a brain surgeon right
like yeah I think I think brain surgeons
don't have inner dialogue either you
think about it and like you yeah they go
like all right next you're going to go
here make the that's what in dialogue is
no I don't think so holy it's amazing
though I I love it I have the worst add
in the world I'm just like what's going
on six songs what song do you want
here that's how I feel at all times like
you know you share content in cars and
you throw it to I think about what other
people are thinking a lot too kind of my
brain is kind of like sounds it sounds
like you got way too much going on up
there oh you guys are busy up there you
don't look at yourself and imagine what
you I'm just chilling up there I'm just
like on a couch watching TV that's so
sick it is sick no it is sick but the
fact that you can't remember the movie
when you're so focused on it's crazy to
me yeah it is it is crazy it's a give or
take thing it's like a superpower it's a
yeah it is a superpower it is you can
hyper Focus man really stuck with you
that are like I know these [__]
things that's a great question great
question thank
you do you have a movie you like that
like I could like tell you every scene
of your no that you like yo I've seen
that movie I know it's about oh like
Aladdin we only we talked about that
last time what do you mean last time I
said which movie do you like Aladdin and
I went yeah it's a great movie and you
said it again four months later there's
got to be a different movie it's got to
be his there's got to be another one
authentic got to be bro his brain is
like a shelf and you only have so much
[__] space on the show it's like yo
movies is this part and this is music
it's only Lil Wayne or anything with
brecks and talking about drugs and then
here's my kids Rachel and then I think
hash is at the end and that's that's it
oh yeah boxing and then boxing and the
dopest you know what me getting high as
hell yeah but like movies uh like even
one
movie it's crazy Have You Ever Seen The
Wizard of Oz yeah do you know at the end
that they like it was just a dream when
she wakes up I do remember that but I
had to think about that I got you okay I
get that it's not like you don't know
movies you just don't like oh yeah be
reminded of parts thank you okay but if
I if I'm like if I'm watching the movie
I could tell you what's about to happen
but I can't tell you if the movie wasn't
on John has a memory like the cloud and
you have to download it you still have
it you just kind of download it in and
then you could talk about it I think
that was the thanks for blowing all the
ashes straight at me you [__]
my yo memory is the cloud I think that's
that's a way to put it what about what
about TV shows there is it like
everything John watches Kim's
Convenience oh my goodness he loves it I
think some you never watched Kim's
Convenience you're going to go home and
watch Kim convenience and you're going
to call me in the middle of the night
like 3:00 a.m. like I'm still watching
Kim Kim Kardashian no no nothing at all
no it's like a that was terrible Marty
doesn't watch it it's you don't watch TV
not really still I don't even know what
we're talking about how do you have
movie references if you don't watch TV
and movies different those are all ' 9s
movies saying like you don't watch like
like you don't watch a screen watching
was done during childhood I don't watch
really much now oh wow you should go
watch Kim's Convenience it's hilarious
and the office I thought so I I known
this man for so long I just found out he
liked the office a year ago well I I got
in the office kind of like a few years
ago I just found out about it recently
crazy to me though that I didn't know
that Breaking Bad Game of Thrones
Breaking Bad uh U did you ever watch
Save By the Bell as a kid not really
okay you're you're four years younger
than me right yeah yeah almost five so
it makes sense St by the B was on its
way out yeah it was for sure okay now
what about M like let's not get too far
ahead of ourselves but music in middle
school era same music now same music now
right but who so my my my so it mainly
like little Wayne my so my my older
sister huh that's how many artists John
listens to that's not true eight and it
goes it's not true it's not true New Era
flip them now it's a little baby baby
when money made when I was younger my
sister was like really hip with it like
she she had all the music before anyone
had it like she was like on it so I used
to go to school she was you know 5 years
older than me so I was like had a an
older sister so she would help me
without all music I'd go to the music
I'd be like I knew all the little Wayne
I knew all like all like the like the
drug dealing music you know that's how
it was so that was music I got into and
just like you know nice fancy [__] and I
was just I never had nice fancy [__]
like grew up with like absolutely
nothing my mom like only reason we had
anything was CU my grandpa and then my
grandpa left us so we were just like
[__] done you know my mom did
everything she possibly could for us and
we were good but we didn't get to know
like extra [__] in life you know we
didn't like on Christmas we got like one
big toy so like a tradition like you
come downstairs and you see one toy that
was unwrapped that was like you're like
your toy that you got like so each one
of us would have like one sick toy so
have like like an electric scooter that
was like 150 bucks 200 bucks that was
like Fu to me it was like a $220,000
gift like couldn't [__] believe my
mom got me a freaking scooter like can't
believe it so that was our thing we have
one big gift we have a bunch of like you
know like [__] we needed for us so like
we never had nice extra [__] so I've
always I think that's why I always like
I think that's why I'm into it so now
cuz I've just wanted to be able to like
do whatever I want be able to get what I
needed to get because before like
couldn't do nothing like couldn't go on
a school field trip for like 75 bucks
you know like couldn't do none of that
[__] so like now it's like I think every
time I heard the rappers talking about
like the good life and like I was like
oh this is this is sick I like this you
know so I got into it where' your M go
after her dad kicked her out we uh moved
to an
apartment and uh it was like a it was my
sister was my sister was almost out of
the house she was still there um and it
was it was like it's funny cuz my my
sister my sister had uh cancer she got
diagnosed with cancer when she was 17
years old and we got we were in that we
were in that house while she had cancer
and then basically when she was done in
remission is when he like was like you
guys got to go so that planned it wasn't
like directly after but it was like you
know 6 months after like we were like
good to go now she was like probably
like all right time to go so then we
moved into uh an apartment it was like a
three-bedroom apartment my sister had a
room my mom had a room me and my little
my little brother shared uh a bedroom
and uh it was uh just like a little
apartment it was cool you know we lived
there for a little while and um I think
we lived there for a year or so and then
my mom couldn't afford it there anymore
and we moved in with my little brother's
friends family oh [__] yeah so my little
brother had like a homie that he like
played like sports with and the mom my
his mom and my mom were kind of close
and my mom she basically like yo you can
move your whole family with me damn so
we moved in with her and I was sleeping
like on a couch and I had like a a
little closet that I had I was like it
was like the it was like the like the
dining room table closet that I had to
keep my [__] in oh [__] yeah and uh we
stayed there for a minute and that's
like the last like the ending of on my
high school we we stayed there yeah oh
it's not even like you were little no
not at all
that's the worst I was little when we
had to do [__] like that yeah I was like
nine eight your dad went back to New
York City um no my dad was living with
uh with my grandma in West Palm Beach
your your dad's mom my dad's mom yeah he
he was living with her for for like a
decent amount of time and then I think
uh he he was there and then he once he
got uh he got diagnosed with COPD so he
got oxygen stuff and then when he get
that my sister heend mov with my sister
cuz my sister had her own place over
there but my dad my dad wasn't didn't
live with us for a while after that
she's been cancer free yeah she's been
cancer free for over 15 years now nice
yeah oh I sense that that yeah good [__]
what was your relationship like with
your dad through like high school and
stuff um it was kind of just like just
like little like calls and like I just
kept it cool with them you know I just
like uh like I always had like a like a
like a hate for but I was like you know
it's my dad it is what it is like can't
change the past so I just like kept it
cool with him and we we got we got a lot
really close like the past like probably
like five six years of my life we got
like a lot close cuz he lived with me
for like two years so we got to we got
to hang out and just shoot the [__] you
know he's he's he's so much fun a really
good guy just drugs [__] his life up
you know you would not know it's Dad is
it Dad if you no it's just crazy the way
this man talks to his dad it's the most
insane [__] I've ever seen in my life
they're they're repeating it back to
each other but the first time it
happened I even looked like are we good
oh my God Walk what's up you little
[__] [__]
nothing you little [__]
[__] I thought you were fighting the
first time no we're just having fun no
we just talk [__] to each other we have
a good relationship oh no no I just
didn't realize that that's I didn't know
I didn't know the first time it's like
how you talk to ratchet I talked to my
dad you know no it's not yes it is we
would be fighting no no we would be
fighting Omar would kick me in the chest
if I said a n 9% of what you say to your
dad me and him are joking it sounded
like you guys were about to fight at the
bar Oho yeah step outside you little
[__] like it's with an emphasis and
then like all right what do you want eat
what you want eat yeah we we're always
like at all times I'm I'm going pinching
his nipple I'm [__] with him I'm I'm
taking his oxygen I'm like what now it's
ridiculous bro they do unug his machine
he like you [__] piece of [__] his
little
ho what are you goingon to do now huh
huh shut up yo it's funny actually now
that I think about it it's funny to hear
it but the first time it shocked me is
he like that with everybody or is that
his Personality yeah that's his
personality too like he's very like same
guy yeah it's just it's the same you
know we're just like always messing
around having a good time you know
that's for sure us OG um do you not like
to finish your
joints hey OG do you not like to finish
your joints no not really it's like
getting to the end it's like getting to
the end John won't smoke past this what
it's BL it's just it's just tasting a
little different now you know so like
I'll roll another one that's no Thomas
has more roll as I know crazy fuest move
I ever pulled on joh will do that [__]
all the time you think so you think so I
posted on my snap multiple times this is
kind of like a roach
now I watched you roll a five G with two
gram a hat this is a roach sir and not
smoke it cuz you're like I don't really
like it well it's it's it's good no no
no but it's not like oh wow not that
it's it's that if that joint was so fire
you he no I smoked the whole thing like
halfway more
down looked to me and then hid because
she didn't want to be on anyone's side
she
went she like I don't want to disagree
with John I also want to say the
truth that's crazy are we taking the
first dab is that what's happening oh
you're just moving the ash no I'm going
to I'm going to take the first sure um
we'll get into this talking about this
in a little bit
but it's only been like 20 minutes right
it's only been 16 minutes no it's
definitely longer than 16 if you want to
look behind you it's been 16 no I'm
kiding minutes he changes so quick had
your back he said mhm you have no idea
but the raate we're going to get raided
right now right we're get swatted we're
swatting ourselves well I have a I have
a monkey on the way in
zebra what does that
mean just be fun is that like it having
to do with a raid or you just say these
words right now no I have a monkey and a
zebra on the way this fool is wild I
think his brain just went yo these are
two animals you've seen before say that
[__] and spit that [__] out seen a lot
of animals
like men in black and there's a little
dude controlling him damn that would be
I wish I could I wish could scare the
[__] out of me holy [__] scared the [__]
really it goes really quiet so it feels
like it's literally inside when I was on
that's what she said when I was on
mushrooms he was playing a little girl
going hey hey oh that's [__] up and it
was doing this it switching sides no
yeah but you knew it was I didn't know
no it was out of nowhere but like it's
never been on the soundboard before it's
when I was sitting over there too
was messing with us sorry yeah what the
hell were we just saying monkey and a
zebra I don't know what you're talking
about continue we'll take a dab right
now ready dabs back on to your dad your
dad you didn't have any relationship
after that you just kept it cool with
your dad yeah my dad saying no are you
[__] with weed during High School
where does this yeah yeah um here we go
okay yeah here we go so uh imagine this
Mark Eko
dripped it was it was it was yeah Mark
Eko and Polo oh that's right it was Polo
I was wearing Mark Eko shirts with the
guy what happened to eeko e they were
sick know remember the shirt with the
dude he had he was faceless and he was
on a bunch of different shirts that's
wild I do remember that they they had a
serious run with like
foooo crazy they had their own huge
stores and all the malls like they were
like sick dude they were were utl
unlimited right wonder if someone just
bought them and like rebranded it oh
that's what Versace is actually now it's
old
Maro continue go where we continuing I
forgot where we were at where did weed
come in the equation oh wow that was the
question I'm so happy I looked at Marty
went is you going to remember cuz I
forgot and then you said where was weed
went thank God there was a second I'm
like I know it's there I know it's there
got it so like where like I started
smoking weed or like selling you step
into high school go wow I smoke weed wow
I can sell weed and get weed for free
and smoke weed for free is that how it
started for you too uh no okay tell me
how you started smelling weed uh start
so I started selling weed because uh my
my buddy Julian you met Julian my best
man on the wedding cool eyes yeah cool
eyes yeah uh me and him would smoke a
lot of weed and we'd always be just like
running through weed so I was like yo I
was like I'm going to start selling weed
you know like I was like I was like I'm
going to get it and I'm buying like an
ounce and we'll have our little [__] to
when whenever we need it and we'll sell
it to everybody else and we can make
some money he's like oh sick do it and
and and mind you Julian is the is like
had like the wealthy family right and I
didn't but I had I was I was getting
money so I was like yo I'm going to buy
this going to sell it so I left at
Julian's house I think I'm not sure I
lived at Julian's at one point too so
I'm not sure I'm not sure which point it
was exactly but when we started selling
it it all kept at his house and every
time I'd come back to like get more weed
to sell like a little bit more was
gone and I was like this is crazy like
at the end of every single ounce was
like we were like the second or third
time weing up and I'm like just breaking
even and we're smoking for free this is
stupid you know and he's like oh well
like working I'm like no like it's it's
not working so I stopped and I like this
is this isn't like it's not for him like
it's not working out for him cuz he's
smoking all the weed and he like he's
like yo let's smoke no joint like all
I'm like all right [__] it let's do it
and I'm like it's not going good so I
stopped selling weed for a little while
and then I got with uh my buddy Nick and
when when we went to his house he was he
always had like the best weed and I was
like yo like this weed is the best we
need to like get this to everybody like
I know I know people that buy ounces so
what if we just bought like a half a
pound like a lot just broke it down he's
like yeah let's try it and it worked so
like we would I would just I had the
best weed in the entire area where did
you get the weed from what was the first
time going to buy a half pound cuz you
know you remember uh my sucks but my
buddy Josh he was he was my sister's
friend that I got that I was able to get
a hold of the older kid yeah super don't
kill my sister yeah no no I didn't care
she was cool she the second time I ever
smoked weed was with my sister ever she
she told me like you ever smoke weed you
let me know cuz it's got to be with me
first and I was like I'm not smoking
weed and then I smoked weed and I told
her she's like you smoke
me she's like get in the car we went to
the car oh nice that's a great story I'm
going to tell you about the story real
quick so we get in the car and she takes
me to this place called
uh [__] Sonic burger no no no uh Georgia
Pig it's called Georgia Pig it's his
bomb like breakfast spot in our area in
Florida so uh we're like she's like
We're going to Georgia Pig i' never been
there at that time right so we're on the
way there and we like smoke Bowls in the
backseat of the car and second time
getting high so I was so [__] up like
I couldn't even believe what was going
onz she had like really she had like
crippy is what we called it you know
back in the day that was like the good
weed the [__] my homie Joe used to call
like got some never [__] it was crippy
called it [__] the [__] oh no it's just
crippy so she had a crippy and u i was
wrecked and we and I was so [__] up
that when we got to the restaurant I
feel like it was like you know days have
gone by and she's like oh I was like
where are we going to go she's like
We're going to go to this restaurant
like no I can't go in there she's like
yeah it's it's called Georgia Pig I'm
like we're in [__]
Georgia she's like no John not in
Georgia I was like oh thank God and then
I had my my phone like had an alarm had
an alarm going off and I I told her it
was Mom calling don't answer the phone I
was like no I pretended to answer the
phone and I got her for like about five
minutes that we're caught and smoking
weed and everything and it ruined
everyone's high but I was still really
high and we get home we get into the
restaurant and my sister it was her and
her friend in the front seat and me and
they only had enough money for their
food oh so so they're like yo like we
can't get you
anything I was like you got just watch
to watch so the the waitress felt bad
that she brought me a CO slaw and I
hated klaa and I ate every drop of the
co saww and ever since then I love Co
saww I hate it I like Co saww now since
that day yeah since that day poverty
broke
you poverty broke you to like you get me
high and then you don't you don't buy me
no you know you do go hey you eat half
my
food what anything eat half of my stuff
it would have been nice right what's
wrong with it you got pancakes I know
she got pancakes I have no idea Square
out and give it to you give me give me
your whole [__] plate please no one
order a single pancake she could have
broke you off panc you could have rolled
that [__] up and it so when was that
first time though oh okay so first time
I smoked yeah like what age
um how old are you in seventh grade 14
okay what 13 I think like 12 12
12n I said that more confidently than I
was I was 9 and th grade yeah so sixth
or seventh grade I'm pretty sure it was
like seventh grade and I was I was I
skateboarded a lot back then it was
terrible stop you used to skate too I
just that was like my whole my whole for
like years I skateboarded like and I how
come John's never talk every time we
chill we're like yo let's listen to the
new Money Man song 62 other songs just
like it we're going to listen to that
we're going to watch world star fine
comps oh my God we're going to get to
that we're going to do all that and we
never talked about how we did the same
[__] growing up this is insane I used to
live in a laundry room for like half a
year with my sister I didn't know that I
thought it was just a small room I
haven't gotten to the certain places
I've lived it gets way better so so I
was I was skateboarding and I was uh I
was downtown for like we live in FLT and
you go downtown was like all the skate
spots were everyone all the skateboard
be down there and it was like was kind
of far away you know so like no one holy
[__] uh smoke the rest of this no one uh
like I couldn't tell my mom was going
down there she wouldn't let me go down
there it was like a 30- minute like city
bus ride and like it wasn't [__]
happening so we used to sneak over there
and uh one time I was over there and
everyone's like yo we're going to smoke
weed and I was like this is it it's the
time all my skateboard are friend this
is it so they emptied out a half smoked
Black and Mild they emptied out all the
Tobacco close your close your jar that's
Fu close your jar crazy it's already in
there it's already in there no it's not
yeah it is blow it
out give it to me I'll keep
the I'm sorry just just blow it all over
me
sorry I'm sorry so you guys do this over
here just blow who doesn't close the jar
I forgot we were dabbing I I lost train
of thought that that was even there okay
continue where was I at ashy OG continue
no but where was I at you were like
[__] a man skating for lale
man that's the accent y used to have
when I first met him so do y man
I man you Dad we dead man so uh we uh
there was Black and Mild they they put
it out halfway emptied the tobacco out
and filled it with wheat and we all hit
the [__] Black and Mild and I was I
was really sure I don't know why but
when I was before I ever did any drug or
anything I always thought like it's not
going to affect me I I had this thing I
I don't know what it was but like for
the longest time I was like no like I'm
going to smoke weed it's not going to do
[__] to me like I know it so I hit the
weed and I'm like skateboard and I'm
like I [__] knew it nothing shit's
nothing right I'm like it's been like 3
4 minutes now and like as soon as we had
we had to like get off skateboard to
walk up some stairs and I get off the
skateboard and I was
like mhm um this is this worked and I'm
like walking up the stairs couldn't like
I felt like I was just like like
floating up the stairs it was it was the
best moment of my life and I'm walking
and we're like downtown this area and
there was this girl that was in our
school that was like way older that
shouldn't have been there that like
dressed like an older girl that should
like just like didn't wasn't meant for
that type of like age at all so everyone
was like oh this girl's so bad this
girl's so fun everyone was all over
she's the only girl and she's older yeah
exactly so then we're like walking up
the thing and she's like there with her
mom she's like hey John I'm like hi how
you doing I'm gone I was like cuz I
thought I looked like I was a demon you
know I was probably looking completely
[__] normal and we just I just we
kept skating then we stopped again empty
another Black and Mild and we just kept
Feeling Black and Milds and smoking it
all day long and it was like this is
this is for me so every day after that
we were smoking lots of weed when the
day that you're like skateboard I'm
going to leave you here and I'm going to
go I remember the day I stopped there
has to be a day or a phase or a person
you started chilling with you're like
I'm not going to skate no more we just
was selling weed we got like selling
weed more like it was just like you
skate to drop sexs no no cuz we got I
had a car oh you had a car is what
happened yeah I got yeah I get no more
skateboard I guess I I was like one of
the one of the first people to have a
car and [__] so car you got a car you
bought it I bought a car yeah off the
weave selling yeah yeah but my my so I I
bought my first car it was uh it was an
S430 pearl white what's that a Mercedes
oh Merc S430 it's like a S-Class
basically it's like the sickest S-Class
back then your first car first car pearl
white pearl white with 22in chrome rims
and I I bought it from an auction like
someone hooked me up at an auction I
bought it for like 13 Grand and you made
13 bands in high school and saved it
yeah yeah you've always been a business
minded person I just smoke that but it's
funny so when I was I was trying to
figure out how to buy a car I'm like how
I tell my mom I bought a car it's kind
of like kind of difficult so I just uh
there was I was like kind of playing
poker a little bit and the barber shop I
was at I played a lot of poker at and I
just kind of told her that I was just
crushing it and then in one day I called
her cuz I was like I want to buy a c
like in the next next week and I called
her I had this whole plan I was like hey
Mom I'm going to this underground poker
tournament right now I'm not going be
able to call you or anything it's a 10K
buying like I told this crazy [__]
story and I called her like four hours
later like I [__] won I won 20 grand
I told her some crazy [__] so I could go
and buy a car cuz there's no way she was
going to believe that I had the money to
buy a
car did she know you were smoking weed
yeah yeah she knew I was smoking weed
she didn't care I I just so I just next
time I see your mom I'm just going to
ask
like when your 15-year-old son said yo
I'm going to the underground [__] on
card game huh and she didn't say stop I
was playing poker every night at the
barber shop like till like all hours of
the night so it was like kind of normal
to her I was you're not 29 yeah but I
was with now I was with all the older
people at the barber shop and I was like
yo they're taking me they're going to
take care of me like they're all like
big dudes they're like Dolphin football
players I was playing with and stuff I
was like yo they're they're taking to a
I get you were the small kid you were
always a younger kid knew yeah she knew
I was
good what Bronx tail movie are we
watching in Little
Haiti Little Haiti Bronx tail is what
happened to this guy hey cogal that's
you hey the legit C you but he made he
made this [__] up though
he made this a real story yeah but I
didn't really go underground K and do
that though okay but you were always
playing poker yeah I was always playing
poker yeah but when she when you told
her those are my I guar all right ready
John yeah your son 14 and A2 years from
now go you're a bus driver yo dad I'm
going to go in this underground po
tournament and you're like let me know
if you win yeah that's it if if if he's
been doing it and every day he comes
home with thousands of dollars from the
poker game and he's crushing it the fact
that your mom was like yo run it is
crazy to me my mom my mom was the best
I'm want me run the bet I'll never
forget I got suspended from fifth grade
for bringing a paintball gun to school
yeah my mom told me I could bring it but
I asked her when she was half asleep see
the key there you're an [__] so you
blamed your mom yeah it was sick so I
was in I had a you know the roller book
bags back then I had the so you're a
okay keep no I was not going keep going
so I was going to my buddy's house and
he they they did paintball so he was
like yo you come house with paintball
all right so obviously I got to bring my
paintball gun to school how going going
get it there so I want like hey M I'm
going go in rion's house can I bring a
paintball gun to school she's like yeah
yeah yeah I all right cool so I like
obviously didn't bring no CO2 no
paintballs just the gun itself right and
unscrewed in the backpack this is the
scariest part continue and I got on the
I got on the school bus to go there and
I told everybody I had it you're a
[__] I showed everybody the paintball
gun the first time he did he was I got
gun in my bag in my head I'm like I'm
like damn my mom said it was like I
don't got no [__] ammo like we're
good you know like [__] guarante that's
the first thing you said to someone I
got a gun in my back it's a paintball
gun though know that's what you did no I
got my paintball gun I'm going payall
John's [__] with these kids so so
then everything was good the whole like
you know like when you're when you're in
elementary school and you're like you at
the end of the end of the day
announcements they called your name no
no no so it's it's sitting there and
while we're doing end of day
announcements the principal walks my
classroom hey John can you come here
real quick I'm like yeah yeah can you
bring your backpack and I was like a
yeah yeah yeah for sure he's like is
there anything in there that uh I I
shouldn't know about I like no just a
paintball gun he said just a paintball
gun he says you got to come to my office
and he told me said why would you bring
this I was like I'm going to my friend's
house to play paintball after she's like
why would you bring like my mom said I
could called my mom so quick and my mom
come down and she's like I never I never
said cuz in the end of the day it's
probably looking really bad on her of
course I wasn't thinking about that I
was like I'm just going to get out of
this for sure like I'm good and my mom
was pissed and she's like I don't
remember you telling me I was like no we
were you were laying down I woke you up
and she's like you really played your
mom hard but I I almost in my back of my
head feel like I I I don't think I was
playing her I think I was I was like
genuinely maybe I was I don't remember
right ready 14 and a half years from now
your little son comes up and does that
to you you're like yo don't try to play
with me like that I know for sure for
sure for sure for
sure yo your mom and at the end of that
she's like the paintball gun you better
hit big in this poker
tournament
for real dude damn I I just see your mom
explaining why Foods break down in your
body to me over the over your Island I
never heard this part of her life this
is
crazy she was real she was really cool
for for for a long time she's awesome
I'm saying crazy like mother don't see
the other side of like no you better hit
big kid when you know when we moved into
that um the apartment after my Grandpa
gave me out that one those small
apartment she used to be in her in her
little room and just smoked cigarettes
in the room it was her thing it was the
craziest thing I ever seen she just
loves cigarettes smoked cigarette after
cigarette after cigarette I was like
this is so crazy weed in the end of that
there would never just just cigarettes
what it's insane I would go out back
smoke weed she smoking cigar oh sneaking
uh at that point yeah yeah I was still
sneaking then yeah yeah okay but she I
think she it was like sneaking at the
point but like like sne like just like
respectively like I'm going to I'm going
to not smoke weed in front of you and
I'm going to like go outside and like
try to not sting too
much but she definitely knew the deal
for sure but when I uh I had a at one
point at in um what was it
uh damn memory sucks Middle School I was
I broke my ankle doing what don't just
Glide over that you broke a thing
support your body you know in gym class
like all the floors like you could like
run and slide on them you know like
slide all like slippery so we were all
like we were planning something my class
and we were all just sliding around and
I like I hit a I was SL I went to go
slide and my left like the forward foot
went and the back foot hit a dry spot so
the back foot like this was going this
one stopped I like sat on my ankle and
snapped it and I was I was such a Class
Clown then right I was like I was like
Yo Miss re like I just [__] my ankle
she's like shut the [__] up
John bro I swear I never forget this
[__] and she's like John shut and she's
like she's like she's like you know
talking to the class on the podium and
she's like talking to everybody and
she's like oh you know I'm like no no
Miss re she like John I'm talking in the
class and I'm like no Mr Ruiz and she
didn't give a [__] until one of the
students like yo I think he's [__]
serious and she's like huh and my ankle
was literally like Snap serious snap why
did you just pick it up and dangle it
like look I couldn't I I couldn't
believe it it was did you crawl to her
or did you walk to her no I didn't move
you yelled I yelled yeah oh she she's
like shut the [__] up dude and like we
were already like in an argument like
that day like she was the art she was
like an art class teacher so I was
really like having a a good time in
there you know in the gym school gym she
was planning like a [__] pep rally we
went to the gym in the school gym like
and everyone cled everyone was supposed
to be in the in the in this in the thing
listening and I'm like me and my homies
are like sliding around not listening to
her so she's like shut up I'm trying to
do the to the teacher and you're not
listening you're a menace you the kids
that weren't listening while the while
the assemblies happen it wasn't no no it
wasn't an assembly it was a class they
moved to the gym from the art room for
some how did I miss that step okay we
just in the gym were pep Ry Johnson no
no no she's planning it it's just us
class thing we're just like not paying
attention your teacher needs a a big
stronger
backbone like yo John stop sliding
around how many of you were doing it
many like six or seven of us there's 30
kids in class your ankle a big
percentage of the class wasn't watching
no a big percent of the class was bad
our schools were not
like like good school like school was it
oh seal middle school and South
Plantation High School okay hold on hold
on we were in Anaheim at your apartment
I'm going to skip ahead and talk about
this
mhm and I'm like yo you're from like the
the racist part of the South I'm from
like the southern part I'm like from you
know from Florida I'm like like the
racist part like no I'm like what's your
town
called and I went he's all it's called
Plantation I goes shut up what is your
town called he goes Plantation Florida I
goes we're on to something come here
continue continue what you got like some
some guy in a hood on a horse is your
mascot
they're called the white Knights they're
on a horse paladins the paladins sorry
and it was a knight on a horse horse
yeah and I went okay in the school South
Plantation we're getting somewhere I'm
like what did you segregate kids like
the North and South like I went to South
Plantation I was kidding and then he
went that's R I'm like John say all
those things I think about it when he
said it I was like damn this is crazy
say all those things again I was like
did a lot of the white kids might have
go to the north side and he went I guess
yeah so so you got segregated in
2017 sick crazy 2017 no oh wait oh wait
12 2012 that's when I graduated that was
yeah that's what I'm talking about high
school middle I guess yeah wow isn't
that kind of crazy goes yeah I mean [__]
that [__]
is 1950 down there nobody else I was
like are you from this racist part and
he goes no no definitely not he had that
Dale Gribble accent still from King the
Hill from King of the Hill the one that
talk be talking fast oh no no that's
boomhower I'm sorry the one that got
conspiracies I mean I like how out of
all the rigs he has access to is this
Dino one I he's had that forever dude
here that's the dino who who makes that
puntington F and elbow and elbow that's
right that's
right oh all right hold on sorry for
everyone driving John's just ripping a
dab right now fck all
right
indeed what's up guys summer is almost
over and for all you sweaty ball ass
fools this is manscape they have twoin
one shampoo conditioner for your other
head in your life they have the crop
mops for all you fools that are just on
the go apparently and can't take a
shower a crop mop wipe your balls off
they have ball deodorant for you people
out there that just can't stop sweating
I just got back from the Bahamas I
really wish I would have brought the
ball deodorant it was hot I'm just being
honest boxers travel kits weed whacker
it's endless you already know manscaped
is synonymous this is dope as usual you
know manscapes here Platinum package 4.0
has everything you can possibly think of
if there's somebody in your life or for
yourself if you're even curious bro it's
20% off and free shipping so all you got
to do is go to manscape.com use code
Yola at checkout and that's 20% off plus
free shipping when it comes to maale
grooming manscaped has every single
thing from head to head to toe also you
can get on a subscription plan if you
like manscaped and you like this you
want it every month go to the peak
hygiene plan manscape has something for
every single dude out there there is no
excuse to be gross guys go to
manscape.com use code YOLO 20% off plus
free shipping back to the episode hey
what's up guys if you're into betting if
you're our fan take advantage of this
next deal this is one of our sponsors my
bookie and although my bookie does much
more than just the NFL it's NFL season
it's week two let's get betting so to
take advantage of this deal go to the
link in the description that's a link
right there it say my bookie click the
link it's going to take you straight to
the page and when you go to that page
use our code dope as usual and that code
is going to get you 10% bonus and a free
chip to use in my Boogie Casino so
remember this is a limited time offer so
go click the link in the description of
this video that's going to take you to
the landing page once you get there
remember sign up for your account all
brand new users are welcome just
remember if you're going to bet online
bet with my bookie just saw Packers
Falcons bills Raiders hopefully you took
advantage of this code and if you didn't
make sure you don't miss out on next
week this upcoming weekend you're going
to want to get Bing and make sure it's
with my bookie and remember guys it's
not super complicated it's not overdone
just click the link in our description
sign up for the account Marty's wife is
over here betting on everything from
college football to your favorite NFL
team just remember you can bet anything
anytime anywhere with my bookie but
remember at checkout use code dope as
usual to take advantage of the 10% bonus
and the free chip in the
casino now did you have like a shitty
weed stretch or were you still finding
really good weed in Florida in the 2000s
so the very very beginning of me smoking
it was uh it was it was definitely
shitty weed in the beginning but it was
it was like I guess like the best shitty
weed you could probably get was with
your homies and you smoking in a Black
and Mild yeah well no the fir that first
time was good cuz it was it was from a
buddy of mine that had like thank you
had like some good stuff but like when I
was like once I found out like oh weeds
for me like I need to get into this and
I started like getting my group of
friends that were smoking all the time
my buddy when my good friend's Mark uh
like one time we went over his house and
like we realized like his dad sells weed
and his dad smokes weed with us and I
was like wow this is the [__] house
it was Middle School we're talking about
oh that's when you started smoking
Middle School yeah what grade oh this
was seventh e8th grade bro I found this
this group of people oh wait we we did
talk about about it that's right yeah so
I'm I'm smoking like I'm like I'm like
like you know the weekend comes and I
like go to their house the weekend and
the dad literally just sells wheat to
all the kids it's crazy it now I look
back at it it's the most insane thing in
the world yeah so we we go to this
neighborhood and we all chill and we be
in his room [__] just playing video
gam smoking in the house you couldn't
smoke in the house anywhere at 14 15
years old D like it's illegal as [__]
Florida too oh it is so [__] illegal
at this point like this guy is like if
this guy were to get caught I multiple
things he's doing so done he'd be so
done so and I'm not like thinking how
like crazy it is you know it's just like
normal to me at this point we just smoke
all day long we we we literally just get
money from whoever we our parents I was
on hustling at that time you know and we
just buy weed from him he he'd take all
of our money from us everybody we would
all put it together and try to get more
and like he'd still only give us the
deals if you bought amounts you know
like he would just like it was crazy so
then like we'd all be hungry and and
they're like the family's like it wasn't
they weren't like wealthy at all you
know they were like they were selling
weed but they were like still poor you
know what I'm saying like just enough to
like smoke their weed and make rent and
[__] so like we weren't allowed to eat
the food no no homies were allowed to
really eat the food so like they'
sometimes bless with some food but not
we had to like pay for it the food yeah
or like do chores around the house
that's a wild house no no it's [__]
crazy that is a [__] crack house no
it it was it there's a point where like
you know like you know everyone's like
loving weed the point you know then like
some kids start like evolving to like
pills and [__] right so all my homies
started getting his Xanax and the dad
was on Xanax all the time too the dad
will get a Xanax for everybody it was it
was it was it was it was so bad really
really thinking about it so I just watch
all my friends just get obliterates so
like mushrooms Xanax like all type of
[__] mushrooms are cool but the Xanax I
never triy never did still to this day
never tried but because I've seen my
friends like they they try to fight me
on it i' throw them across the room hit
the floor and they'd be fine laughing it
off you know it's I was like this Drug's
not for me they go nuts yeah they oh
yeah they have the freakouts yeah yeah
they were and they were kids you know so
they're like they're like they would
just do a bunch of xan and then they go
like Rob cars all night and then get
caught it was crazy stupid [__] what but
in the first like you know six seven
months I was like yo this is the coolest
house ever like smoking weed with
parents and like weed's kind of good and
then there was like another weed dealer
in the neighborhood that was like a like
a kid you know probably like I don't
know how old he was at the time but he
was definitely like you know 18 1920 you
know like an older kid you look like oh
that's the kid that we get some weed
from he had the crippy and the the dad
had the regs so like when he come over
we all be like oh what's up and he give
us like a little hit of it like like
literally like we were like little
crackheads that they were helping out
and they were just like they were just
like milking kids if you think about it
like it was crazy hey want some cereal
you want some cereal clean my [__]
room no no I'm dead ass serious that's
[__] insane dude it was crazy but we
were like oh we're chilling in the cool
house and like my mom would pick me up
and you know for a fact I smell like a
[__] pound of wheed she never like
she never said said a thing like either
she was oblivious to it and I think I
talked to her she said she knew I think
she said she knew she knew but she's but
she's like you know underground poker
tournament what's about with a little
bit of weed and cleaning someone's room
what' you do I touched my friend's dad's
underwear what I was doing his laundry
and I had to hold it I was high he got
me high and then he fed me and then told
me to do stuff to his underwear I I
washed it it might sound crazy from the
outside perspective also it's a tight
chip let's join this joint is pretty
nice doesn't even move the joint yeah
we're smoking it wow so you got hustled
and you're a slave for drugs you're a
drug slave yeah yeah so so one of my
good friends I was there that kid Nick I
told you about I started s we with he
was like part of that group as well and
then we realized that uh that that
Nick's mom didn't really care too much
so we just kind of chilled over there
and she wasn't she wasn't the bound with
like she was more strict that she just
knew we smoke weed she's like if you
going to smoke weed smoke it in my house
and don't get caught outside all right
cool so we're like yo this is way better
over here we could like do what we want
like not have to do [__] so we we kind
of like came good friends and we started
we started just you know selling good
weed we had this one connect I'll never
forget dude he was uh he worked at
McDonald's this guy all right but he had
the most virous weed I still think to
this day that it was better than all the
weed now it was like you know like no
I'm telling you that the flavors he had
I don't know maybe just cuz our palor
has developed but it was incredible weed
it was incredible weed I'll take that it
was incredible it was but you'd go to
You' go to McDonald's and he would you
would just you could order all the food
you wanted and he'd give you all the
food and he come out with your weed and
everything and goes meet you with the
car like so we get like un for the food
no unlimited McDonald's he was the
manager there that's why you got hooked
on McDonald's sir yeah maybe yeah I love
McDonald's what you got free McDonald's
like he we' order and he'd be like bro
order more bro like just sitting here
bored like I'm like all right we just
order so much [__] and then he had the
weed and then we were just we was
amazing that's incredible through high
SCH what a [__] plug come on yeah it
was always we got 10 bucks we got $6 of
food I got four bucks on it you got $5
to throw on it we got to get a Swit $8
on a 10 he wor he worked like the all
night shift you know like you could pull
up like 3 in the morning 2: in the
morning you know like and he was there I
want McDonald's right now but i' still
jealous like I'm still jealous for the
younger of me like Damn you know what's
funny too my my uh childhood like best
friend growing up through like I was at
my grandpa's house for like a long time
in the neighborhood his name was Timmy
his parents owned a Burger
King we literally RI my shirt he the dad
would bring home Burger King every sing
day long chicken sandwiches every
everything you go in his fridge and they
be all Frozen Burger King this is some
[__] it was it was bad it was really
bad it was really bad long chicken
sandwiches with that big ass piece of
lettuce with my [__] goal of life I
start selling weed I C but you add
cheese though right never I ain't put no
cheese in my chicken sandwich back then
what's wrong with you I was a child yeah
yeah I get it you weren't even vegans I
wasn't even no I was eating chicken
sandwiches crazy go back to that those
were so BB should we get one right now
no I'm good they eat it for the podcast
you can eat it for the podcast like this
they don't care joh wants plant power
yeah I'll get plant power you get get
chicken sandwich for buring yo that long
chicken sandwich just meant yo your
parents are doing good you know there's
no fighting at home that's what that
chicken sandwich means why because you
can afford [__] a chicken sandwich it's
the cheapest chicken sandwich they were
for5 but isn't that like the cheapest
chicken sandwich you could get at the
time like where was going to get a
chicken sandwich for
cheaper [__] dollar chicken
sandwiches from McChickens oh that's
wrong with you you used to get them for
free so much he's like oh yeah they cost
money huh I forgot I and he whips his
hair back I forgot about chicken
sandwiches piece of [__] that's a luxury
item yeah what the hell do you remember
when Carl junor dropped that $6 burger
and they dropped the commercial
no everybody's like what sick there was
no Carl Jun in Florida oh you that's
right so I what's that
noise is that you wow my God ratchet
today dude reach into a a McDonald's
bag oh my God he was like yo actually I
do have some leftover what's wrong with
him Rosie you didn't look at him and go
what's wrong with you know he texted me
at like 12 bring McDonald I'm not coming
there hours oh he's going to throw MC
chicken no
that's what was going on you had to make
chickens still chickens are trash that's
hilarious this fool I thought a [__]
thunderstorm start was banging on the
door oh my god dude I thought your car
started okay here we go uh you got free
Mc McDonald's I'll never not be jealous
even though I [__] hate McDonald's I
want fun it's great 14-year-old's pissed
if I can butterfly effect I'll go back
and move to Florida that was like the
greatest plug I ever had his name was
Matt it's incredible Matt Matt I how
long did that last for good run it it
lasted found better weedo no no he no no
he was like he was the guy for me for a
long time and I had I think I had one
other guy but it was mainly him for like
for a long time dude long
time okay so you started selling weed
yeah
right sorry you're selling weed you're
wearing all Polo every day you're buying
you're buying a car mhm and remember I
told you one of the the car I Tred to
buy was a
a all-white Mercedes I saw from this guy
and he was like a have you ever seen
Matilda yes do you remember the dad
Danny deino he's a really bad car
salesman and he sells really bad cars to
everybody no it's a big part of the
movie um yeah anyway that's the guy
tried to sell me the Mercedes and he was
he was Mr wormwood and I went oh I can
see the signs and I backed out and I
went to work and I went there I don't
want your car same car but I mean when I
bought when I bought the car was it was
that it was an auction so so the person
had like some type of connection to
where I could go look at the car before
we bought in the auction so I went to
like the guy's house that owned it and
you pulled his house and it made me want
to buy the car so much more cuz you
pulled it it's a [__] castle like you
know the big circle driveways that's the
best one you have a tree in the middle
yeah the tree and then there's like a
huge house and he's and and every spot
is taken up by a car with some type of
crazy rims on it you know what I'm
saying like all Chrome everything and
then I get to his and I get to the
Mercedes I'm like this guy is got to be
a cocaine dealer like there's just
there's just the way it looks so bad you
know and I was like you mean the way
people look at your house continue no
not no it was chrome rims everyone 22 24
in like it was like it was like
obnoxious it's not continue but anyways
so I was like oh this guy like this is
this is I thought it was even cooler
because I was like oh this guy's like
done some [__] in this car probably you
know like he did all even cool I bet you
sold some sacks in yeah yeah I don't
know I was I was hyped so I was like all
right yeah take it so I ended up getting
the car so was cocaine just wild out
there in Florida yeah for sure yeah but
I wasn't it wasn't in my like scene at
all you know like I got like it kind of
like I kind of like got introduced to it
like later in life kind of because like
everyone was just smoking weed by me no
one was really everyone was just smoking
weed doing shrooms mainly and then like
fow some of the people were like that
the X's crowd would like eventually get
away CU they love that more but all that
smoke weed kind of just smoked weed
never like never was really into the
Coke but I I had a couple friends that
were really into it but it was like a
different group of people you know they
go to the clubs and the bars I I I'm
just trying to wrap my head around
15-year-old you gambling buying the car
I was the best gam wearing all pole you
you why were you you were a grown man
you were basically a grown man back then
well I had the reason I was gambling so
much and do because uh the guy so after
I was after I was done with hey baby uh
that one guy Matt I was talking about
weed I met this met this guy at the
barber shop he was he was one of I was
getting my haircut always at the same
barber shop for years and they got like
a new barber in and he was was like
basically just there to sell weed you
know what I'm saying like he got the job
to like get connections and sell weed so
he ended up like like taking me under
his wing I would say you know so he was
like my OG in the game and uh he was
just he was just there like really good
at cutting hair but he was just always
selling we most of the time he was
always like gone like you go in there
everyone was working he wasn't there you
know he was out like to Miami to go get
weed or something so I ended up selling
a lot of weed with him and he was he was
a lot older than me you know like
probably 15 years older than me so he
was just he was the first person to show
me like 100 BR in cash you know he was
like first person to like show me lots
and lots of pounds of weed like took me
to like when in Miami like an hour away
from where I'm at and like that's where
people would go and like you know buy
weed and I'm like it's crazy it took an
hour ride to go pick up pounds of weed
like that's insane so he'd ask me like
they used to call me jit everyone in the
barber shop was like jit cuz I was so so
young he like yo jit man come with me to
to Miami get some like hell no I'm not
risking myself for the same weed I'm GNA
get when you get back here like that's
stupid true but he just cried he always
wanted someone to come with him so one
time I finally like I'm just gonna come
and it was like the best decision of my
life because we get in the car and we go
little shitty Toyota Corolla like you
know like the gold Toyota that's just
like and there's a part bumper that's
messed up yes yes yes so that's the car
he's in right he got like 100 Grand cash
in the car to go get weed okay I was it
couldn't believe it and we go and we go
to this like we go to Miami and like
this like little like little like town
almost just looked like the ghetto you
know like you're like oh this is
different than what I'm used to and we
go in he's like wait in the car I was
like okay and he goes in he goes talks
to the guy and he comes back he's like
all right you come in and he introduced
me and it's like it's like I know like
the he Cub some Cuban guy and then he
has like he has all of like the grow
houses in all in Miami and he's like
this is like before this is like super
old times you know what I'm saying so he
was he was like the guy he was called
like uh pops was his name and everyone
knew him I guess he told me the whole
story after but he used to go in there
and he would they talk in Spanish I just
felt like I was a movie like watching
from afar and I like this little kid and
then he' come and like talk to me real
quick and he'd be like good things from
you and like okay then the grandma would
come over kids running around and then
they come and he like make a like a snap
guy would come get it and they go to a
spot and then load the car and I know
they load the car and then we get in the
car I'm like well I thought we're going
to get something he's like it's already
loaded I'm like this is so cool you're
[__] you're you're killing it this is
awesome like it was it felt like like
the real movie drug scene you know and
then we leave and we get back and I feel
like I accomplished a mission you know
and I was like I'm going every [__]
time oh hell and I went every time and
we just had never anything bad happened
everything was always good and that just
like got me into like oh this weed is
amazing so he would just he'd get a
bunch of weed and he just front it all
to me he like whatever you want just
take it so I just go and I just sell as
much weed as I possibly could and I
bring it back to him I was just loyal to
him forever so he was just always like
always kept me going I even moved in
with his with his family at one
point Jesus Christ yeah you living
everywhere man well when I when I when I
lived in the when when our my little
brother's family took us into the house
uh I I that's I was was like really
hustling like the most I just bought the
bz you know I was like really doing it
and they had uh the mom and dad at the
house the mom was super cool but the dad
was like a piece of [__] dead beat drug
addict but he was still always there
like trying to be there but he like like
we go to the gas station and like we
walk in the gas station and he would
steal everything he wanted and walk out
he'd like just watch this don't don't
trip grown ass man like 50 years old and
that's like that's type of guy he was
you know it's always a bad guy so one
day I go to like my stash in the closet
and all my money's gone like 30 grand
stop he stole all of it so I was like
I'm [__] I'm out of here so I packed
all my [__] and I left and that's when I
moved in with
um I I just lost all train thought I
moving with um your homie AP yeah I was
like y I have nowhere to go like he's
like all right he had he had a garage
and he turned his garage he put flooring
down for me an AC unit everything a bed
and he he had gave me the whole garage
and like refurbished it for me to live
in I lived there for like six months so
I get AFF my own spot cuz he took
everything I had
ah and right after that my car the Benz
so I bought it five months later the I
was I was driving I hit like a some type
of like it was like a big pothole in
like flood flooded area and like a day
after that I found out my my air ride
suspension was broke so it's it's a
basically a $5,000 fix for Mercedes so I
just paid 13 Grand for the car spent
five grand to fix it I just I sold the
car for five grand and I bought a
fucking1 1999 Honda Accord Coupe a I
went from like the biggest the biggest
dog like oh now you guys a Honda Accord
I like God I really [__] up and
everyone's like I told you not to buy
that old ass Mercedes cuz like in in the
eye it looked like a brand new Mercedes
[__] but it was like a 2006 you know
like it it was like 10 years old type
thing so it was like it was
old well that's cool so I had like a
good like five six months with it and it
broke damn okay so where are we at we're
in what age right
now that's like that's like no this like
the high school when I when I got rid of
that when I got in into the in my
buddy's house then okay so that's where
we're at you used to wear a lot of Polo
they used to call you Polo at school and
can you show us your Blasphemous ass
tattoo or is going [__] your shirt it's
not blasphemy it's great it's incredible
I just have a right here it's Jesus
Christ on the cross no he's carrying the
cross carrying cross wearing Polo slides
yeah he has the slides on and they have
the polo logo I was always told that
like you po logo how are you perceived
how are you perceive Jesus is is who he
is to you you know ice what do I always
say killing in the FR I respect that you
don't remember what I always say to you
when you say I perceive my Jesus like
that and I think my Jesus singing lead
vocals that FL skard that that's all I
think of every time my Jesus is doing
this my Jesus is an arm robber so the
ski mask is on him that's the kind of
things that John is that okay
it's my body my rules that's how I feel
about that it's crazy John hit the roach
ass of this thing oh that's heating it
up yeah so you have to use a
torch disorderly conduction disly
conduction it's control tower control
tower yeah so it keeps it hot at what
degree and you put it straight on and
just ready to go oh you're about to turn
Mar into a [__] monster he looked at
that Mar's next it's getting he up oh no
so you have to use a torch yeah he's all
for it he just started getting in dabs a
little bit this whole box is just the
heated or there's the box is really like
this
you can still open this and put a banger
and put a bong and rig in there and
stuff it's perfect it's perfect it's
cool okay John was considering the audio
issues I'm
like know create we appreciate that DJ
Cal knows his Beats and his
production equip it so continue where we
are in high school you're selling weed
you get robbed which sounds terrible
what did you ever hear from him again he
just dipped out forever no they they
said no they didn't do it oh yeah of
course they did yeah and the mom was Rec
cooling she's like no I talked to him he
really didn't do it I was
like is the money lost in the closet
it's not very big so I was just like I'm
out G yeah never saw him
again how long did your mom and
everybody live
there
um not I don't really I couldn't even
remember to be honest not too much
longer
though they ended up moving out and
getting their own spot
too did they know about the money yeah
yeah they knew yeah but my mom like
couldn't really do she was she was sick
you know she couldn't believe it and
she's like you know I was like it is
what it is you know [__] should have
kept it in the safe shouldn't have kept
it in my jacket pocket in the
closet I mean I was at [__] I don't
know you know I just thought they they
were like they were like family to me
you know like yeah jacket pocket in the
closet I used to hide sodas at my jacket
I only had a 2 by two closet and half of
it was their [__] and I had this little
section to put my clothes and my shoes
his clothes on oh it's not my oh I'm
gonna go smoke it no he just definitely
knew I was making money you know that
was the problem and he was like ah I
[__] take
that well that's cool live and you learn
yeah put a huge [__] loss yeah it l
it was [__] ridiculous back then I
couldn't I I was broken sick
yeah okay and you had to go find
somewhere to live now right basically
yeah yeah exactly but I I had a lot of I
bounced a lot I've been to like I've
lived with like three different my
friends and like and then my my buddies
like four different places I've lived in
here and there when my sister had cancer
I lived with my my buddy Julian me and
my little brother moved to his house for
a while myom was basically like living
in the hospital oh okay you know and
then and we got homeschooled that time
too what who was your hes school teacher
no no it was on it was online homeschool
stop you mean no school it it was it
didn't make any any sense no schol you
had the test and then you had another
tab open of Google to ask the
test of course it was
ridiculous it was really bad but at that
you know at that time when I lived with
uh that family uh my mom my my grades
were getting kind of bad they were just
like slacking off a lot and my mom's
like it's cuz you smoke so much [__]
weed yeah I was like no like the weed
helps me like if I go to school I way
better she's like you're an idiot y y
and the mom like the the other mom that
lived there she's like yo like she was
cool like we we'd smoke weed together
and she's like she's like no like she's
like why don't you why don't you put
them to a test and she's like what do
you mean she's like for this quarter
like he's not allowed to smoke weed near
us at all like obviously he's still
going to smoke it but just don't let him
smoke it near us at all and she's like
okay and she's like the next quarter
have him smoke weed before he goes to
school and before he does his homework
and see if he's he's
true this [__] gets free
McDonald's hold let's backrack it this
fol gets free
McDonald's and then they're running
experiments on
him challenge AB test they're running
experiments on him hey son I need you to
get high as hell so I can prove to you
that you well this is my mom would never
do something like this ins but she
really trusted like she took a lot the
lady said you know cuz was like she was
helping around she's like all right well
she's like a more younger Hip Mom so it
was like it was like the old school
versus like the younger you know so she
was like all right let me just take her
advice so so we did that and the quarter
that we smoked weed my mom would take me
to the bus stop and I'd smoke a joint in
her car get out and I get out and go to
the bus and then I got home before I did
my schoolwork I
smoked and that quarter every single
grade got was up a letter and she was
just tried dur yeah yeah yeah for sure
she was like you can smoke as much weed
as you want whenever you want I'll never
say anything ever again about it I was
like wow I went to the other mom I was
like you crushed that you [__] killed
that but you stole from me now so I
don't like you anymore but you stole
from me yeah it was it was a dope
experiment this sounds made up but I
know it's not it's just the dumbest [__]
I've ever heard it's crazy too cuz my
mom is not like would you would never I
talk to your mom when I see her tonight
probably or
tomorrow I'm really going to ask her I'm
going to ask her because you missed it
you walked out of the room when he
talked about the
experiments he get free McDonald's and
two joints a dayon never getting over
that one two joints a day like how like
kids give their like uh or parents give
their kids like rid and [__] or
whatever backwood with his M yeah yeah
yeah yeah literally it was it was it was
insane damn okay continue continue here
we go you graduate high school and
you're out now what are you doing still
selling wee but in your own spot yeah
yeah so I uh I see right out of high
school we just me and my buddy got a
spot an apartment
and I was just still selling me with my
buddy that took that took me in that end
up getting his remember I I was in I was
in the guy's uh like garage for a while
I graduated got out of his garage got to
an apartment with my buddy and my buddy
like didn't really have any money so I
paid for everything to get in and then
he would just keep up with rent and he
like clean the house really good really
good guy we would we would uh you know
remember back in the day when you was
first stabbing and you have like the
reclaim like it was a drop down and then
there was the reclaim thing so he would
he didn't really he just liked getting
high didn't really care about the
quality so he would just like every
morning go in and just email dab oh the
biggest dab of reclaim you could
think it was the most incredible thing
you could ever see he like we'd be there
with all my friends like all the best
[__] on the table and he'd be like uh
he'd be like just go and get the reclaim
we be like y you could just dab any of
these like n that's
cool cool
reclaim damn so hold on so by the time
you're out of High School you're already
[__] with dabs and [__] yeah okay so
so dabs came in uh before I left High
School it was uh was probably junior
year sophomore junior year and uh it's
crazy I haven't even gotten into that
part yet but uh my my uh my buddy Nate
we uh his he had like a he his his
parents knew we smoked weed but it' be
in the garage right so be in the garage
is like his own like little layer it be
like a couch TV you know it was like uh
almost remind you of That 70s Show
garage epic exactly like that okay and
the parents come down once a while but
never really right and uh we just be
chilling there getting hot all the time
and um uh someone had like we started
like the talk of dab started coming up
like in the industry you know on
Instagram and [__] and uh I was like bro
we got to get some dabs and he's like my
my boy's like no we'll make it ourselves
and I was like huh he's like yeah and
like I'm going to I'm going to figure it
out like we're going to make it
ourselves I was like all right cool so
he did little research and we went to
like the smoke shop we got like a little
glass
tube made a we made like a a purging
thing out of a pot and like a Pyrex and
drilled holes in it put a little thing
there old school yeah the old school so
we did all that right and uh we [__]
we I'm sorry we didn't buy the purger
yet the first time we just got the tube
and blasted on the hot dish the first
time no no we didn't even build a purger
yet it was there was no purger the first
time we blasted it oh so we just blasted
it onto the hot dish and we whipped it
up real quick and we dab on the hot
plate I thought it was the best thing in
the world oh my God so so real quick
with the weed right I love smoking weed
but the biggest thing for me is like the
like the bong smoking always tasted gr
remember I tell you always tasted gross
to me joints like I always rather
smoking joints but it's still like never
like I was always like missing I always
wanted something tasting better always
so when I hit a dab it like changed my
life and I was like yo this is how I
want to smoke forever like the way the
way I got high cuz like we didn't get
high anymore cuz we smoked so much
[__] weed like our goal was just to
get as high as possible you know like
everybody so we we smoke two three face
joints in a row like every [__] day
like so like at the point we're just
like not getting high so I hit that dab
and I got high again I was like was like
this is like this is the best [__] ever
so then like we got more into it the
next time we did a run we we made that
purger and we made the purger we made
some shatter I was like yo this is this
is it so me and my boy made a company
which I'm not going to say the name of
why not because it's not time to talk
about the name time I already said it no
you didn't but we made a so we made a
company and uh this is like before like
anyone was really like on Instagram
doing [__] like it was like very few
people was like you saw someone doing it
they were doing it like you know like
you're like oh dop is Yola's post this
weed is nuts or there like a couple
people that were posting weed but they
were all in California like no one in
Florida would do [__] like that it was
like very few people starting to like
post [__] here and there so we made a
company made a design and everything and
we started just [__] blasting oil
like all the [__] time it was like
blasting oil blasting allil little
little things we make pictures and we
started like getting a pretty good
following on Instagram and um it was
going really good and uh my eventually
was I finally I finally was like got my
own place and then didn't even to go to
his garage anymore and uh we basically
just start I started blasting oil at my
house and I bought one of those big ass
AI ovens yes okay so that was that's
when I thought like I was like oh this
is like next level [__] so I bought the
AI oven and I lived in apartment at the
time third story gross and you had that
in there so no I had it on the balcony
was uh if if you go on the balcony
there's a closet and the closet had the
washer and dryer outside so I put it
inside the closet on top of the washer
or on top of the dryer so i' I'd be on
my b balcony blasting oil with that with
a big ass glass tube like I'm talking
about like like 3 4ot glass tube i'
stuff it with the best weed you could
find cuz that's another thing everyone
that was blasting oil was blasting trim
I didn't even have access to trim so I
couldn't get it if I wanted to so it
wasn't even an option to me so I was
like we were always blasting nug so all
the all the all the dabs in Florida were
all like you know stuff from California
and [__] no one really made it and it
was all like really nasty [__] it was
all like trim and so like I was like
kind of ahead of my time you know no one
really understood why I had this like
clear shatter that like taste is good
and like no one understood it but
because it it was nug and I was paying
like $3 $4,000 for a pound of weed and I
was blasting it you know like it was
unheard of so we started doing that and
it ended up you know blowing up pretty
big and my boy ended up kind of just
like doing his own thing he he stayed in
his garage didn't really come to my my
apartment anymore so I kind of just like
doing it by myself and um I had a I'm
sorry were you charging way more like I
was charging $100 a gram for pH sh
and it was like back then it was a lot
too back then it was in everyone was
selling for like 60 bucks you know which
is still expensive but it was it was
like [__] so I had the [__] that no one
had so I was like I'm going to charge
what I want for it m so then um we uh
had you know a couple couple of my
friends I was never like so you know
that there's like the Instagram
community and like the the Wii Community
Ione like got together in SES I never
was in that so I was making oil with
just like the homies so like there was
people that knew my Instagram but I
didn't really never linked up with
people on Instagram never did any of
that so I had one homie of mine um
name's Dylan and he was like a younger
cat and I was uh it was someone that
like I just you know served oil too and
chill with a lot and uh one day he tells
me he's like oh I just got back um from
this this uh one of this one of this
girl I followed is now my wife but I
followed this girl on Instagram and he
was like yo I just got and she was like
she was like the like the girl on
Instagram that like had the good weed
and the good Edibles like all the [__]
that like people couldn't get she had it
so everyone you know followed her and I
was following her and he was like yo I
just went to her house yesterday I was
like damn how the [__] did you go to her
house he's like oh you know one of my
boys you brought me over there and like
we're all kicking it there's all people
from Instagram and I was like I don't
can I can I come and he's like yeah for
sure like I told her I knew you like we
can come up so we went over there and uh
I met Rachel in her like 2 by two
apartment it was like really small and
uh back in the day like I always like I
greet a girl and like kind of kiss him
on the cheek it was like kind of like a
thing I always did so I that's how I did
with her and I guess she's never had
that before cuz she was [__] you
know what I'm saying
so yeah so she so
she Marty an hour 32 minutes to Zinger
just came in hard it's been an hour and
32 say it's been that long and this
Zinger it took that oh o Mar had to get
warmed up dude no not even that like
there was a perfect up that was a Zinger
for the of Lifetime thank you I was
thinking about April Mason me when I
said it Jesus never mind it was this
physical and domestic violence that PTSD
Marty I'm sorry I thought it was
thinging he was just talking out loud
continue I'm sorry I'm dead and you ciss
you Chief because [__] [__]
yeah so uh so then we're chilling
whatever and uh she has a boyfriend so
like obvious I wasn't like even thinking
about like oh and she's like super older
than me and I was like obviously old
she's like six years older than me that
is not a true statement you don't know
how old your wife is 6 years older than
me I'm 4 and a half years older than and
years old and she's younger than I am no
she's not yes she
is five years old five years I thought
was four and a half my bad five dude
five John's 19 guys and you're you're
younger than we
right overs I'm 16 Thomas never mind
continue wrong continue um I forgot give
a [__] a dab name Marty yeah
yeah I got you right so he can not cough
and have no reaction and you think he's
not going to cough to Marty has no
reaction
toist he talks about this a lot dude oh
God like you own dad the substances they
don't matter to him you know what
substances are do you know what
substances are cornerbacks to Marshall
Hulk they're bouncing off I like that
take that okay all right you know to do
this right that's a glob okay maybe he
might cough he might cough I usually
[__] with the puff go but I can figure
it out oh that is called the Carta don't
[__] this not
pu I know you do never giving you a
p take that that is the cleanest I have
ever never seen and just now now just
hold the bottom of the long time dude
you got to go in there there you go get
the cap form he's got he's already
capped get it all on there now that's a
DB you got to put that you got to put
this back on there man let me help you
out Thomas really thinks this guy's
Invincible I'm tell it's the angle of
your rig is is the craziest angle too he
asked for it like
that there we
go stop
I saw Marty cough off the first pool for
the first time of my life go
ever weird angle it was the weird angle
huh no don't give him that dude I'm
telling you cuz now look at him now look
at him yeah hold on hold on experiment
before you do your homework and after
you do your homework you're going to
take a dab and then we're going to stand
up and then we're going to sit down
stand up okay that's what we're going to
do your mom I can't I'm going to talk to
her I'm going to kill her I'm going to
talk to her eye that just looks like my
eyes on there it's all blue and scary
okay sorry go hey what's up guys taking
a B for this awesome long ass episode to
talk about one of our new sponsors
couldn't be more stoked and that is raw
papers as you guys know raw papers and I
have a long history and this is
unbelievably cool to be able to have raw
as a sponsor on the show we read the
comments guys we see it everybody long
time coming this is perfect couldn't
have been cooler this is the best match
thank you guys for being happy for us
also raw giving that's their charity and
for anybody trying to buy for the for
their stores their smoke shops hbi
International that's how you go check
out a wholesale go to your smoke shop
and tell them hey we need want more raw
stuff and I guarantee you they're going
to get it cuz it's going to sell there's
hats helmets there's five joint smokers
there's twot challenge cones it's
endless also if you're on Instagram go
to rawlife247 check them out go ahead
and follow them I know this is a super
long ridiculous episode with John but we
just want to say thank you to Raw thank
you for sponsoring the show thank you
for sponsoring us until NE we're into a
year guys we're going into 2024 with raw
as our sponsor we're the ambassadors
thank you so much have a dope ass day yo
guys check this thing
out feeling dangerous so the clip you
just saw was from my Tik Tok I posted
that and thousands of people asked me
where do I get this how do I buy this so
right now if you want to take advantage
of this go to Hamilton devices.com and
use code dope as usual for 15% off 15%
off of this right here this is the
butterfly from Hamilton devices the
butterfly is one of many items that they
have on Hamilton devices.com it's
actually insane how many things they had
so go ahead and check out Hamilton
devices.com remember use code dope as
usual and you get 15% off if you want to
try this out 15% off and you're helping
out the sponsors of the show that are
supporting our show this is a huge
version of this this right here is the
kr1 this is a bubbler for concentrates
it's two in one double cartridge 2in one
bubbler it's just like this but with two
and it's a bubbler it's non-stop also if
you want to see how these things work
scan the QR code goes right to a video
and showing you how it
works you go dope as usual at Hilton
devices.com for 50% off back to the
episode I guess I kissed my wife on
cheek she ain't never had no kiss on
cheek like that boom she has a boyfriend
like um yeah so she had a boyfriend over
her yeah hold let's wait till you're in
this microphone's V doing something one
second yeah I know I'm surprised you
even spoke while doing something uno
momento we're getting some traction here
on camera John just evolved he's to the
average human he's alcoholic his Banger
in between each time yes before we get
more into this I feel like we're not
intoxicated enough at all waiting for
you
so da you guys are trying take dabs I'm
trying to smoke you got like a little
like a little never mind what you trying
to chug a syrup I thought I'm not going
to chug a syrup just chug it just chug
the syrup I think you should just chug
it but this this interview might end
no we're done right this interview might
end immediately as soon as John he's
very scared sounds like a good idea he's
a he's scared of getting high often he
casually just throws these things back
around the house while he's he actually
just opens it and swallows the whole
thing like a Tylenol it's going to
dissolve list I'm just going to I'm just
going to uh pour one in here and then
drink that drink that do that I want to
see it and then Marty will drink his
because he's not soft
m
was that you making the noise or you it
was you Marty I thought it was you wait
so Mar you should have put one back
that's how I do it mar Just chugs it on
the no not on the freeway Marty just
chugs it at home so continue how you
stole a man's
girlfriend no didn't do that I'm going
to steal your girlfriend and make her my
wife if you do on a horse as a knight
what was your mascot name Paladin that's
a paladin it's a paladin like I'm going
to take this blonde woman for
mine and procreate you have to start
speaking in the English voice for the
rest of this episode all right poor that
that looked bomb I'm going to be honest
it looks incredible that looked so bomb
let me
get that let me get that no no no no no
this is mine all four I'm putting all
four in that's not true you don't think
so no Marty are you chugging one of
these Che one surprise me surprise me
give him blue to match his soul boom let
me watermelon Lemon Cherry I
figured hey thanks okay you're welcome
continue um yeah boom so you were oh
yeah so stealing a girlfriend yeah we
were there um brought my uh shatter in
but hold on you mentioned this kiss like
it was something oh it was magical yeah
yeah oh it was magical oh okay so it was
a good moment well yeah it was a great
moment well one because fine ass girl
from Instagram right I was like wow this
is crazy got her
off camera he's told me the story one
time at breakfast with that old man was
helled her birthday by himself yes yes
wow that's how do you remember that
remember I do remember now and he went
and I thought damn she's the plug oh
yeah yeah yeah she was I'm trying to get
connect and then I was like and she's
pretty so I went over there and I was
like oh that's what I do I kiss girls on
the cheek and obviously you ain't never
had that done before that's never had
that he was explaining Hospitality [__]
that you know you just get away with
um that's crazy I like poured it and
then just put it down right you're going
to talk [__] it's okay I wasn't going to
talk [__] her boyfriend was are you guys
both just chugging okay you're put a lot
of water bro you should pour some of
that out it's a lot it's like you're
diluting it a lot it's the same amount
getting chugged no that's not that's
like saying that's like saying mixed
drinks and shots are the same
thing stop same amount of liquor is
going to get into your body no hold
on you're telling me right if you have
the D no arguing right if you that was R
I knew it was coming broken something's
going to happen so let's say you have
you have a cocktail with two shots in it
okay and you drink that and you take two
shots okay same amount of
intoxication
yeah why wouldn't it be it's just not
cuz it's diluted I guess still going
through your blood no but it's but it's
going through diluted I I guess yes for
sure oh no we should we
should this one know water it down and
then drink it it's different than just
drinking it at once cuz you're get 100%
different percentages of why do you
think I put it in here I'm scared Thomas
guess that's like me saying yo I'm going
smoke two grams of hash in my weed it's
going to be
diluted I'm still smoking the hash yeah
it is you no you definitely you're
definitely not getting as high on that
half a gram of rosin that's in that
joint that you just smoked a half a gram
on a
nail I get that versus the nail I get
that but that's dilutes same thing I
guess I feel like it doesn't wow
sounds did you see me just prove Thomas
wrong well I mean and he and he admitted
like he was like oh you're right I just
don't know I guess no no that was that
was a [__] we need to ask a Google
ask a Google person moment ask a doctor
that ask a doctor call my sister oh yeah
after this let's call and BTS it she's
going to be like well I mean you're
still getting two gram of morphine in
your body whether or not you chook some
water with it no I'm hoping that's what
she say IV drip you know like all the
all the all of it's like in there and
diluted it's not just like a straight
drip into you now you just made it sense
boom all right well hold
on I'm still going to chug it though I
was still going to chug it I just don't
want to chug the syrupy syrup but are
you really going to chug that I was just
going to chug it immediately the whole
bottle just change it on me right now I
was just going to chug the whole bottle
you see he flipped me right now right oh
have you have you edited our Vlogs
before I chug the bottle and talk [__]
you drink it very quickly insanely fast
like three four sips for sure within 5
minutes
but you see his shit's already done in
his system flowing I get that and you're
going to be the one without it I drink a
little bit oh you
[__] we could have all just done that
we could have done thatal you didn't
make me though it's okay diluted is it
diluted cuz I drink water after yes
supposedly everyone tells me that's why
I can uh drink so many shots because I
drink a chaser after every shot a little
water after so we're techically diluting
it you're soft is what I just
heard ready that was a that was a
slight almost like an educational lesson
I'm not sure I don't know who it makes
sense on the IV drip [__] though 150% I
was a good it do good example but like I
was just going to chug it if you're
going to just chug It Anyway then so
somebody like just squeezes your IV and
it all shoots into you fast is that
still
diluted do you see what I am saying do
you know what I am saying saying
continue on stealing stealing your way
go continue on stealing your way oh my
so he goes over there like I need a plug
oh wow you pretty um yeah yeah so uh we
were dabbing and stuff and she had like
these gummies that everyone wanted that
time it was like these Edibles everyone
wanted so we like did like a trade for
like my oil and her gummies because no
one wanted to pay the everyone over
there never heard of oil that price
because they're like actually in the
community and actually like you know
know what's going on so they were like
you're a dumbass like you're not gonna
get that ever and I was like all right
cool like then don't [__] buy it you
know and every time then they dab that
everyone loved it so then she got it and
traded me but she paid [__] pennies
for the gummies so she she sold my [__]
for
pennies and I was like what the [__] is
wrong with you you that's not how this
works here you know and she's like oh
you know I'm just flipping [__] that's
what I do I'm like oh great cool it's
amazing so uh next time the next time I
went over there uh I went over there
like 2 3 days later and her boyfriend
wasn't there and uh damn what happened
oh I went to so there was a bunch of
kids we met there and they're like all
live in in the apartment area I was like
I went to the the kids house we're all
chilling there I was like oh where's
Rachel and she's like oh she went home
to go put makeup on because she heard
you were coming I was like oh fire I got
this girl I'm in there I'm in there this
is fire cool cool so um so she came back
and we started talking whatever and then
we started talking and basically her
boyfriend was a p [__] and like was a
piece of [__] to to like everyone in
front of her it's like it was it was bad
so uh that's the best scenario to come
into yeah yeah it was some sa you know
Captain you know Captain I want to sleep
on my bed tonight Captain I want to go
home so uh with that story John's at a
strip club in a in a one way in a oneway
mirror right now like I can't say or do
anything that's pretty much how he feels
oh she's Captain say
just that [__] just trailed off continue
beat his ass Captain Save a plug there
you go Captain Save a plug so uh so at
this time too uh she thinks that I'm the
plug you know so I think she's the plug
she thinks I'm the plug when I'm [__]
not I'm like I'm just blasting some oil
selling a little bit of weed I just got
robbed by my I thought my [__] yeah
you I'm saying like I'm not I'm not that
crazy you know so uh we we end up like
he hanging out a lot it was getting kind
of weird cuz like we were talking a lot
then like her boyfriend was there so it
was like it was not good you know was
like we're just kind of talking she
didn't really know how to leave her
boyfriend at the time so we'd be like
we'd be like at the we'd all be dabbing
at the at the like like like 30 kids at
the table we'd all be dabbing and she'd
be like under the table like kicking me
trying to touch me and her boyfriend's
right next to her I'm like oh it's bad
you know I'm going to for sure have to
fight this kid eventually so then uh she
ended up uh at my house all the time you
know I was with her we were just doing
our thing um having a good time time we
like Went to went to Colorado when I
first met you we'll get to that oh yeah
um and uh she event she eventually was
eventually like the the the boyfriend
you know figured out like it's done and
uh she it was just it was just bad the
guy was like trying to like trying to
send people to my house trying to do
thisy they were just doing the the most
[__] cuz he was just mad that obviously
I took his girl which obviously makes
perfect sense you know just I would do
the probably the same same amount of
thing sucks but uh yeah it definitely
sucked but but she was definitely uh
mine at the time so it was it was over
at that some caveman [__] yeah yeah yeah
but but your life is mine but you know
what's funny so when she left him she we
we were together but we we were like we
were just best friends for like eight
months CU I was like a this girl like
left her boyfriend for me she going to
leave me and do the same thing I don't
want to date you yet her and friend all
my all my friends are like dude like you
know she can do the same thing to you
right I like I was like [__] makes sense
right like makes perfect sense so I'm
like [__] and so like we I just like
kind of kept it like not official you
know and then it got to the point I was
like yo this
is this is obviously this is obviously
for me you know like I really like this
just like the guy was like a piece of
[__] you know it all ended up working
out so I was like like made it official
after like eight or nine months of us
being like best friends like that's what
you meant well like when we met you we
weren't really dating yet yeah we
weren't cuz we met the same weekend yeah
I when went in Colorado we weren't
together wow wow yeah okay and then went
to Colorado that that's when I had my
you know I had my company I was like
trying to promote it as much like K we
all wearing the shirts and stuff and
we're walking up to the Cannabis Cup it
was the first Cannabis Cup first
anything I ever did like weed weed
related and I was a big fan of uh this
one [__] weirdo online he was about
to say one [__] loser he was about to
say it he was about to say it and I
heard
hisou but uh no was I was a huge fan of
Thomas's I was a huge fan of yours and
uh I I'm walking up and I'm like holy
[__] it's [__] dope as Yola I was
like I need to give him a guy a shirt
right now so I ran up to him introduced
myself gave him a t-shirt told him and
you know talked for a second and then
you went your way I went my way went the
cup and the whole time I'm like just
talking about like yo like I came here
to promote and like I just did the
biggest [__] I possibly could have done
before I even got to the cup so like I'm
like I'm on I'm on like I'm Cloud I'm
good you know I'm like I'm like I'm
thinking oh my my shirt's in Thomas's
hands I made it you know but like for
what for what you know it's cool so I'm
having a great time and we go by the
booth and he like remembers me we we
talk we smoke a little bit and uh it was
a good time so then like when we left
I'll never forget it I was like yo like
wonder when he's going to Poe my shirt
like when he's going to you know post my
shirt you know refresh refresh yeah like
all the time I'm just like wait I'm like
waiting for I'm like this is my moment
you know like this is this is what this
is what people wait for you
know nothing I was like this mother
[__] I'm like yo Rachel this guy sucks
gave him a [__] medium shirt he's a
4X and didn't didn't [__] post it
like what the [__] is going on like this
is [__] what he doesn't know is it
did get posted and he was folded in my
hall picture [__] whatever I'm just
let you know how I felt you ready my
perspective ready my perspective guy
gave me a medium and I went oh man I
can't wear that but I'm going to keep I
kept it for almost 6 years then I move
into LA and I'm like I got to not take
all of these weed shirts even fit me
that guy was
cool I was like I'm going to wrap it up
man like I can't just hang on to
everything like I got rid of a bunch of
[__] before I ever really knew John just
got rid of my [__] I kept it for six
years I love the design yeah yeah yeah
yeah this was this this what's canas cup
you'll know the year 10 14 that's so
weird I can't think about my life depend
on it so 2014 we probably didn't really
start start CH until oh 2018 17 is that
when we moved to oh no 16 when do we
move to LA
16 16 yeah so 2016 it could have been
only two years later just seemed a lot
longer back then why did it seem like
five years back then it was it was you
know now we're just like it's been a
long time we've been through a lot of
things a lot of years you know back then
it was like damn why did I think it was
six years oh we've lived here for six
years yeah that's that's maybe that's
that's the thing I remember I was still
living at the push trees house when I
had it and I was packing up to move to
the Poppy Hill house I was like I'm
going to take this shirt mhm so my
perspective [__] my perspective is
this and it it post it you dick I posted
thank you guys to every single person
here appreciate it posted a bunch of
stuff people gave me and the shirt was
folded with the I couldn't see it though
animal showing we'll just say that
continue but uh so we had uh we did the
uh the oh the next time I saw him was
[__] it was like uh we were in
Downtown LA and I was I was I didn't
live there yet I was just taking trips I
was taking trips out to LA a lot and I
was uh I rented this like Airbnb was
like the sickest Airbnb ever next time
oh the next time I think it was another
year
later another C cup and we were in a
lounge where we threw like a party and
you guys pulled up with mad different
cookie G gsse flavors remember that you
came up with hella of different weeds I
was like oh it's John oh give me a shirt
I'm like oh the princess dabs chick I
like oh they're dating now what
it was a lounge but we did like a
party there was a lot of people in
Denver there yeah buoy was there it was
a lounge oh it was where all the all the
bongs were out everyone had the rigs out
all the AKs and stuff it was uh when uh
Lions it was like a darker Lions yeah
yeah yeah it was it was it was a darker
spot it looked like the lighting kind of
sucks yeah that is that's crazy that's
the next time oh yeah oh they're dating
now I remember that and I was like oh
cool yeah yeah yeah I remember we talk
each other a few times I remember you
remember who I was and I thought was
like oh super cool I remember who I was
meets a thousand [__] people a day
just like everyone [__] knows Thomas
you know so uh so then but the next time
we like chill only time we still never
chilled at that point we were just like
passing by saying hello the first time
we ever chilled I remember we we were in
uh I was I was it was the last time I
was coming out to LA before I was going
to move out there I was in I was in I
went to this airb be in like downtown LA
and I thought it was the sickest air
beam be ever and uh I was like trying to
figure what to do and I just like got a
bunch of like I got a bunch of Professor
sift rosin that's not what happened yeah
you hit me up hey how you doing how you
doing I'm like hey what's up man how you
doing you still in Florida no but I had
it I got the I got little bit of Ros has
weho and then you brought profess he
brought all the Ros what happened yeah
is this guy hit me up and he said hey
I'm I just moved to LA I go for real I
there I was there you said hey I I'm
here now I'm living out here like yo I
just moved out here was two weeks before
you textt me I had just moved there to
the met and we we were just walking
around downtown doing everything eating
that uh uh Pizza next door that place
his bomb and then this hits me up and he
goes yo I moved and you sent me the
address to go bro you're one block away
from me shut up you want to chill oh
yeah yeah yeah that's what it was and I
went up and I'm like yo this place is
sick and yeah and I'm like and you
wouldn't go on the balcony hell no you
wouldn't go on the balcony I was like no
I'm good exactly he like oh it's all
glass over there but it was it was it
was a that I'm not that day was like
insane to me cuz like you were there
Professor Siff was there yeah cuz you
can you get some rosin I go you want
some rosin sh EXP if he's like here's
400 I want to get some rosin you know
Professor sift I want to get it I'm like
yeah you want to spend $400 on some
rosin right now and that's back when
like I'm like I would never spend over
that much money on some ra now it's like
oh let me get an ounce of Ros but that's
before like dude I dabs I got shatter
slaps for $8 and gram or whatever it was
yeah and then I got that brought it back
Professor sift came over and then go
sorry that's exactly we just got h we
got high all all night all day it was it
was hours we hung out for hours and I
was like wow this is [__] crazy and
then you know we we all just chilled and
then then I moved there
officially into a spot and I mov there
officially into a spot and then we we
[__] I and that I don't remember what
happened after that I just know we were
just chilling every day yeah you were
like one of the only people I knew other
than buoy out here and buoy was always
like doing something busy and you were
just like vibing getting high like doing
some clothing [__] you know and we we
were just like I would make I'd make
some rosin and you'd be chilling making
clothes yeah it was kind of odd how it
happened for sure we start chilled every
single day and then I wasn't productive
at all no we were we were both very
unproductive but we were doing but we
were still build trying to build a we
were trying to do stuff and it was like
it got to the point where I told I think
I told Marty where I was just taking all
the push trees orders to your house I do
them there like I'll just chill at your
house yeah I like bro go get your [__]
done like no we didn't do nothing
productive at all
yeah it got bad got to a point like yo
we we got to stop chilling all day every
day yeah we're just doing absolutely
nothing absolutely nothing we're
watching world star Vine cops we're
watchings lot of dope [__] is world star
still relevant to people today or is it
some Boomer [__] that people don't watch
anymore I feel like people don't watch
anymore what's what's the current world
star Twitter Twitter Bar St like that's
what people bar what's the page oh I
don't know see it's not really a thing
anymore yeah it's not it's not like it
used to be I feel like now people are
just like on like Twitter and Tik Tok
and they're scrolling and they're like
seeing funny [__] and serious [__] and
personal [__] and all types of different
[__] yeah yeah it's not as much anym
because we used to be on always there's
nothing else there wasn't else to
nothing else to scroll like that we
would just we would go down and see the
craziest [__] on World Star and then I
introduced John to a bean and cheese
burrito he's never had one in his life
loves the bean and cheese burrito story
I not a
story fact okay Rubio what's bean and
cheese and cheese burrito like what the
[__] is that to a person that eats meat
that's insane I ate meat with him he was
eating meat the time he just a year
after I got here like eight months after
I got here I stopped eating meat yeah we
were eating like monsters at random [__]
all the time that's why it sucks he's
vegan now that's where you invented like
that I stabed it and then I pour the
syrup inside the hole so that it expands
sounds great my pancakes you stab
you stab the sack of Pancakes and then
on like five of them you stab and twist
a little stab and twist so when you pour
the syrup it goes like this through all
the pancak fuses all of it I thought I
remembered this conversation from
YouTube talking about like [__] used to
do everybody just commented no way and
when it works two weeks later go it
worked watch they're got a Time St it
works Sor I continue you uh where where
we I don't know where we at you moved
here is that the then you're like yo
that [__] that [__] doesn't make sense
it's cake that doesn't make
sense I I I smoked it at the fair and I
was like no this is too much like a
funnel cake smok at the fair that's
great and then I put it away I was like
I'm smoking at the fair I got to put
this away I'm at a fair and then I only
hit it once and that was it dude I felt
so stupid like oh I got to go off to the
side and hit this thing I tried it for
the first time yesterday it's like a
fresh bite of frosting it's weird hold
on have you tried the wedding cake
pen let's get this fo's face why he look
so upset cuz he's high he ate McDonald's
and he didn't like it he's
cinematographer hit that and tell me it
doesn't exactly like oven baked cake the
yellow cake that you put frosting
on a little weird
huh it's kind of kind of crazy this
one's my personal tast like Christmas
Widow y you i' I've saw the clip of you
bone drwing one I don't think I've ever
done some had a million on Facebook too
isn't that crazy it's like a million
views on Tik Tok and Facebook us just
talking about things but not directly
getting high so Tik tok's like yeah more
of this more no smoking [__] guys so you
like more of the weed ones yeah yeah
we're talking about today sour d like
this one I like rather the fruity ones
all day but Mar you made Marty cough
today but then again we'll go another
round I don't think I think it was the
angle it was at the angle we'll see I
cough my [__] brains out at home I
could have been the curent angle
okay continue oh hold on hold real quick
we're we're in La we just moved here
first day we're hanging out boom wait my
perspective MH I'm walking into the
first Cannabis Cup I've ever been okay
the first time I'm ever filming for a
YouTube video mhm the right when I press
play I'm looking at my feet I do that
everything my feet and then go up to see
like all you're walking boom it's always
just some fans some fans fans but that
one was Jay's for some reason like my
biggest video back then I was wearing
shoes I never [__] wear anyway I'm
doing it and R it do he goes yo what's
up man I'm like I press stop go what's
up dude he's like oh I follow you I'm a
big fan go oh nice man it was this
[__] guy little a little skinny
version of this man no that's with a
with a beard that's not lined up oh and
hair that is not not buzzed right uhhuh
hell no go look at those first ones this
fo looks n you look different for sure
you look Mexican you look like one of my
cousins it's racist even early on though
no like uh now you look Italian with the
hair liner Puerto Rican did you always
have Place emphasis on your brand though
it seems like you're that type of person
yeah yeah I've always I've always TR
I've always been trying to like build
something and uh something that I could
like make incredible and big that's
always been my goal like just build
something I never I've never had it like
that you know and I think I think when I
when I first started the company in
Florida and I had I was making the
shatter and stuff I think that like when
people would tell you like they've never
had something like that before they've
never dabbed something like that like
gives you a good feeling it's like oh
like I want to do more of that you know
I want to that's what I think like I'm
always just want to give like the best
to people I'm trying to like trying to
like give something they've never had
before I love like bringing a new
experience to someone you know like like
giving someone one of these syrups
changes their life they don't they like
H HH doesn't work worse changes their
whole life they're like yo my bad that
shit's incredible works really well you
give them something to dab that like you
know is like they're always dabbing like
you know full spec or like really cheap
RW and you get some good RA like oh I
understand now like people don't really
get it until they get to experience it
you know so like I didn't get it for a
long time I get to experience the dope
[__] so as soon as I started
experiencing good stuff I was like this
is this is it so I was like got to build
a brand and make someone know like so
you can build yourself you know I've
always wanted to like have a family and
like do all that stuff so now that I
have that that's like what I've wanted
to do so you got to make a brand you got
to always like work for yourself and not
just work for other people and build
other people's Brands up you know
beautifully said but also when he means
by experiences sometimes they're bad not
bad in terms of you [__] up with the
syrups when we were at the dinner thing
the Grand Theft Auto day the day that
felt like Grand Theft Auto the
[__] oh he doesn't watch our stuff
sorry John only watches Twitter Clips uh
sorry my bad John the day we went to the
car rally thing yeah when we were
driving you guys were be in front of me
and all that stuff I filmed it and I was
like yo I feel like I'm Grand Theft a
we're out here in Malibu all these cars
are in front of me I'm behind and then
during the ride to the mansion
spot Sean called me the guy from Grand
do I told you did I tell you this to
show these clips I don't think so see he
doesn't want [__] anyway I talked about
on the show I talked about that day how
it was what we're smoking like this is
crazy we're D dve we're getting dab
right here this is
unbelievable Sean called me that play
Frank from Grand Theft da he called me I
put on speaker cuz I'm trying to keep up
with you fool I kept up pretty good for
a while in a boat mhm anyway I'm
smashing I put it on speaker he's like
yo what up and I'm like I'm on [__]
Grand Theft Auto what's up man he's like
yo what's up and then he's with Michael
from Grand Theft Auto n like yo I'm like
oh nice to meet you man he's like I got
five stars on me right now what's I
swear to God I'm might keeping up and I
you guys and I see that that guy that
did you know he melted that pfp guys pfp
off his car mhm ppf or they yeah yeah
that guy was blowing fire out of his car
like we in Greece blowing fire out of
his car and then he's like yo nice to
meet you go oh my God Michael what's up
nice to meet you man like what are you
doing uh I'm driving right now what's up
with you guys uh no we just by your
house and need you're chilling so I
wanted to come hang out like oh I'll hit
you guys up there I'm like it's all
right cool like you got to give me that
car I'm like yeah yeah and I hang up and
I went no [__] why and then I had to
pull over two seconds later cuz I
thought I left my backpack at the
restaurant that why you were that's why
you got left yeah and I didn't I
panicked cuz I was like I leave my
[__] camera and my backpack and all
my weed and my laptop [__] it was wasn't
anyway I felt like I was in Grand Theft
aut sounds great then we show up to that
place and we're just sitting there
chilling that's what that's the day you
don't watch [__] the day we're talking
about was such an epic story I don't
know but anyway you were there that [__]
was tight the girl filled up your rig
with the water from the restaurant from
the restaurant yeah that was nice that
was nice what what a day it was it was a
good day it was a good day that was
crazy sorry how we got into that don't
oh on nice things and dope [__] the
syrups yes oh the we get branding we get
into and the the the first company that
I that I started in Florida that uh is
no longer here it was it was a really it
was I wish I could have kept building
that one but in the in the area where we
were at the reason why we came to
California is because a lot of kids were
just getting in trouble all over you
know kids were getting worked up and
people were getting you know people were
snitching so it was like I was like
looked at Rachel one day I was like it's
it's time to go and she's like go where
like we're going to California she's
like no I was like yeah we're going to
leave so we l packed our [__] and we
left like 2 days later and we told our
mom like Hey we're moving to California
they're like what I was like yeah we're
gone she okay so we moved there move we
moved to California with 10K to our name
I like 12K to our name same though we
had 11 and we we we didn't have an
apartment yet or anything so we just
lived in a hotel in the hotel for the
first three four nights with our cat
[__] in a [__] like a cardboard
box in the hotel room hotel room across
the street from what would be what would
be oh my God the hotel I stayed at was
across the street from our uh our
billboard that we put the shop [__] like
literally the hotel like we went ate
breakfast while we waited for it to get
put up we were at that hotel wow we're
just looking up he's like he stay in
this room so we we were just literally
just we were in that room every day we
were just searching for apartments and
we're like where what studio we live we
we had no idea what we were going to do
and we're like we went to like uh
Anaheim like oh this is nice like it
reminded where we used to live cuz where
we was where we live like it wasn't like
the richest area but everything was new
everything was like like not like an old
building like you would pull up an LA
like first time you get there and you're
like oh this is sucks like it's
warehouses and homeless people and [__]
like in Anaheim ore kind like there
wasn't much of that so I was like this
is where we need to move so we found a
place in Anaheim and we got accepted and
we we moved in there and we literally
slept uh on a we went we went and got a
couch cuz that was all we could afford
the time and we slept on the couch in
our living room for like a good amount
of time and the very first night before
we had anything in there I had uh
Kenny's glass and and Roger and and uh
what's his name Nate and Nate come over
I'll never forget this the very first
day I moved in it was 420 I moved in it
on 420 right they before 420 so that
night going in was 420 so Kenny's glass
came over with uh with this huge slab of
nothing but nectar like WiFi OG like
super fire shatter and and then uh Roger
and him brought over Tai sticks and we
literally just fogged out my empty
apartment and I remember I told they
were like looking for an apartment 2 and
they ended up moving the apartment in
like the same building as me a week
later but we when I was there I was like
oh man I live in Cali now like I need to
buy an ounce of shatter like I need to
be able to smoke whenever I want and I
spent half of our money on an ounce of
shatter that I just smoked cuz I thought
that's what I had to do when you're in
Cali sick was dope that that hurt I
think she was a little mad at me but it
was the best it was really good really
good um
shatter wow that's cool no hey
prorities we all got them
man just pissed she's pissed now Idiot
she like they left they're like she's
like why'd you buy a whole ounce I'm
like I was like it's like how you buy
here right like can't buy a little bit
look like a [__] [__] Cali dude got
got to smoke a
slab so you left home yeah now you're
out here yeah so John's the first person
that ever recognized me in public before
the first one I was walking up stopped
it to say hi how you doing I went Rosie
what the [__] somebody know who it was
what the hell and I just kept walking
like wow that was crazy then years later
yeah we start chilling wild it is wild
it's very funny actually really crazy I
had just started I just started like a
year and a half before
that yeah like a year in a couple months
pretty wild wild stories wild timing I
think yeah for sure
so you steal Rachel
mhm see face when I looked at her put
her on
Paws friend we're more months for
friends now we're now we're together
we're moving all right so you're moving
now you're when you're a kid you're like
oh trap force is combined when you guys
flew into the sky and sold a bunch of
[__] I'm assuming okay correct right at
the beginning they like Rachel was the
more Force I would say Bobby Brown and
Whitney Houston they weren't on drugs
what their forces would have been
combined yeah you the Jay-Z and Beyonce
that's a probably a thank you thank you
it's probably a better couple to
pick one a couple and I was like Jes God
I said without the drugs yeah that's
pretty much Beyond JC I'm going flip his
table into the sky Mar that was a way
better example way better example OG do
you want to hit this joint that you
never smoked OG is that mine yeah no
it's yours no I have no idea swear swear
it's yours I lit it you tell me I guess
you call that a little bit lit but I let
it and put it down yeah wonder why I
wonder why too yo thank you for that
example way better Jay-Z and Beyonce
sorry called You Whitney Houston and you
Bobby Brown but I said without the drugs
so like the good famous singers right
mhm but trap forces
combin that's what you guys did for a
little bit then you're like yo we got to
bounce because [__] out here
snitching I remember when that wave went
down I know exactly who the humans
you're talking about I remember all that
[__] wonder how they're doing now cuz I
was like yo we're going to be like
losers in our third 30s by the time
these fools get out that's what I was
thinking the time has come yeah they're
out that's there that's sad um okay so
now you're here and you're like yo
Thomas I need this logo hatch house is
going to be my name I'm like that's a
sick name and then you're like should I
put a house for the a I'm like yeah and
then you're like yeah and then we
ordered and then one time we ordered
pizzas we both were broke and then John
was like y i order these pizzas and then
we got the bill on the C and it was
$106 how do you remember this [__]
random I snapchated it and laughed at
you you all remember this okay snap and
yell we ordered two pizzas we're both
like
yo yeah we need to make some money all
right we're we're chilling a lot though
we need to get up and do some [__] it's
like I push trees and [__] but it just
got deleted also you guys don't forget
right Thomas was very established more
than I was so so like even though me
hanging out with Thomas and him talking
was helping me out a lot so we were
hanging all the time but I was like
Thomas was like oh hash house and I was
like oh damn this is great so Thomas
really helped bring my coming while we
were chilling doing nothing chilling
we're just chilling like organic
chilling he just like supported the
brand you know what I'm saying so like
that got me to like a different level
even though we're just hanging I wasn't
really working much because it it like
it made someone that was like relative
it's like oh stuff's good so then people
were like oh what's this and the first
person to ever put me in any Cannabis
Cup ever was him which one was that it
was I on the table couldn't [__] tell
you you gave me a corner gave me the
sign and everything and he's like he's
you've never sold weed at any of your
booth I couldn't believe I was like not
even expecting it and you're like yeah
do your thing and I was like for real
and it was like the sickest moment of my
life and it worked we were it was it was
incredible I we sold out it worked it
was it was the it was like I was like
damn I just sold out at a canabas cup
dope as Yola damn it was it's big you
know it's organic to him to him it was
nothing you know to him it was just him
chilling but to me it was like it was
crazy you know what I'm saying like it
was fun it it was normal but at the end
of the day it's like oh like it worked
sick you know he talks about what he
likes and then it just has that imp for
sure like EI if it's good it's good you
know what I'm saying and we were both
trying to make it yeah we were both
having a good time doing it like we were
both he was making it while I was making
it too I was making pucks too and just
like your are way better we were having
fun dude we fun like no but the temp I'm
like [__] that how much skill is
involved in making it that skill it's
experience of like how to do giving a
[__] what to do it really comes down to
just give just like anything in the
world like obviously you need to you
need to educate yourself about what the
process is but you just got to give a
[__] and not be dirty and and like just
do it the right way and take your time
and not like cut corners and so it's not
about secrets and tricks and tips and
I'm sure everyone has their everyone has
their own little things you know but
that everything can be achieved by some
other way no one has like one [__]
way that only one person can do it I
don't that starting material start well
starting material is the biggest biggest
part of course but I'm saying like
besides the starting material if you
making it is about if if you gave an
idiot and a smart person you know the
same material it's going to come out
different you know because this guy is
Dil diligence and he he takes his time
and he's super clean and he washes
everything after every wash you know
like this guy's just [__] just
getting it done you know so I think it's
just more about giving a [__] is what it
really comes down to and not just trying
to make a dollar yeah see so when I when
I was doing it
I'm smoking this giant Pug and John was
like please don't put the pre the the
screens together stop putting all the
fourth the first third and press
together I'm like shut up fool it's a
bigger Puck I want to smoke it's like
different he's like [__] sh Thomas was
hard man he he didn't want to do he was
just like listen I'm smoking it I don't
care a [__] I would press it hot as [__]
to get that last bit scrape it all
together like well this giant dab is
going to taste okay I guess yeah but
it'd be like one big I'm like I'm going
stretch it out look little you still
liked weed better always like you're
still like yeah I always like but you
still didn't like to the point you are
now with dabbing you weren't like that
at all before okay ready you enjoy it so
much more now and like accept it you
smoked hash he like didn't accept it
back then why cuz he just accept like
you didn't accept like doing all this
extra [__] Fu like he was like no [__]
it it's not worth it [__] that [__] that
[__] that John this is stupid this is
dumb he'll take the that but he don't
want to do it now you see a set of now
now he's like different he's evolved
it's different so but are you ready for
the evolution okay it's only cuz this
guy and every time I'm like you are a
snob shut up John 3 months later I'm
like oh you were [__] completely
right I'm doing [__] so the first thing
was stop putting your first and second
and third press together like shut up
and I start smoking just the first press
oh my God still smoke it if you want
separating I would just put them like I
was the kid that John's like yo Playdoh
Reds go to Reds and yellows go to
yellows I was like shut up trying to
make a [__] bam one color big ball you
know what I'm saying yeah that's how I
was and then he's like yo you got to
clean your nail after every day I'm like
fool do you think I got 2 and a half
minutes to do that [__] I'm trying to
watch world star Vine cons this
knowledge trickles down to people though
oh cuz I I say it in but in the videos I
go [__] John told me I didn't used to
do this every video I always go and my
homie was like stop doing that [__] I'm
like he's right so what happened is what
I used to do I'd go like this with the
nail with the with the Q-tip and be like
that's the most I'm ever going to do
that's stupid enough I'm not doing that
I was am I going to the store buy Q-tips
so you got to got Q-tips and then put
all
alcohol I like shut up and then he's
like at least clean I go nope and I'd
burn it off and I my nail so hot all my
oil left over turned black and then it
would get clean and they say you CH your
nail go I don't give a [__] about that
nail cuz I didn't care had the same nail
for 5 years I didn't care it was insane
and then he's like you got at least put
alcohol and I went like this one day
with my nail ja cuz I went it's wet
there you go and I cleaned and he's like
don't ever do that to my [__] nail
ever I was like don't worry it's mine
and and then what else happened you got
to dunk your [__] and you got to use qti
you got to dunk it and I'm like no I'm
not going to dunk it and then now look
at me I have a [__] D you got a whole
protocol like a Fu you got put a pearl
in there no Jay show me pearls but still
it's like sophisticated in getting hot
it's not even that and you're like if
you're going to put $110 [__] gram in
there and then I thought about like okay
if I'm eating a steak and I'm like yo
give me that butter knife but the
plastic one let me get that styrofoam
plate that you're already used like I'm
still going to be able to eat this but
it's going to be shittier and I could
get it there faster and nicer and easier
and more sophisticated like you said by
using a [__] knife it's a valuable
life lesson about taking care of your
[__] you should liking nice [__] you
should as you put that out my heart just
went and we're going to Rel light it in
a little bit but you ever seen Fantasia
you you have it [__] what the [__] is
that okay you know when fireworks John
you know when fireworks go off they go
and they dissipate and they go away
fireworks Marty that's what my heart did
right now I should have a [__]
fireworks out if I got out where's the
wests side gun okay what
now what about fireworks Thomas you know
how they go and then they fade away and
they start into pieces that's what my
heart did when you put that [__]
joint out right now why because it's not
out you don't want this no more I'm I'm
liting a little bit oh OG OG's here in
the in the in the spear form where are
my glasses where are my GL what they
just formed can you put some on edited
right now oh real quick for the next
couple seconds stay still talk but stay
still now you have glasses on awesome
give him like some John lenen ones
though sick ones all right continue
where were we at I have no [__] idea
oh you have to care about your hash and
stuff and then you're like yeah BL and
then we started making hatch and then I
was like yo I'm [__] over it and then
one day I went to his house he goes I
don't even even want to smoke flower
rosin anymore and I went shut oh my God
worst [__] ever and for like 60 remember
earlier like what do you mean about that
that's what I did to this fool you're
tell me you're you press flow the first
rosin that everyone was smoking was flow
press weed and you get the rosin and
then I you just press Ice has oh I got
you okay so all this is all ice hash I
Will Never Smoke flow ring in my damn
life took me about 7 months after going
shut up dropping my dirty ass flower
coins with residue of weed
still I didn't give a [__] dude I really
didn't care I swear to God it was like a
dirty Chef yeah that's how I feel about
looking at flow I was never a big fan of
but like you know I I came to Cali to
start a BH coming like I was I was like
I'm going to come out here and start a
shatter company and extract and do all
that [__] and I was like cuz it's legal
out there you know easy so when I when I
first came out here I was like oh like
trying to like you know start getting it
going and everyone's like yeah you know
you I kept saying like oh you know cuz
it's it's like legal out here they're
like can't extract legally without like
a license and I'm like yeah but like
it's not like he like no it's still it's
a horrible really that and I'm like oh
[__] that sucks so I'm like trying to
figure it out I'm like damn like I just
left Florida blasting oil to come blast
oil here like [__] this do really make
sense and I'm like a like wonder what I
could do that'd be like you know a b
better I was like oh Ros was like just
like just starting the thing I was like
oh I'll start a rosin company instead so
I started pressing pressing flour and
doing the rosin thing and like I liked
it but I wasn't like I was like damn man
like some you just can't get that taste
cuz it's always that like flowery earthy
taste tea AR Palmer when there's too
much tea yeah it's just like there' be
like certain strands youd get like that
were like kind of good but it was it was
really hard to come across but I had
this I had this um this company that was
like delivery name was cream of the crop
and they used to come they're still a
company today they're still it's a brand
yeah it's a brand today still legal
brand and um they used to come to my
house and bring me all different types
of weeds you know they you pick your
weed you want I I'd go do like a little
test squish in the room come out and
that's the that's weed I was getting for
a while remember them and um uh one time
they came here and they were like hey
they're like yo man um they're like do
you want to buy any hash and I'm like
I'm like no like I know and this is the
time when like you know since rosin
thing flower rosin was what was being
sold in companies and then like the
heady kids were getting like the the ice
the ice ice wax the Melt you know and
they would take and they would press it
on like a little hair straightener they
press a little GR it would it would be
like you know no one would see Ros like
this was clear light like it was
incredible cuz they were pressing like
really expensive ice hats like1 $150 ice
hash but only kids that had a lot of
money were doing this because you'd lose
you know on the mount you squish in
there so people were doing that but no
one was actually selling it no one was
selling hash Rin like it wasn't a thing
so one day he came over and the dude's
like hey man I have this uh who was it I
think it was
uh K or no Pacific Northwest remember uh
what's his name wow Primo it it was
Primo I didn't know Primo at the time so
it was Primo stuff and he's like I got
this melt and we went on vacation and
the the freezer like went out and all
the Melt is greased so like we can't
sell it and it was like $100 melt and
he's like you know maybe you could get
it and you know squish it for your you
know for hash house and I'm like dude
this shit's [__] like $100 a grand
would cost me so much to squish it like
it would made no sense and he's like
he's like no bro he's like since it it
[__] up on us and greased we'll sell
to you at cost it was like I like 50 60
bucks a gram or something like that and
I was
like okay like let me so I went there
and did a test Squish and I got back
like 92% yield you know it's not unheard
of when you do flower RS cuz you were
getting such little amounts so I
squished you know like a gram and I got
back you know like a 0.92 so I'm like am
I doing the math and I'm like all right
cost me this like if I could sell it for
this I it be good so I'm basically I had
to sell it for like like like 80 bucks a
gram or something like that but I'm
thinking about like oh if I ever want to
do this again and sell it I'm never
going to get this price again so like
what would it really cost me so I did
the price of what it would really cost
me if I had to go buy that melt again I
was like I sells it 100 a gr and Rachel
looks at me she goes you think you could
sell this for $100 of gram who do you
think you
are I swear and I was like I was like
listen this is cuz as soon as I as soon
as I did the TCH
squish I dabbed it I was like it was
like the first time me dabbing shatter
in that [__] garage I was like this
is it like this is the [__] best way
to smoke there's no way this is going to
get better like it's [__] on flower
rods and like if people want to smoke
fire which I know people do they're
going to [__] pay for it and if not
I'll [__] go back to flow rosin so I
I bought everything he had and it wasn't
much you know proba like 30 40 grams of
it I don't even remember but I I
squished it all and I packaged it out
and it was just like to the homies and I
was like yo this what I have and this
what it is and they took a dab and
everyone [__] bought it every single
person bought every drop of it and
Rachel was like holy [__] he [__] it
worked I was like yeah it worked so we
kept [__] just buying ice hat from
him and just [__] just and that was
like that was the that was like the that
was like the the Pinnacle of of like
everything for hash house that was like
the I was like the first person to put
out a product that was actually ice hash
that wasn't [__] flower r that you
could dab that was clear in the nail
that tasted [__] incredible like and
it was like yo you could buy Mass
amounts of it like you could buy grams
and and you know ounces of it like no
one everyone had like a little bit that
they made like at the table that very
second and dab it so it was like when I
would go to session people would have
like $50 $60 grams of flower RS and have
$100 grams of hasra and people were
still picking my stuff because it just
you couldn't get it you know so I think
that's what really set me apart from a
lot of people and why why I have the
name I do because I just one of the
first people to do it and show that
there's like there is like quality you
know and there's there's fire out there
way better than what flower R could be
and everyone knew that just only the
people that had money could really
understand it and then um and then
people started you know catching on and
every flower browen brand switched over
like it was like in a matter of like
probably a year damn I totally lost
every train of thought for everyone out
there to think that you're not crazy we
cut real quick to change the battery and
get water so we did no cuz they're going
to be like you were talking you GNA get
a good prize oh and it's gonna cut
straight to that so you're going to look
10 like 10-sec Tom that's from another
movie 10c Tom from 51st dates you
remember that movie Adam S I do know
that movie very well remember they go to
the insane or the the Asylum with people
with brain injury the guy's like hey I'm
Tom 10 seconds later hey I'm Tom he
forgets every 10 seconds like you 10c
John sorry talking about bad memories
about the guy and asking him is insane
that's like when I asked nordon you ever
get so hot your light just can't work he
go bro I just got out of a wheelchair
dog and went oh what's wrong with me
you're an idiot I felt like an idiot nor
he's we know him now it's okay so I can
talk to him like I felt so stupid when
he left I would oh my God what am I
doing remember that like what did I just
say when Ryan secr try to high five the
blind guy on America America F or
American Idol that's what I did I felt
so stupid he he was Pur he oh he felt
bad my guy's blind man he got a a walker
thing anyway I'm sorry continue John
didn't just forget everything well no I
did no no no no no we took a slight
break yeah but I forgot and this cut
you're going to look insane that's fine
okay you you went from fully talking to
what we talking about isn't going to be
insane we talking about the ice hash and
the [__] I know but it's yeah and
you're like yo my shit's getting picked
over it because I'm get higher quality
fire they want fire oh all the comies
switching over all the comies switched
over and then basically there was flower
Ros was dead there was no more [__]
flower I haven't seen in a long time
just doesn't exist anymore I I've never
seen anyone do it in probably three
years at least you know what's crazy
about two hours in mhm I Haven I haven't
taken a dab yet yeah which is nuts you
know why cuz we're telling stories and
stories get you captivated and you get
lost that's what happen give me the ash
part I was already doing
[Laughter]
that my bad the second I went get his
Ash off me a it's open got a little dab
it is a little baby dab what little dab
for little baby
dinosaurs okay like him you you a baby
dinosaur dinosaurs he's baby Sinclair
you got to go you got to go right now
yeah see you later you little bit
it sounds so different when you take
these [__] things off dud all right
now while he's doing that yes you're a
guy who buys a lot of
[__] sometimes Che like stuff what's
the one thing that you bought that
you're like this was [__] outlandish
I should have never bought this and I'm
getting rid of it um well everything but
that I'm getting rid of part because you
can't really get rid of it but this
chain oh
okay I love sick should have bought a
custom no no I just like should have
gone down a little bit in the size you
know didn't really know how big it was
yeah didn't know how big it was going to
be until it got here so your traps are
developing because of it it doesn't get
uh it doesn't get used as much as it
could go cuz it's kind of it's not very
safe to wear yeah but we're you know
it's nice nice nice little area
here well can you explain what we got
here for people that don't know what
they're looking at uh it is The Hash
House pendant covered in diamonds and I
got like a chain the six stars to
represent like the hash house
six-star what what does that mean okay
so uh for a while like hash was graded
in like stars so it' be like before
people were squishing it people were
were actually smoking the Melt so people
were great like oh this is six-star this
is five star six-star being the highest
star so I used to used to be like it
used to be called like six-star rosin
because I used to like the rosin was
always made from six-star Material
that's so six-star was just kind of
thing I have the stars and different
like design and stuff so when uh when I
was talking to the the Jeweler he was
trying to like figure out how to make
something custom that would like match
the vibe and I told him about the stars
and he's like oh it's perfect so we put
the stars in it it's pretty [__] sick
thank you how long have you had that for
her um it's been
probably 3 weeks little over two years
now I think about that like two years
something like that it's fake it went
from this guy Nam completely fake uhhuh
but it's big you know I could have got a
smaller fake one smaller fake one next
time next time you learn from it John's
actually like maybe almost 5 foot that
chain is literally just looks real big
on camera foot couldn't imagine being 5
foot I can you were 5 foot one time no
never yeah you were once I came out 5
foot
two and that's why your mom's like go
get that money for the pament you know
what you did to me yeah 14 stay out and
make it just carry a pistol poer is
great do you still gamble do you still
gamble as whenever I get the chance yeah
yeah I get a chance in Vegas we like to
gamble oh that's why you like going to
Vegas Vegas is very fun do you do like
online Sports no no I don't I don't do
none of that I I'm not a big Sports guy
I don't I don't keep why you coughing
why are you coughing it's a this is a
very professional podcast flower
Ros I can't wait to put some clips in oh
it's going to be great I have a lot of
Clips so he I'm going to take this time
to to do nice I respect that Oh I
thought get a dopest I thought you're
going to eat it y I'm giving it to each
of us can you guys wait no want to know
what's going on right when it happens so
impatient these hosts very impatient
just want to give you guys he call us H
yeah you didn't say host very impatient
these ho I heard take time to eat our uh
dopest Hash House collab live raw and
gummies that are delivered to off the
states on the do shop.com hello that's
true that's true it's like the Matrix
I'm going eat none it's like the I'm
doing a movie reference here guys it's
like The Matrix like it's called the
Maddox no it's it's definitely [__]
not actually you you should eat both of
these because it's your collab I did eat
you mine too take one for take two for
the team I two more eat right now do it
right now
okay people see you on the dope as YOLO
Channel and know that this this energy
he's bringing right now is not
real this is fake edible liquid courage
go go hard right now before it
drops
Perfect Beat oh no keep going keep
going good oh my God meet my later
[__] oh you [__] [__] ass damn oh my
God just throw in my M do you want
another one you want here I got you all
right appreciate apprciate on the house
all right on the house on the on the
hash house yeah on the hash house okay
okay where we
at
so y you're out here making has I'm over
here dunking on
you um what else that's where we left
off let's talk about let's let's talk
about you playing me and basketball
let's talk about that it was fun hold on
hold on mhm it's not like anyone's
better hold on I was re I really
technically I'm better in all actuality
remember this excuse no excuse I lost
huh recently this is uh two birthdays
ago yeah two years ago hold on before we
say this I did not want to mess his
[__] outfit up go dude true were in
the chain when we were no when we were
buing each other I was like oh no bro I
was like a lot so you couldn't body them
how you appropriately I didn't want to
any not hard no we were but we were
sweating sweating as we were like
disgusting cloth go out the window as
soon as he's [__] dripping and swea
no they don't this man I shoot the ball
I shoot the ball I miss he shoots the
ball he misses I make it we're just
playing just at his birthday party there
70 people at his house he's one of those
guys that's where I [__] shine oh
[__] where I [__]
[Applause]
shine the L for him hour 32 for a singer
232 for a singer look at the look at the
look at the screen dude you're on the
you're Clockwork long episode that's
where I shine oh jeez this is true Mar I
didn't tell you what happened I don't
know this story at all this a great
story okay hold on man is wearing a full
I have never boughten anything more than
Vans and my own push tree shirts at this
point and Yeezys I bought a pair of
Yeezys at the time yeah so I was like I
don't even want to get close to your
stupid ass outfit it's matching you know
that [__] was
expensive so I'm like we're like boom
I'm like oh hell no I'm going to rip
this button off and it's going to be
hella of money that's stupid okay we're
playing hard but we're like we're both
not like pushing each other you're
keeping track of score oh hold we're all
keeping track of score we all keeping
got to the best part he's telling a
story really bad man we started off
playing no one really watching and and
we're like I'm not even there no you
tell the story I want to hear you tell
the story no go you go ahead you go
ahead trash ass fool back he so called
backstory and that's how I tell story go
ahead go ahead go go sorry sorry sorry
sorry he makes one I make
one we're not playing the game yet we're
not playing then we're like yo 101 we
just start going into it yeah for for 49
minutes straight at about minute 15 10
people start watching from his birthday
party like yo where's John's his bir
playing basketball pretty actively over
there what the [__] it's hot yeah full
the Gucci outfit all matching and I'm
like damn he pushed the [__] out of me I
went into his Bush I went all right
we're playing at about minute
30 every single [__] person in his
entire birthday party is staring you
know you know when when when Street
Fighters started and it's panning up and
the people in the back just doing this
[__] that's what everybody it looked
like it was just like a crowd of people
there was some police Circle the court
it was a half court ins theide of his
house it Rucker Park bro 49 minutes
straight no score Marty no one can make
scored a shot stand and pushing so hard
and he turned around trying to fade away
I'm doing the same thing we're the same
size damn near we're doing this no no it
was it was that stalemate it was a
complete every time I went left he went
left or his right and the same we
mirrored each other like Peter p in the
shadow for 49 minutes it was getting to
the point where people were almost done
watching yes because they're like are
you guys really not going to make a
[__] shot I go for layup he swatt it
he go for layup we going to 11 then at
one point like Jo first first to score
wins yeah oh God yeah a UFC fight they
never throw a punch
in yeah they they about to stop the
fight they were about to stop stop the
[__] fight cuz no one can land a
punch not nobody was trying Marty
imagine a bunch of Fighters swinging and
missing and then swinging and
missing trying like I'm fullblown out of
breath
swea really going hard bro I'm like I
insane this is not that hard believe
they're not dropping can't believe his
aren't
dropping I'll be like damn game's over
oh [__] he didn't miss it and then
everyone like oh he John's going make
like and then I'm welcoming it like
please [__] make it I'm out of breath
it was bad I'm out of breath and then
not even that he turns around finally
shoots one it bounces goes in everybody
erupts like the Super Bowl just [__]
ended and they're going to storm the
[__] field with the band everybody
comes in and John just does this rips
his shirt in
half and all the buttons
go he don't give a [__] about the shirt
the whole time I'm like you [__]
kidding me instantly ripped the shirt in
the half and I what the [__] he's like
it's just a [__] shirt dog like
you're a piece of [__] this whole time I
let you throw me into a bush the walls
behind the bush you piece of [__] it's a
fence I hit that [__] so violently hard
he like pushed me and went H that shirt
that shirt so much respect for the price
tag on that [__] Gucci I swear my
life I was so scared of the it was like
your your rigs I'm
like no cuz I used to not touch these
[__] R till like 2 years ago
maybe then I was like month ago all
right maybe like 6 months ago so all
right so technically he won won let the
record show Sean won he won it was just
so stupid you got to run it back and
some wife beaters and
[__] yeah we will we should but 100%
we should do the next subscription video
on the basketball court it's just first
to one it's no smoking involved there
[__] editing it's shaky Omar the same
style as the birthday Vlog all right the
same way you film the birthday video I
need you to film the
basketball inspired by inspired by The
Blair Witch Project was the best one by
damn Blair Witch cameraman on this one I
[__] was cracking up in my kitchen on
the live chat cackle cackle laughing
when someone [__] said that [__]
sorry yeah first to one he won but okay
thank God who play the one no that's
[__] because we were like 21 we couldn't
get five like yo whoever scores we were
both it was 40 something damn near an
hour it's his birthday party yeah yeah
people were excited on the sidelines now
they're kind of everyone was like semi
drunk too oh we were both taking yo it
was I've never seen anybody with that
many bottles of just that was insane
that lady that full fli shot speaking of
that let's take one you want to take a
shot right now yeah yeah that sounds
great all right all right let's do it
you get that Bott this is technically
Thomas's birthday episode
right am I wrong no is
it sounds right no cuz we're three weeks
out so you're high so this week for
everyone reference we film with fluffy
cheich today and John finally blessed us
with his [__] presence after like I'm
wait for Jeezy No I need a big I
comedian like all right fluffy I loveu I
need what to happen man no ooh what
happened was he's like I need a haircut
they already know yeah I need air they
know they know they got the playby play
they got the yeah they get it they know
every week that we've been waiting so uh
we need some cups we'll get that done
that's fine we'll get that going hold on
I I lost in great fashion and in [__]
up fashion also cuz he ripped his shirt
in the end and that's how that ended
that was awesome yeah someone you think
he said something basketball and I came
up that's how we got there no idea I I
don't remember
do you remember how we got here it's
crazy yo hold on remember that one time
when Ryan DJ afterthought invited me to
a con like yo you want to go see Riff
Raff with me you're all hell yeah so we
were in backstage oh was it Anna Anaheim
remember went to see Riff Raff with John
and Rachel and John's like yo I love
Riff Raff and then before I knew about
any jewelry of any kind and you were
like after we left you're like you
didn't see the watch blah blah something
I was looking at BL I'm like who gets
[__] about watch fool shut up I don't
care but it was like it looked like
Dorothy shoes it was red ruby it was
wild remember that [__] yeah and then uh
anyway we went there and that fo was
pretty hilarious I want to just say that
I don't know what I was going with that
but remember that was hilarious Oh I
thought it was be a crazy story I forgot
about it I was I was like Y where is
this going I remember this night but I
don't remember what happened from videos
I've saved and I go where were we at H
it's just us you sure this is uh
actually the right tequil in here you
guys didn't and
just it's barbecue sauce sure it's
[__] barbecue sauce and chopped up
nuggets in that
[__] damn so what you do is you pour
you pour like like
that are you [__] serious is this
camera on is it catching all of it thank
God this full just can you walk a
straight line for me son and he just thr
napkin please [__] F dude hold here
listen I don't really pour shots okay
you don't really pour shots no I'm
usually just like you know the last time
I got blackout drunk to where I don't
remember certain parts was at this
motherfucker's wedding and it was
terrible I mean fun wedding was but it
was so that's the first time I've ever
drank that liquor right there that
liquor right there [__] was bum okay
where we at now where we at no [__] I'm
Michael Jordan yes when he retired went
to baseball Michael Jordan when he was
still playing basketball basically he
just had the H of edge yeah
and thank God I was so over it anyway
where the [__] were we going with that
[__] to begin
with huh
what [__] come on let's take the damn
shot why are you rushing the shot man
you brought shot alcohol up and now we
can't remember anything we were doing oh
my manager cut [__] you he's over there
come drink this for me come drink this
for me yeah
exactly what time is that Marty 2:44
yeah yeah you're doing good
you're doing good my god dude OG we had
to treat like Julian from [__] big
daddy and give him invisible glasses for
him to come on the show so you're doing
great John was so scared he dude he
literally earlier he was knees were
knocking when he was walking in he was
so ner remember Rosie his chain was
colder Ros we put on uh David gogins and
Joo and it [__] fired him up and a
little way album and John was fired up
we brought the we brought the masc got
out and we had give him a pep talk and
[__] and that's why you're here that's
this is why I'm here exactly you're
finally here and you're safe you're in a
safe place are we in a safe
haven can we speak here yeah are you
ready to take a shot what shot the shot
you forced upon us do you know want to
take it I don't I don't want to force
anybody not you just did is that okay
yeah I'm just kidding this is just apple
juice Chase it yeah Chase it with yeah
I'm going to chase it with this with the
some other red stuff
cheers do you guys finally invited me on
the podcast
finally B doesn't
care he wants that bird he wants I
welcome
it to my
genetic Mary likes like getting hit in
the knuckles on a cold morning type of
[__] like when you hit your you're
getting out of your car and you
accidentally smack something ah look at
your face your
face might a home grow Street home grow
at least it was before I [__]
everything up take a dab already fool
it's it's yours one yeah I did give you
one okay cool I'll
take you okay you're about to break that
lighter in your hand you're grisp Gras
your Gris grass got a lot snap crackle
pop snap crackle pop that's it's chist
Krispies what
[__] Rice Krispies remember the
Rice Krispies people the little elf guys
snap crackle and pop is that their names
yeah that's why I said it and then I
said yes Krispies it's facts yeah cuz
you know it's yeah but they I know I
thought that's what the snap crackle pop
that's their name to three little
elves you don't remember the rice you
guys remember the Rice Krispies
commercials as kids and they be sneaking
and doing [__] are you don't remember
their Saga Florida the Florida system is
flawed no no you were just old [__] that
was in when I was like [__] 10 oh
well then I was like [__] two you at
least five but five like am I like
paying attention to commercials yeah I'm
not remembering [__] from I don't think
so oh [__] okay this guy Thomas is like
oh when I was two and 3/4 I watch this
one show it was like about toilet paper
it was crazy it's called Babes in
Toyland am I
wrong I don't remember what the [__] I'm
watching when goes to commercial oh I do
that all the time holy [__] and I'll go
why can't I remember what we were
watching then I feel like I'm [__]
thought that was just a me thing I do
that [__] all the time dude and I go me
why or when I get off to get gas when
I'm going to mered or coming back for
the trip I don't know where the hell I
am I swear to God I have to look and
search I'm like how did I get off and
get on again I don't it's like I you
ever fall asleep in the day wake up and
go what day is it
that's how I feel no did your brain not
reset no what D you took a nap in the
day and you woke up said what day is it
you ever wake up and [__] day you
were just in [__] I'm saying
it's like oh yeah it's not morning I
woke took as sleep in the day it's
middle of the day it's not morning you
don't ever feel that when you fall I
don't fall asleep in the day so it's
really weird when I do I don't fall
asleep in the day either but I don't
think so you haven't done it in a long
time no so the next time you no actually
I have actually I have I actually have
pretty recently okay so when you fall
asleep and they go oh yeah it's it's not
7 in the [__] morning no I don't
think that much oh I do that [__] it's
weird just think about how I woke up and
I'm ready to well your brain's only
thinking about one thing I'm thinking
about [__] peewee's big adventure the
whole movie I'm thinking about hell of
[__] all right all right all right then
take a dab oh another joint here we go
hello okay so oh look at this little
roach right here no that's not a roach
it's it's still there oh this yeah you
bastard
you should smoke it I am okay so here we
are since we're doing
chronological oh we haven't got into
any I want to there's certain things
that we want to ask like hey tell me
this hey and you know what I'm saying
we're not going to get into that yet
continue we're in your life still you're
living here you're doing hash houses
like eight years ago we're continuing
and now you're on to the next step
obviously of doing your [__] uhhuh cuz
it's going to be in stores
oh as of right now what are we doing
you're saying that's what I'm talking
about right now oh you lost me present
Day present day I got it now I'm here
you're like oh God this eight years ago
now you didn't hear that that part you
know just the you got to do better that
you know I mean I heard me but I get it
I get it he's developed full CTE from
boxing already oh [__] he relayed the
message I guess he got it so as of right
now Hash House is in the process of of
uh just launching fully legal in all the
stores and everything we have a grow
that's almost uh going to do our first
crop with uh some genetics and some
really really crazy genetics for the
next round um and it's going to be
[__]
epic that was sick nice that was loaded
up we we waited a long time to uh you
know we had a lot of different like
approaches and different things we could
have done and gone to Market but this
has been this has been the best
situation we have you know our third
partner in the dopus he is the one
that's going to be you know helping me
out with bringing everything legal so
it's all like a big family and someone
we can trust and I know I'm not getting
[__] by anybody so it feels
comfortable and he's basically G me like
free Reign Over the huge facility that
he's basically put together the past
four years and uh it's almost time we're
just designing all the packaging right
now as we speak and uh hopefully next
month or two it should be first little
drop now are you going to look like is
it going to be cuz you really understand
and can nail down you've proven it
through the dopest the designer clean
modern look or are we going more like
flashy loud going no I'm going
completely completely clean modern look
that like something that like you know
can last forever that's like everyone
can enjoy nothing like trappy or like
designing like how how like I do my
stuff now like every every month there's
like a new design on here you know so
that's kind of like I'm not I'm kind of
going away from that it's going to be
kind of just more clean you know kind of
whites and blacks and just like just
luxury you know that's we're just trying
to promote like a luxury LIF style and
just show that there's you know fire and
all different types of aspects of the
industry you know so we're going to not
going to be just rosin it's going to be
you know weed uh pre-rolls oh [__] um
pensan it's full it's a full circle
company with it so I'm going to have I
want to have every product to where it's
like the luxury and I also want to be
able to get to like the lower end market
and be able to give them something
that's like better than what they
usually have at the same price so we
want to just attack all the angles but
we're we're starting to focus just on
like the like the very exclusive drops
at the moment you know the first thing I
want to come out with come out with
something really good so like we have
our first we have our first uh crop
coming down in like two weeks and um
it's not the uh genetics I wanted CU we
had a wait for so we're going I'm going
to Q this stuff and see how it comes out
so either either we're going to do a
drop the next month or two if this stuff
works out or we're going to have to wait
for the 3 four months to get uh the
genetics that I was actually waiting for
to be in the grow so if if this stuff
goes well we'll be dropping soon if not
we'll just wait a little bit longer but
everything's been designed like just
like super super clean you know super
legible you know no like not much
Graphics you know I might have like per
flavor like on like like say like it's a
bag of weed it's like a eth it'll be
super clean maybe the back of it with
the sticker of the flavor might have a
little bit of Graphics or a little bit
of like little color a little touch but
it's going to be very very simple and
clean for
sure 60% under now nice yeah he gave it
to me Thomas is 100% own we did a rock
paper scissors B that was nice of you
that you did that rock paper scissors
was flip of coin that's why he lost D
dou that's why he lost cuz we were
playing rock paper scissors and he just
didn't get it that's why I lost default
default a really
bad you had that loaded up like that he
knew something was going to happened
today that was
incredible perfect [__] timing Marty
okay good [__] I think we're almost
caught up so almost where are people
going to be able to get
those everywhere California off the bat
yeah well I have I like at the moment I
have like I have a decent amount of
stores waiting for the first drop so
it's just like a nothing crazy just a
small drop but I want to I don't want to
make it like to where it's every single
place not going to be that much
available is there going to be a website
that people can go to well there's not
there's not going to be a website we're
going we're going to have a we're trying
to implement like a some type of
delivery for it too so like a direct to
Consumer type thing that like if you're
in the area you can like you know find a
hub near you and we can you know get it
to you and like we're going to have some
type of program like that but it's not
very it's not like setting stone or
anything yet so by the next time you
come on this will be moving oh yeah but
it'll be it' be for sure a moving moving
thing yeah was I was I was actually on
the call with with the girl this morning
talking about everything and it was sing
pictures of it because it's so close to
being done and it's just like now
waiting on the test to see how it is and
see how it gets dry and all that
different stuff well I mean you got all
the experience you got more experience
than anybody probably in the space
really I mean lot people have a lot of
experience but I just I think I just uh
there's a difference of like having the
experience and also implementing like
the like trying to care you know and
trying to like actually put a product
out that like you're going to be stand
behind and not [__] just try to make
a dollar on you know CU we have I have a
lot of other things that I do in the
world and and this is something that I'm
building for a future you know so it's
like the the legal industry to get into
the market is not like the most like
profitable thing at the moment you know
in the future it will be but right now
it's about making a brand that's
something that you're going to be able
to stand on that everyone's not never
have something bad to say about so you
know you can can set yourself for the
future so that's all I'm trying to do
I'm just trying to put out good [__] and
that everyone's going to enjoy and have
some good like marketing and good fun
and good time and good collaborations
with people I want to do a lot of
collaborations and do different things
with people and just like you know have
have fun doing it that's what you're
supposed to do yeah for sure let's go
and also at the same time I really can't
wait to be able to give back you know
that's that's a big part of something I
want to do too I'm trying to get
back you guys can't hear [__]
that was perfectly time for like the
worst [__] time yeah I love it I'm
trying to get back to these
kids trying to throw parties and get
bottle service that's what that sounded
like bottle service hey man you like
that kind of stuff I've never been to a
club and gotten bottle surfice in my
life actually I have [__] video
evidence of it happening where what do
you mean where where where where in
[__] Miami that's not that's
not a club it was a night it's a bar it
was like a bar I thought it was a
nightclub no it was outside service came
up I wouldn't consider that a club I'm
talking about like going to an actual
club we like walk in and there's like a
stage and there's like tables you buy
and [__] like that was not like that was
not the same to me there was a roof it
just look at the sky you're just High
I'm saying I've been a little places
like that that's not a club to me I'm
talking about like a real like a live or
like you know like a real Club the I've
been to that's what I'm saying so like
you haven't been really Club I've been
to a nightclub in Las Vegas see I've
never done that it was the worst why
because you ever see those videos of
hell where there's like hell people
crowded it's just hella talking that's
what it was like I this oh thanks for
I'm going get the beer thank you and I
was just trying to walkes sound fun to
me now it was terrible like if I want to
go I want I want to like go there and
get like a [__] VIP table on top of
the [__] club and watching everyone
do dumb [__] while I'm up there just
smoking having a good time chilling
that's the only way I want to do
anything but that cost so like it's not
worth it it's like I don't drink like
that you know so like when I oh here we
go here we go here what I was looking
for confirmation that he doesn't drink
like that I don't drink like that I wish
could drink like a fish no I when I
drink I drink a lot but I'm not like
that's not my goat too like I'm not like
I'm not a hoe but like if he's like cute
as [__] that's how you sound right now
like he like he's nice and [__] that was
great he's cute that's you [__]
guess I'm I'm way bigger of a drinker
than I was like two past two years for
sure when I was drinking fifth of
Hennessy I wasn't drinking nothing I you
were still drinking
tequila you were drinking tequila way
before I even ever tried this [__] you
were drinking tequila during your
wedding that's oh when I to the valley I
love tequila holy [__] Tequila's
great I don't drink like that I don't
drink like that either but when I drink
I'll drink this table for sure I'll
drink the whole [__] table so you do
drink like that just when you do it I
process alcohol great that's like saying
yo I can't hit hard I can't fight but I
can knock you out in one [__] punch
Bunch but you can't really fight I don't
do sometimes but I don't like to fight
yeah but when I
do yo so you're saying you can drink a
lot him and I can drink a [__]
shitload look at that joint just sitting
there waiting to be
smoked look at you which one the big one
the one that you haven't smoked yet D no
I wouldn't take a dad that's what I want
look it's on the on the see hey it's
nobody's fault it is it's ratchet's
fault
right he always forgets he can't talk
and the other day he was putting stuff
on his phone and holding it on his
forehead cuz I was talking about
technology and he put you can't even use
your computer and he put it on his
forehead like an ass heckling you real
you didn't realize that oh because in
the edit you can't see that M the other
day we were talking he put on there you
can't even use a
computer and he put it on his forehead
on the screen that piece of [__] a
reminder yeah you can't even use a
computer [__] assle when we had
fluffy right you suck fluffy no it
couldn't have been fluffy it was your
birthday it had to be your birthday
there's no way you suck at the internet
I do it's crazy how much I suck at the
internet Mar how old did you turn 37 37
I look 27 see it's the weed that's what
I said it's the reer it's the
reaper Mar just like actually
M37 it's the reaper you [__] crazy
ass old man right now it's the reaper I
needed a say and [__] that's your new
say it's the
reaper I like that saying that's a new
don't
cough people are driving they don't want
to hear you cough all right guys don't
crash see don't crash we've had I know
you don't watch the show that
often I do watch a show I know I'm just
going to keep talking [__] ready we've
had that I've personally seen from the
DMS with
pictures in total about 15 with pictures
eight people are we talking that it's
just that DM me to the show that they're
listening to the show in
Crash I was like don't be laughing
[__]
crash I've said that in the first season
and the first season I got one like yo I
crashed my [__] car listening to the
podcast like how do you do that like cuz
they're just listening to the show while
they got in an accident I'm like
everybody out there be safe I know
you're listening to the show I don't
want because like you think they're just
like they're like laughing they don't
pay attention no no no it's not like
you're you guys make laugh so hard we're
causing an accident that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is just they
happen to they happen to be I'm like y
be out I don't want you guys listening
to me and associating with
crashing yeah and I punched the
[__] with a screw in my hand and
they always think of Marty like
[Laughter]
damn scared [__] out of that was weird
that scared me it's a good one right
yeah it was a good one need a punch I
need a punch I need a punch Marty's over
here playing with my [__] emotion I
didn't know who was laughing like that
scared me didn't get you at all no oh
okay never mind just got was like he's
doing it again oh he's doing it again
shut up I was
involved all right where were we
at for real for real I'm the wrong guy
to ask that where we at for real John
doesn't really drink I was in Middle
School John doesn't really drink all
right John doesn't really drink
apparently all right apparently John
doesn't drink I don't drink two fths
okay we were talking about Hash House
coming out though and then we're talking
about Hash House coming why do you can't
remember your own Hash House
oh really bad we were talking
Rachel yell [__]
at oh never mind but yell [__] out of
that
okay sorry oh sorry for everyone driving
yeah and then we've had a lot of people
how about my favorite thing in the world
as a professional video video editor is
to make those chop highlight re Cuts
with John [__] dying cof oh my God it
is really intense on the videos it gets
intense it makes it look amazing we're
like really like we're like uh making
ourselves get obliterated like on
purpose it's like that's effort that's
professionalism oh my god did I ever
pass this to you no you haven't you guys
are Entre you know what's funny I was
going to I was going to talk some [__]
earlier and I was like you know what let
me just keep them talking I don't want
to interrupt them I was waiting for an
in to talk [__] and then you just yeah
you're a piece of [__] oh my
God smoke that while I smoke John's
because he's not going to smoke it
little there you gok it
up scared let's go I can't believe I
didn't pass that [__] joint
sorry sorry my bad yo take a dab all
right I'm I'm passing it's Marty's turn
I know oh [__] take a DB okay so we're
on Hash House coming out boom let's jump
like
this the dopest how do you remember it
starting cuz I remember exactly what
happened well I have a I have a
backstory of it happened before we have
go to you technically oh so you like
telling Back stories too huh you can't
just get right to the story Thomas it
was a back story [__] said that
[__] to me ear I said you know I want to
tell some back story huge back story
tell you're wrong man yeah did that's
what he said to me ready put your face
close to this put your face close to the
right now I'm on the way okay I'm on the
way [__] you go tell the story down the
way yo when your son's old enough to
know [__] I'm going to tell him so much
[__] to say to you Sophia is still like
this Thom where's Rosie though where's
Rosie though and I'm
like she like hey come hang out with me
and I'm like hey tell your dad this
she's like I want to go play [__] when
you're like four years old I'm going to
tell you so much funny [__] and you tell
don't say it when I'm here and then
you're going be so's been saying this
crazy thing lately I'm like I know I'm
not going to say [__] it's never going
to happen me and her text she's too
smart we she don't have a
phone we be texting but we text knew you
going to say it the're shining stop
touching my feet Thomas that wasn't me
that was ratchet man
ret man rocking the ryale high hat
that's the second time we brought up
grease tonight Jesus Jesus how do you
have a old back you said you have a
backstory to the dopest shop how it
started now continue with your
[__] you any
wine what it sad look I like you a cup
of wine with that I can't hear what
you're saying
go uh so uh dopest
continue just missed um I had our third
partner when I he had hit me up after
not talking to him for a couple years
because we did a uh he was he was
talking about taking hash outs legal
four years ago and he showed me this
facility and it was super dope and I was
supposed to be done in like a year and
then same facility today yeah same
facility today and it took four years to
do instead of it was and it was supposed
to do a year so we like kind of like
lost contact and and then he hit me up
one day and he was like hey uh I want to
I'll talk to you about some stuff but
you've heard of uh like the Delta 9
Delta eights and I was like no not
really and uh he's like let's have a
meeting so I I came there and picked him
up and he's like he sold a bunch of uh a
bunch of uh like a bunch of hhc a bunch
of delta8 different companies he's like
hey you have a a good name for for
yourself let's start like a hash house
uh like brand and I was like that'd be
cool he's like but I don't really know
like if people would really come over
from like the dabbing Community I'm just
like I just have like like hash dabbers
that follow me I only have many people
like that I was like but Thomas my buddy
has a lot of different following you
know like probably be probably better
you know to just do it like that and we
could all have a good time and he could
be the marketing for it and we to that
with you I me I told you about it and
you were like you were like a what you
were like what do you want to do and I
was like Hey listen I don't know about
it either but supposedly gets you high
and it works and we can get it to people
and let's see if it gets you high and
you're like baby were both very doubtful
about it we were like nah let's just see
so we had the meeting I never forget out
of my house and he came and he brought
[__] all these [__] different
Edibles and [__] sick ass gummies it was
crazy you're like oh these taste great
you know but like who knows if they do
anything like that's got to be got to be
better than tasting great you know and
you [__] ate a bunch of non-vegan
stuff let me added that I had to make
sure yeah I Hey listen but I'm saying
that's dedication you I had to make sure
you were like all it's not veg I'm going
try you're not going to tell me [__]
you eating them and you kept eating them
cuz so much they were good yeah I didn't
eat food yet yeah and then um I ate the
[__] and we and I was scared cuz I'm
already you know I was I'm scared of
Edibles so I ate I ate a certain amount
you know just so I know I'd feel it or
not that's how you are for Edibles yeah
yeah yeah just like that exactly people
all people fall in the commercials John
old people that's mean to them man
that's a factual commercial that's you
both Edibles oh here we go what' you do
nothing all over them shorts you can Ash
on the ground that's okay Ash my shorts
that sucks um um continue so uh we sat
down with him and we ate everything you
know and uh he called me like 30 minutes
later and you said this [__] works
that's not what I said I said so [__]
up this [__] was what's going on this
[__] hella word what the [__] is this
well you said it in more way more
detailed I'm sure but I can't remember
your sentences go ahead you take the
rest of the story that's true that's
true what happened you know what I'm
saying it it was like we both came
concise like yo this is [__] this is
[__] good you know it's the same as I
would feel from any edible so we sat
there and we [__] just what are we
going to do what we're going to put out
we tried I to this day it's in [__]
it's in [__] insane the amount of stuff
and different flavors for each skew we
have tried approved and disapproved but
the ones that we pick is thousand it's
it's crazy the ones that like get picked
you know like thousands that we've
denied that like literally wanted to
throw up all the all the cereal and swe
mil mil but it's dangerous but it's just
it's just something that like what I
really see it as is like you know some
people have hate on it and some people
don't but this is something that can get
to people that can't get stuff at all
like that people that are getting such
trash that don't even work they're
getting pens that are [__] made by
the guy in Cali that are is literally
trapping it out and cutting it with who
knows what and people are getting
Edibles that aren't even [__]
medicated you know like people are just
getting anything that are shipped from
Trappers everywhere tell
yeah we we got a way that like this is
something that like is tested by us two
people that are really picky and snobby
with their stuff by tested by us means
the FL and I'm saying like we're testing
no what I'm saying it's approved by us
you know so like I feel like I feel like
for us to approve something like that
like the normal person that doesn't
smoke like us has to be in love with it
you know that's how I look at it like
we're two people that are on a high
level smoke smoke a lot of weed we smoke
a lot of dabs we've done a lot of
Edibles In Our Lifetime you've done
[__] a lot a lot of challenges you
know what I'm saying so like you're the
first person to know if this [__] works
or not and you're the first person that
like keeps it real with everyone and
it's been like true to their people for
10 [__] years which is why we're
where we're at you know you guys are
Authority in the space both you exactly
together and we and and seeing what me
and like me and Thomas came up with all
these [__] designs with with with
with c and the team and Chad and but oh
they they they it really like it's
something that we can like they we have
to give our go you know what I'm saying
like to have the to have a company
that's not ran by a bunch of people that
like controls you and like at the end
like we're never going to be able to say
like oh man like we got [__] like it's
just impossible you know cuz like
everything has to be yes by me and
Thomas you know like it just doesn't
[__] go through without us and it's
because they have he has so much trust
in us and you know this is his face
we're not going to ruin Thomas's face
this is something that like we have to
make sure is perfect you guys have done
an amazing job as a brand person and
design and just somebody who's worked
with a lot of different companies it's
been amazing to to watch yeah I know and
and it's honestly and it's and it's
changed my life you know what I'm saying
because you know it's it's something
that we have that we can put out as a as
a legal brand that we have you know
through our bank accounts as legit
people and we're we're we're selling a
lot to a lot of people and it's it's
it's a it's a blessing you know it's the
fans really really [__] with it and just
see the fans [__] with it in a show like
how much different skews we have and
what we've been doing like there's no
doubt that people love this [__] you
know and the real s of the I was just
going to say the underlying point is
Thomas going from reviewing other
people's Brands to having his own is the
message yeah of like entrepreneurship
it's like that's how what you're
supposed to do well that's what that's
how I kind of feel too with like when I
was uh when I was in Florida I had my
brand but I was always buying like you
know catly stuff and different brands
and stuff and I was always commenting
like oh if I had a brand like I'd do
this different if I had a brand so I was
I was a huge customer before was a brand
so I used to preach that a lot when I
was first in like doing my rosin thing
in Cali like I was the Bigg like
everyone know I I was coming out to Cali
for 2 years you know I met a lot of
people coming out here and uh it was it
was it was crazy to
see
people um lost a whole train of thought
right there for the water bottle how
about that incredible you know why cuz
you focused on crunching the ice I guar
big piece of ice came in I I know you so
well that I know that's exactly wiped it
it shook you at your sketch style and
you it shook me huh the ice was such a
shock to your
system is what happened I got to be
honest now that I talked about the edge
sket [__] what the [__] are we talking
about no way what happened that's not
good no Marty what was I just saying to
you Marty Marty Marty you have to be
here bro you have to be the only one
here here yo I love that can you clip
that I know what it was it was the ice
it was we need that cuz you know one
time what what customer oh yes you guys
in school something you know he took
good notes in school oh yeah
okay there we go and we're back on track
customer yeah so I was just was I was a
very picky [__] customer before I was
have you know have my brand to give to
everybody like like you just said you
know you you got you were went through a
lot of companies and you've [__]
reviewed a lot of different ones and
you've been through a lot so it's like
now you have your own like you say all
the time like yo I'm not doing that [__]
we're not going to do that we have to do
it like this you know we have to do you
know so it's like we both have a lot of
experience in like pass [__] to make our
[__] what we want it to be yeah and not
goofy yeah and not Goofy and not goofy
super clean and professional some of it
looks sometimes we're like yo maybe the
five hour high was a little trappy yeah
that was my idea that was my that was my
like twist so that was like that's why I
was trappy a little bit but it worked s
we never sell that
again anyway uh lifted liquid forever
yeah that [__] is strong lifted liquid
changed my life too lifted liquid oh yo
I'm going say this uhhuh I have never
I've only seen music videos and videos
of that happening I have never seen that
many grown humans okay falling asleep at
once it was F unless I was in
kindergarten and it was [__] nap time
I have never seen that many people fall
asleep at once God this [__] was
drinking so much damn lean uhhuh that I
was like yo stop doing that [__] he's
like yo it's cool man yeah it was like
he was like a juny Le was just a like a
drug of my choice like say so much are
we talking about quantity at no I'm just
saying cuz he was never doing this [__]
I'm say a lot of his drink it we drink a
lot it's like whenever I drink alcohol I
drink a lot what is a lot of lean uh I
mean it's just all different types of
I've never been I never seen that before
person concept of like what dosage is
with that well I mean like you know like
anywhere people drink like about an
ounce or two cuz it's super expensive
right yeah it's it's ridic how many
ounces in a bottle
16 you need an ounce to [__] you up um
at least yeah well no an ounce or two
should [__] somebody up for sure okay
but uh ever since we came out with this
I haven't drank lean one time no [__]
nope that kind of wild and but the main
the main reason I like I like lean so
much was the effect I was like I got to
sleep really good so I never sleep good
so if I drink the lean I slept really
good and I had a great High all night
yeah so this is like it really is like
the same thing to me so it's like oh now
I make it I know it's not [__] drugs
yeah it's [__] it's [__] you know
like it's [__] works so no it's it's
something you know it's great that I got
to [__] stop drinking that [__]
[__] and drink that you know it's
kind of [__] funny to see though
because you see your home now that you
don't really drink L you see I know it's
not like you I was never once like I'm
concerned never like oh this one time on
New Year's you guys were all [__] up
and me and Ro left I was like yo that
[__] was wild you had like seven homies
over one had his mouth open neck up with
his phone a couple homies were dead ass
asleep and then we went to your birthday
and then somebody was eating it who who
is eating a steak and falling a [__]
sleep stop who my God I want to say I
don't want slime I I want to say it was
slime I think it was but I thought it
was funny but I was also like we are in
a nice SL place you guys are all
drinking lean in the restaurant in your
cups on the table the wait to see they
don't serve purple [__] no they did it
was there okay yeah it was there for the
story they serve the purple [__] there
but I remember just looking at it like
wow I've never seen that much sleep and
then obviously have a couple homies that
drink aot Bing and was like wow that
[__] looks fun as [__] how many times I
tell you I just want to fall asleep just
like that so bad I going to drink that
[__] I always preach like y heroin don't
be drinking that [__] it's the same [__]
that's why I always got like don't don't
do it I never preached like that is that
a fact people on heroin seems like so
much more H have you ever seen anybody
drunk as or [__] up off lean towards
like are you alive okay all right yeah
for sure neck up mouth open is the
scariest position I think that's scary
to look at somebody are you good are you
alive are you alive like Homer with eyes
closed I was like where the [__] is hom
I see him now W that's what they look
like it's [__] wild but it looks so
fun I want to fall asleep this so bad I
don't want to fall asleep like that so
bad I would love to fall asleep when I
want yeah it's just like the best sleep
you'll ever have but that yeah I already
drink a whole one I'll be okay I'm
moving if I drink two tros going to have
to drive the car cuz I'm not going to
risk that Rachel's for sure driving home
yeah I it's not and a lot of people
drink them four gummies oh you'll be
fine yeah yeah Chick-fil-A some
Chick-fil-A I ate it he's going to be
hitting the bag on the way out he's good
yeah that that' be fun you should hit
the bag on the way out no it's not you
should I'll hold that hold that I'll
give it back to you later no I be too
animated that [__] pop up not my [__]
front teeth out oh yeah I haven't taken
a dab again it's okay don't worry about
me wait did did did I put this get knock
give you a dab how'd that work that's
how I feel how'd that happen it's cuz
you're very very selfish listen man I'm
just trying to put all the effort into
your podcast all right I'm just trying
to make sure it's not my podcast it's
our oh watch out you hit the microphone
a podcast knows it's part of the family
so I mean the microphone knows the
podcast knows it's part of the family
it's okay if I smack it a few times it's
heating up for you right now thank you
no no wait Marty's turn
right have you taken one I feel like you
haven't taken the second DB no have you
tooken a second one no I don't think so
then it's Marty's turn yeah what are you
doing well see when you smack your hands
together it's funnier to me um continue
TOA shop right this is what I remember I
remember we came over to your house I
was like damn them green chairs are sick
ass color and we sat down and I went oh
what's up Claudio I like that
[__] tall for a mexan like holy
[__] I like you got to be mixed a little
bit come on girl you mixed that I was
like come on girl now Claudio's awesome
he's [__] tall as [__] I was like you
look athletic and he's like yeah and
then we s skip forward went to Claudio's
house one day and he has a hoop outside
that kicks the ball back that kind of
shoots back the [__] didn't miss
for seven minutes straight yeah it was
seriously [__] insane thought I
thought it was kind of like a joke and
he's just sitting there he's like
raining what bro just be throwing the
ball in the air like he was holding left
all day and just pressing X Circle X
Circle it looked like a glitch bit like
he was just from like what like
fre training him from far as hell
training me and Thomas were sitting
there like are you Europe I used to play
basketball like sh's a [__] monster
know that oh no he's a he's a monster I
didn't think of it and then we we
brought up the professor at the Champs
and I was like the professor would cross
you Claudia what are you talking about
and Tone's like claudo I'm sorry I think
the professor cross you claudo erupt
like set it up
I would smash the professor oh [__]
because Claudio's so damn big it's not a
it's not it's not a Juke situation if
it's a one-on-one yeah Clo's not going
to sit there and just get juked a bunch
of times he's goingon to hopefully
Swatch it cuz he's so damn big I'm he
made that point it was amazing he made
it as technical Point 40 minutes
straight and I was like all right you're
right he called a home me he was like
damn all right he founded a [__]
friend in that was a professional
basketball play like you would crush he
like you're so big like oh my God
Claudio's that good holy [__] and then I
remembered yeah you did drain that [__]
70 times in a row from 90 feet out
[__] Tom Brady it was incredible I
don't even think he missed we both
watched it I was doing this one cuz it
was so damn far away yeah it was hard
mhm anyway Claudio I walked in see
that's what the back story is
[__] I walked in said damn this
a nice green chairs how can I kill this
backstory right now all right I'm going
to kill it right now good no but that's
what I would considered that and then I
was like damn nice green chairs what's
up clao you like the green chairs a lot
no that's that's where we were at in
that moment I was like fast forward now
we're back so we sat down and I was like
yo this in my head I'm like this [__]
better be real and then he's explaining
this is what we would do this is what
we' go we could drop this this is what
it does I'm like hhc and he printed out
all of this [__] explaining everything
and I'm like
so I can Google all this and I did like
sounds it was real yeah sounds too good
to be true like early season two of the
podcast
right it's October
20 end of season one oober 2022 no sorry
right early season 2 October December 17
2021 that's when we launched yeah I'm
saying we we were have this meeting
October it was like was it like I have
the picture like four four months before
December I I have it hold how about this
how about this it's um [__] I'll get it
later it's on my YouTube I posted on the
community got high for TW oh fast
forward got so [__] dumb today I
think this company might actually be
real I think I might actually be we
might be doing some [__] and I I have
the date we'll pop it up on the screen I
posted it on damn YouTube I know I have
it um and I sat down I was like yeah
that shit's not real there's no way it's
real and I ate the gummies I like all
right gummies are [__] bomb and I ate
so many of them I remember that first
box first shipment we taking pictures
yes but this is when it was in a brown
box and all just had sample names and it
had what alternatives canb noid and I'm
like hhc what the [__] is this like it's
one letter change and I'm so thrown off
what the hell this [__] says live Rosen
D9
THC wow holy [__] then you see AJC go
what the [__] is that cuz if you don't
know what it is like what is that even
though it says all the bomb [__] in it
too you I just don't know what AJC is
and then explained all what AJC is the
alternative canoing how it's like Delta
8 I called it you Delta 11 just explain
it is another alternative [__]
another one but the new one that's bomb
see and that's what DJ khed came out
another grew his beer grew the day we
launched and then another one I ate a
bunch we got a uber home because we
ubered there why we did I have no
[__] clue you and I ubered
home how do who who remembers something
like that I don't know why we he's like
hey remember that day we uh we Uber with
Jasmine the driver she was four star I
don't know why we
ubered getting wrapped Boom the blue one
of course Rosie knows if Thomas do know
it memory of goats of goats I think it's
elephant Billy Goats to be
exact yeah this is episode long as a
billy goat this episode is long as a
billy go it's okay that's what we're
giving to people what they
want hey mother we been waiting a long
time you're going to S here for so long
I'm not in the doesn't even feel like it
it's been 6 hours it's crazy huh been
six no just kidding all right so I sit
there and I eat all these Edibles I get
the pans that tastes delicious but what
is what am I doing here smoking HH what
is this going I got all these samples I
ate all these Edibles I did the math I'm
like all right 1,200 is I 1,200 is
milligrams like if this hits me well no
get in the
Uber oh I remember this yeah you do I
get in the Uber and we're taking we live
in Glend all the time we're taking the
left to hit the 134 to come into
Glendale from the north part of
LA and right we're turning I'm like I
might have to tell him to stop because
my stomach hurts so bad I was like oh my
stomach I have to go to the bathroom
really bad ow like this sucks and I went
on my thrat up and I got so [__]
violently dizzy High I had to put my
face against the window cuz it was kind
of cold you know what I'm saying cuz the
glass is kind of cold and I just
wanted and I was just sitting there and
I was sitting there like with the spit
almost dri on my lip and I'm like I'm
going hear the [__] to throw up hurry
the [__] up and then we're were getting
home it was only like 6:30 so there was
some [__] traffic and then we get off
and I remember I got in the bed at I
went to the [__] bathroom immediately
got in the bed bed and went a [__]
throw up and I [__] drank water and I
waited like 3 hours I woke up and I was
so violently [__] high cuz I've never
had HC in my body I had no [__]
tolerance to it I was experimenting
didn't really dip your toe in it either
no I I dove in cuz I wanted to know like
ion [__] don't get you high [__]
for sure and then I I Texas full like
nine hours later I was like yo I'm in
this [__] [__] me up that was it you
know it's so it's just so crazy it's so
much better than like like even if you
have like know 20 cannabis companies
right and's say matter they're all the
biggest they still will never be like
how like that that's why this is so
exciting because you can this is real
legal like it's not like it's not like
where it's like oh it's federally legal
and you can't use money for the bank and
you can't do this like everything that's
why I think it was the most exciting for
me and Tom was like yo we have like
legit stuff that's going to be running a
real business like and it's still
cannabis something we love to do
something we still get to put out and
design the same [__] we already do and
now we get to put it out for every that
like can't enjoy it you in all 50 states
in all 50 states because on my story
times I not even my story time on my
comments people would always say I wish
I could smoke what you're smoking damn
watch I wish I could smoke what you're
and now they could yeah that was the
number one thing now they do now they
that was the number one thing wow you
can actually eat some edibles and watch
the [__] video now I think it was
just different and then it turned into
when we were I had that meeting
yesterday and uh the guy was talking
about how like he's like oh like your
analytics like obviously you know like
Call's last on the list right and I was
like no actually C's number three nope
it's crazy because C's number three on
the website like people that have the
most access to the most weed and
different companies in the world still
like really enjoy it's so wild it's a
part of my life for sure oh for sure
it's just part of the mix easily crazy
but it's easier to do that when you're a
part of the mix already you know when
like there's people that are in Cali
that have had their mixes forever then
go to their dispensaries forever and
like before dopus they obviously were
buying something else and for them to
buy dopus and keep buying dopus that
means that whatever they're getting was
not as good as this so like you know
like I think too with like the pens is
is a big thing cuz like the pen Market
in Cali is bad you know like it's like
you don't know what the [__] you're
getting in that pen because there are so
many people making these pens and they
make such sick packaging that all of it
looks legit and all of it looks perfect
and all of it looks good you know but
like they're bad some of them are really
bad so I feel like with us they know
like it's a really good [__] pen and
it gets me just as high as a THC pen
there's no difference
for for the I mean unless we're talking
ice hash Ros and pens a whole different
category we're talking about dis pens
yeah I SW you hit the hit our pen and
you like all right pen I know it is like
a pen yeah mhm you the White Widow
tastes like a [__] weed pan if I've
ever tasted one it's kind of wild how
much that tastes like a weed pan but
even most weed pens still tastes like
fruits and stuff I know I'm saying just
that one yeah that one just tastes
[__] this my favorite one I know
that just bomb but the Reas this a
straw straw is one the wedding cake is
the is the best one because it's so
weird and different like the if you had
the wedding cake and a strawana it's
like I'll pick a all day no no I'm
trying to say you to have both of them
like oh this is like the cakey flavor
then the Str is like the fruity flavor
when you're like on the go like you
can't smoke cake all day I can't I can't
smoke the cake all day smok OC Fair you
can't smoke it all day it's more of like
a a special hit you know like hit
through the day the strong and could do
all [__] try that one what what I
might have already I don't there's St
over there it tastes like a KS it tastes
like a KS you always say that in the
videos we didn't have curs what I had to
look it up
what where you from New York you got New
York salers only oh [__] hey that's on
the house dude get the [__] out of
here I I've never seen this one before
what is up with you what are you saying
hit that immediately it tastes like a
strawberry banana delicious ass smoothie
it really is it is shocking how much it
tastes like strawberry banana smoothie
yeah what the hell it really does like
the on Rosie orders it tastes just boom
the one from earlier bomb kind of wild
huh you know what's crazy is we've been
here for a minute today's been such a
like long day what did you do when you
woke up today John uh woke up went to
the gym
got back to a show took my daughter to
her her her first day of not first day
of school but her her her uh Jesus her
orientation of school to meet her
teachers and and her classmates what do
you mean for what what's kind of school
preschool okay she's only going to be
three preschool that's preschool three
years
old pre pre yeah yeah are you kidding me
m how long is she going to go to school
for three days a week 3 hours a day okay
that's very minimal she'll and hang out
with people what she'll be at school all
day already she just she's just so smart
that like to not like she has everything
else down like something like she needs
to go be with kids more social people so
it's like she needs to go to school to
like if not she's just going to like I'm
like I'm like holding back her smartness
you know it's like she needs to get used
to not being around you guys all day
yeah for well she also with with the
nanny as well so she does that she also
with a lot of friends here and there but
with the school it's like no one she's
used to and like she can get more
friends she have many friends you know
she has a couple friends of like you
know all my homies that have kids but
she doesn't have any other friends you
know it's time for her to like you know
have a couple play dates and stuff like
that and like just different kid stuff
you know it's crazy weird awesome Weir
already though it's crazy yeah that was
fast super fast that was
weird damn
it yeah I could rip that all day too
yeah trying to say okay here we are I
think we've come full full circle
besides the dopest and we were talking
about getting high as hell and I almost
threw up or [__] my pants or both or
what's that called when you do both I
don't know but honestly it was like it
was still kind of daylight I was
thinking where am I going to [__] my
pants out it's the side of the 134 what
is going to happen fols are going to
take a picture and then it's going to
get online they like that's it and I'm
pretty sure is is that oh [__] I'm going
to be just a guy with just his lower
stomach and ass hanging out cuz I'm
going have my shirt over my [__] head
like God like I [__] his pants too with
his shirt oh my and the homies for Life
te [__] damn push trees on the back of
the backck wall man hey pretty sure yeah
I almost [__] my pants so we started the
dopest is that a good tagline I got so
high I almost [__] my pants so that's
why we started the dop
shop.com SS good that's be the next the
next uh
billboard don't start with i sh my PS
for the dopest no I got so high I almost
[__] my pants in an Uber the dopest
shop.com this be a t-shirt this is why
we have a Twitter this is why we have a
Twitter Chad I got so high I almost [__]
my pants in an
Uber Thomas Thomas a little like from a
fan testimonial tesimonials from a f
also what speaking of fans we really
need to do that uh you know go pick
someone and C like put an order and go
pull up on them yeah but we got to plan
it ahead of time because we pull up it
yo uh uh they're not there have a list
of five people whoever
answers it's got to be lucky the draw
you got to be a little bit more lucky
than just ordering I get that I get that
but okay if we're going to film all day
and hope and hope you know what we could
do yeah we can pick a person on that we
pick on lot and maybe we like you know
see their Instagram see who following
see comments as much hit up a friend and
go hey can you keep a secret please and
make sure it tell us when there's home
and we're going to do a day and I
guarantee they will got to just hope or
tell them ask them where they work and
we'll pull up on what time they get off
I a 650 we should just hire a private
investigator to stalk this stop it to
stalk a person that would be so yo this
is not a idea address I need you to go
sit there all night wait for a car to
leave this is what the person look going
get him arrested so we bail him out so
was immediate I feel that was genuine
I'll I'll out immediate steak dinner why
can't we do that without him going to
jail we can but if he goes to jail also
are you
willing my God yeah I'm willing for a
steak dinner what's wrong with this man
he knows he's not going to get caught
he's not like
you what he won't get caught he's quick
why would I you're slow if you guys find
out where he works you know how fast he
is Yo he's like
69 like 69ine the rapper he's like 6'9
like he runs like 69 from a meeting is
that what you were trying to say or is
he 6'9 that that's a joke about I really
was asking I know I know you were that's
why it was good to me that's why it was
so funny don't do that
more not
down hey don't be don't be pretending
like you're on your phone now asking you
a question we're three and a half hours
into this
podcast yep yep flew by remember where
those cameras no he don't told you ran
out oh
what we're almost there yeah
good he really did the phone thing I
don't get it I'll have some else what
does that mean I don't even get it you
typed it I still don't get
it oh my goodness he almost put his
phone eight
times do what
though
he's Ming us sorry I wish there was a
camera pointed [__] this this is
rough this this cholo over here rocker
cholo fool over here come on man wa is
it Marty's turn or is it your turn the
crime Mar it's your turn right what
crime yeah
speak [__] stalking somebody oh yeah
that is the crime I don't think it's a
crime I CRI investigator he said idiots
you're a private investigator not a
stalker get we getting someone with a
license oh I don't look like a private
hey you do how do you know what they
look like you can't see them they know
that's their job they never get seen so
how do you know what they look like I
would just say yeah I saw I'm going to
the store with some [__] and
never go [__] follow the person like
how do you know yeah right investig is a
scammer worst one I'm the worst cop ever
too by the way I'm fuing avoiding
everything Marty doesn't make small talk
oh you got CH
huh oh he's got the angle to cough again
he decided it again he didn't want to
pick it up he did
it and cover that little cap with your
finger too that little green part that
green part the cap on top cap on top
slightly just cover it look at Marty
hold it hold it
hold he waits cold it's all right it's
all right still hit
it nice well all right well all right
well look you think it's over
it's not it is not it's not no okay so
so now that you're starting Hash House I
mean now that hash house is going
uh into legal
stores what is the first thing you're
going to do are you are you going to do
any donuts of any kind are that's why I
want cuz people are going to ask what is
it going to drop and I know that's what
they're going to ask yeah Donuts weed
like donuts a and
rosin pens not yet not right away no
rosin pens not not right it'll be the
Rosen pens won't be right
away if you really want them up you
should do them immediately I'm doing Ros
and pens right away thank
you how many times have I smoked Ros and
pens and fell asleep or Smoked Out
restaurants and it just looks like the
steam you Andel are very Avid Ros and
pens love double f r
pens I'll hit three to four at time know
the way you said that
but it's taking a fat DB in the middle
of the restaurant nobody could tell Inc
yeah just been living on them things
right no this full [__] took them
away this full took them away no I just
I just want to get better Hardware the
hardware was [__] annoying dude it
was annoying but damn yeah so I just I
just I've been lagging because I haven't
found got the next
Hardware yeah I'm lagging yeah you are
lagging got a lot of things going on
yeah you do it'll be all right soig it
out real quick quick uh for the dopa
shop mhm let's talk about the collabs we
have coming out real quick before we end
this let's do that I will start we have
a phase rain recovery collab coming
out probably closer to a couple weeks
after this comes out yeah def definitely
when is it coming out I would say
October we're going to launch it in
October okay all right dropped the
picture right the black on black yes
that's a surrender of one thing we have
a like three SKS coming out mhm then we
have the Goblin collab coming out which
is going to be awesome cuz the Goblin's
[__] awesome is there renders for
that yet no yeah oh I guess we were
going back and forth we were going back
and forth there's two out of three done
yeah yeah and then one John got done the
collab that John got done Chief ke
collab yep oh [__] yes sir yeah that
one's gonna be sick done as in like
locked in oh it's locked in yeah getting
designed right now getting designed yeah
can you speak on how it looks um it's
it's just very Chief ke
[__] it's like it's not like it's very
like his Vibe it's not very like it's
not like art un usual stuff it's going
to be cuz uh it's his it's like
collaboration with uh gross you know
which is like that's his cannabis
company you ever heard of that no it's
like his a cannabis strain so it's like
it's like this like it's called gross
it's called gross it's like a little
like
a exactly so it's like a little like
molecule like little little guy like
little atom looking mascot dude so it's
like very it's it's a little bit I guess
like almost more like more fun you know
more like a little more trappy a little
more like it's nice I like it a lot it's
going to be cool is each collab get
different products yeah well no
different flavors but a lot of we're
doing like our our most popular products
you know you want to give people like
what they actually want to buy so we
just picked our top three things for
everyone to collab with and then they
pick their own flavors go that's why the
collabs take a little longer because
we've been we have to go back and forth
with them and then make sure they like
it make sure we like it make sure
everything works design wise like liquid
Diamond syrup yeah there's be liquid
Diamond there's going to be a syrup and
there's going to be a gummy some some
type of edible for each person it's
going to be so it's going to be the each
collab for the edible is all a hash
house doist and then whoever we're
collab it's just crazy that it's like
yeah to your door and then as it like
come as a pack or you can get it like
all a you can get it all all a cart and
I'm sure we'll have like some sort of
bundle you know if you get all three or
something like that we're still we're
still getting everything down we were
like basically every all the packaging
is being ordered right now so it's going
to be dropping real soon mhm you know so
it should be should be cool it's prettyy
[__] sick it's going to be really
dope we we're going to do a lot of more
a lot more content we have new people to
do stuff with and just like more more
ideas flowing in so it's going to be
cool it's be a good uh good time now
that it's like you've done the hardest
thing which is get it up get it going
and be successful it's like now we can
be creative and see what we really can
do what we have yeah and Tak we're
trying to take it to the next level
we've gone through we have 192 SKS I
think I'm not even sure now 187 SKS 188
SK and we're dialing it back cuz like
there's no reason for us to have 62
flavors of a disposable this is getting
out of hand cuz every week we were
dropping two new skes two new
SKS you know what I'm saying John we're
dropping two new SKS so we have so much
we drop we drop at least one skew every
week insane how much we were doing for a
while we were dropping more than that
for a good stretch of like three months
so we're dialing the back right now
because we know what we're we're about
to be two years we're going to keep new
stuff flowing and and like and like
start like taking some flavors out
bringing them back later you know cuz
exactly there too many too many flavors
for everyone to choose from you know I
feel like feel like it's over a little
overwhelming I go to the website there
Jesus Christ which bring them back in a
couple years whatever exactly cuz Jesus
Christ it's insane and the thing is if
there's that many SKS we have Deni times
20 oh and we have we have this this new
uh this new thing launching and I feel
like by now by the time this comes out
we'll for sure be already talking about
it which one the the little joints oh
yeah go for it so uh there the big thing
now in the in the hhc industry you know
alternative cbys is the thca so we have
the thca diamonds we have a collab with
the glob mops coming out so it's G be a
pack of glob mops with like a two gam
jar of th Diamond just straight
crazy looking th diamonds and then we're
also going to have joint these little
joints as me th weed with the th
diamonds so it's literally going to be
something that's like you can usually
not get to your door like this it's
going to be something it looks like I
don't know what all this means it looks
like it looks like regular weed and
regular dabs in a joint because it like
basically is but it's not okay it's kind
of shocking some with the TC AE looks
like this [__] in my jar [__] yeah it
looks like the [__] we're smoking right
now if you grind it up no just looks
it's so fire it's like the same [__]
except it's THC which is we might even
be selling like quarter pounds who knows
on do.com legally legal quarter pound of
weed to your
door it's going to be insane going to be
cool it's going to be sick yeah so
that's that's something new we're always
we're just trying to make new [__] all
the time know be out by the time this
comes out we're it's going to be talked
about for sure Rel he already showed one
sample of it but it was with the CBD
weed when he first we first got our
first Amo was CBD we with t diamonds and
we're like what are we doing let's put
thca weed in there and thca diamonds
it's like a lot more like weed you're
going to get effect from the weed and
from the concentrate gotcha so it's
going to be a pretty nice little
five-pack joint it's going to be sick
yeah no hhc just straight thca
yeah yo it's I used to smoke glob not
Globs shards shards literal like
spoonfuls like bottom of cereal dust on
the people used to have like the the
Pyrex things just filled with it so much
how do you get it the th yeah it's like
it's like extracted from from from the
plant but it's the thca so it's like
nonactive THC so it's like it only gets
active until it gets burned legal so
it's legal oh what the [__] yeah okay
don't ask me don't ask me you ain't
asking but it's going to be it's the
same way of like how we're putting my
DHC raw in in these gummies and still be
able to ship a bit it's just it's legal
you know there's just there's just
certain percentages laws and guidelines
you have to follow if you follow it
you're good it's pretty amazing the weed
looks [__] fire it's kind of
shocking I'm interested to see it I
could show you it you have no idea yeah
no for sure it's not just like packs of
weed so how many like strains you going
to roll out we're going to see we're
we're we not to find the right strains
right now so that's why it hasn't come
out yet so we're going to have some I
think more samples in a couple days and
we'll see how those go and we'll just
we're just waiting it's pretty that's
the best part me and Thomas just wait
like more samples I have I have stuff
showing up to my house like every two
days say a week for sure like oh there's
some syrups oh here's some more flavors
of pens here's some more flavors of this
here's a TCA Diamond tell which one's
good oh no [__] this one's bad I got as
soon as we got the first joints I sliced
the first one slice it open I was like
oh no diamonds going be bigger we
doesn't look good can't run these and
then we figured it out F we just we just
tweak everything and we make it [__]
dope cuz it's the dopest that's it and
we're allowed to do it yeah so crazy
that was beautiful we're allowed to
[__] do it cuz we're the [__]
dopest Jesus Christ that was
beautiful man love you damn we're we're
definitely three and a half hour in high
yo it's crazy like the tabs are like
non-existent in my life and [__] and
they don't exist in my realm and [__]
crazy man look at Omar you look high as
hell too yeah man um yeah man yo I am
genuinely hi yeah of course how you guys
feeling over there I believe it's been a
while Rachel this is the longest I've
ever seen you come out over here in a
while no it's awesome it's been so long
for real a minute since the children
don't come out she be hanging at the
house but why not that shit's tight yes
I don't want to hang out at home I do I
do it's fun yo so Marty is there
anything you wanted to
ask I don't think so I'm just glad we
made this happen this feels legendary
this feels legendary I love it legendary
defitely for it Coke
milk huh uh Rosie was new flavor no I
saw this new flavor Jesus I saw this
hilarious ass uh tweet it made me
[__] laugh and I thought Rosie was
listening sorry we're we're we're kind
of just all talking so I was just
talking [__] and see if Rosie was
listening she was not I nothing to do I
can't even explain the joke to you oh
that's what I have to show you can't
even show you Coke milk Marty yeah guys
yeah doop do shop.com Coke milk that new
Coke milk oh my God yo we were walking
in Champs and tell
me a girl came
up just subcribe what Short's this big a
promo girl with basically a sign but it
was a big thing with a logo and had
samples on it and she looked at me and
goes hey I was in Vegas we were walking
through I about 10 ft in front of this
guy and this girl looked at me dead in
the [__] face Marty and she goes hey
you want to try some cocaine oh my God
that was great I damn you did a backflip
and kick this [__] away from me don't
you dare ass me some [__] like that at
least not you know how many times they
said that that day
anyone want cocaine want to try some
cocaine it's a brand called cocaine it's
a drink oh it's a drink hey you want to
try some cocaine I think it's an energy
drink are you [__] kidding me [__]
don't be asking me that [__] especially
out loud like that people going think
I'm down with some [__] like that
cocaine is awesome I don't do that [__]
Noone cocaine is awesome but don't be
ask me that [__] like that that loud El
Jesus cry like no I'm good thank you
very much I been ask like uh maybe
activates a whole reaction
even worth it wouldn't even know
wouldn't even know good all right the
nose thing's weird you think we're done
we're not tell me about your first time
eating mushrooms oh my god oh you think
we're done we're not I Haven you taken a
dab yet it's crazy no no it's heating up
it's it's ready then you ask me a
question I almost forgot
see wow that was crazy uh first time
eating
mushrooms uh what was I doing that day
eating mushrooms no
that's the noise I make um I was uh damn
I'm I'm I'm literally like blinking
right now take a dip take a what dip
you're
disgusting um first time I did mushrooms
where was I I can't remember oh my God
first
time wow that's crazy huh what's your
favorite mushroom story that you can at
least remember then no it's crazy I
can't oh I remember the first time my
bad woo wow that was crazy don't go like
this say smok smok out SM oh cuz some
people are are not watching some people
are listening and not even no no I want
you to admit like smoked out smoked out
okay so with my buddy Nick and uh
everyone's like you know he's been he's
been shrooming lately and all everything
so he was like y you got to try it I was
like all right cool I'm only going to
try it like with one person so I Tred it
with him we're at his house his mom
leaves in the morning and uh we're he
leaves like supp go to school so we like
we leave to the bus and we leave and we
wait wait like around the block for her
to leave we go back in the house and we
eat [__] I think I eat like [__]
three Gams or something like that and uh
what
grade
like 9th or 10th okay uh something like
that probably 10th grade and um we we
start we're just we're just smoking
chilling you know and we put on aliceon
Wonderland he's like that's be a good
movie to watch I was like all right cool
so and I never really watched Alison
Wonderland so I'm like wa and we're like
watching it It's beginning and then like
we start tripping and like he has like
poporn ceiling so popcorn ceiling was
like pretty incredible and then we like
we end up like we end up like turning
the TV off but it's like a it's like a
TV like movie so it's like it's still
going while the TV's off you know so we
like go upstairs you know just he's just
just like exploring [__] checking [__]
out smoking weed in all different rooms
and [__] he like rolled joint and put
him in every in all different rooms [__]
were you feeling it by then huh yeah
yeah I was I was completely [__] up
okay and uh but like I feel like now
people aren't like doing three Gs really
like people like micro doing more micro
yeah so like back then like no one did
did that so everyone was like you have
to take at least an eth so I was like
scared I was like I'll do three Gams so
I'm [__] like in in the next World
Now by now so I'm like and then I come
down the stairs and we turn the TV on
and I sit back down and like I start
watching it and it's like now she's in
like a different world you know and now
I'm like oh my God this is this is crazy
like is this is this how the movie goes
cuz I didn't know what was going on so
I'm thinking the movie is like on I'm
like watching like I'm like
hallucinating watching the movie you
know then I feel like I'm almost damn
near in the movie with Alice like Alice
is my home girl we're chilling we're
watching movie it was crazy and then uh
we I remember making a baloney sandwich
and I couldn't eat it because it was
disgusting it looked disgusting to
me yeah but it didn't look good when I
when I made it it just looked like bad
uh and the these he had these blinds in
his uh in his in his house and it was
dark so like the blinds had the AC on it
was just like some light would come
through like every once in a while and
it was just like tripping me out and all
of a sudden uh his his mom uh like
pulled up and we're supposed to be in
school and we had to like pretend we
were
fine no and it wasn't we weren't fine
kept smoking I was like all right we're
leaving and we left to the Homie house
and we just like kind of kind of like
killed our trip we were kind of like
almost done after that and I thought
like I was like that I love streams
after that I was like this is this is
the best it's a great time it's just
like just like getting high like in a
different way but like seeing [__] like
seeing [__] like move a little I was
like in a whole different world I loved
it and then I tripped a couple more
times you know and it was good times and
one time I tripped uh at this at the
same with the same kid we had a party
this time cuz I thought like I was a
professional shroom Tripper I was like I
I got this this is so you did it in the
public space so I did it in a public
space with a bunch people that weren't
tripping just me and him the Weir
decision of my life my weirdos for sure
yeah so like everyone was [__] with
us you know so like I like for some
reason went into like a closet to get
away from everyone and everyone was like
bang on the closet
and I like it [__] me up bad and I was
to the point like the party was over and
I was like I never I was on this I was
on the couch it was like a Christmas was
just over so like probably January or
something like that you know and there
was like these wreath like know the
wreath you put in the front door it was
right there and I had my arm embedded in
the wreath and I was taking I was just
slamming it against the uh I took like
five or six grams and I was slamming it
against thing I at the party no no party
was over my homies house now the party
was at but everyone left you had taken
six grams already yeah yeah yeah that is
all right and then in a public space
crazy but I didn't know that this the
first time me experiencing in a public
space we've always done it like just
chill at the house I was like that'll be
cool like be tripping at the party and
then uh so I'm like sitting there just
screaming I'm so confused for like two
hours the only words I could speak I'm
so confused it's the only thing I can
speak and then he called uh so his mom
she like she smoked she knew we smoked
and smoked with us and [__] so they I
guess they collaborated this whole story
cuz they were worried they were like oh
he's having a bad trip so like we got
call the Mom and tell him that he smoked
l weed so they had this whole story
right and I didn't really know there was
a story right so she came over and like
they're like oh I see them I'm on the
couch [__] bugging out and they're
like I see them all talking I'm like why
is a mom here like this is crazy you
know and all of a sudden she walks in
she like John John what's wrong you okay
and I just stood I was like I took
shrooms and she was like huh and they
were like
John you [__] idiot what do you I was
and I didn't know they had this whole
plan cuz I was over there screaming I'm
so confused on the [__] couch no one
came over to like or maybe they did and
I just don't [__] remember who knows
but uh so she was pissed the [__] off
she was like oh you [__] idiots and
then we were at like my homies house it
was like literally it's like s neighb
it's like a block away so they had to
like take me back to their house you
know she's like want come back to my
house so they come back and it took them
like 30 40 minutes to get me like 30 40
feet cuz I was just like doing the
craziest [__] I don't remember this part
I remember I woke up in my homie's room
cuz when I SLE in my homie's house was
like I slept on the couch I'm like pull
out couch and I [__] woke up in his
room like on the floor next to his bed
and I'm like why the [__] am I in this
room like what the [__] I go out and I I
go out and I see his mom's right across
me I look at his mom and she's like
shaking her head at me and I look at my
homie he's shaking his head I'm like I
like I'm like go like to the bathroom
and I start I'm taking a piss and I'm
like it's all starts hitting me and I'm
like oh this is bad you C out the window
no no no I just w walk back in the room
and I closed door I said yo Nick did we
[__] up last night he like yeah yeah big
time and then the mom never let us smoke
weed ever again she never let us do
anything she was the strictest person
ever cuz she's like yo you broke my rule
told you only weed I like [__] so was
like the worst [__] ever I [__] up you
did [__] up you did [__] that whole
thing up BL weed is the perfect cover I
didn't know I didn't remember that's
such I was so confused but you're high
Six GS you are not accountable for
anything I wasn't there try to follow
rules no said I was just taking my shoe
throwing it 30 ft and going to run and
get my shoe on the way over there you
know when like kites are really taken
off and you have to pull against them
that's your brain and that's you down
there that was wild you can't really
blame me for that as long as you're not
hurting anybody that's funny you're
throwing in your shoe but that's [__]
also like scary and embarrassing for
that lady so I get it yeah for sure but
still a perfect story now yeah no it was
great all right so John freaked out and
[__] everything up MH I love it that's
going be the title of that clip John
freaked out and [__] everything up you
ready for that mhm I've never seen your
eyes red really no you look high get
your Fe D
wow you really did it yeah I'm taking a
dab you really did it thank you you want
I'll tell you the um you said what's the
longest podcast you ever did was like
four four hours like 20 seconds no I
mean not oh 4 hours 30 minutes oh so
far
go go how much time are got on that one
go let's go y cap the top oh yeah full
here that's only got like
10 we're running out of space yeah we're
we're going so long it's
crazy hold
on oh
man
sorry everyone drive for dabbing sorry
everyone dab got say
something Jesus Christ like yo is he
okay you got to stand up we discovered
that that's exciting man you try not to
hurt my back that wouldn't be good ooh
thank you
sir what was that that was the Apple
P tastes very
PR all right all right been here almost
four hours did it justice did a good job
we hung out how you feeling you weren't
like OG the first time I had to hold
your hand he was ready I wish you would
hold my hand remember remember Rosie he
was all scared and [__] oh ge's for s's
[__] I'm
nervous I don't be on camera like John
you been on 30 dopest Y videos it's
different it's not though I didn't say
that said it's different it's easier
because you don't got to sit here and
rip blinkers the entire time and [__]
yeah yeah yeah be challenged rip a
[__] blinker right now before we get
out of here it's your episode it's your
episode you got to rip blinker no I'm
trying to catch him from the dab so we
wait a
second sh double I another one it's your
episode you should really take a dab I
mean you should take a blinker come on I
want to see it I want to see it I want
to see
it the light on this you can't see
it it's blocked by that sticker
o
double oh much breath a you should the
double redo it redo
it sorry for everyone driving you had to
say the word blinker huh for everyone
driving s great for everyone driving
I'm
sorry should know should have known
should have known how you feeling you
didn't even cough hard no I'm not soft
usually usually on video evidence back
me up you dying no not at all all right
it's okay everybody else knows old
Channel go watch some videos go refer to
like every
video
yo for a minute me you see I was I was
good we about to Coast out of here yeah
I was good it's okay we've been hanging
out Doos
shop.com that shit's tight it's kind of
crazy we have a whole team good info and
a damn Amazon style Warehouse it's
pretty
incredible yeah I agree all right well
we're here we are we've been here for
four hours damn near my legs damn near
asleep legs are asleep that's a
moved well you you played foot with me
16 times that's a lie no I'm talking
about like my legs I haven't like
adjusted my seat oh my leg's been
hurting your hips yo can you sign this
toy I made of you yes
sir yes love it thank you so much take
another blinker no you take a blinker
was that you signing it with a pen
oo you like that what was it say some DJ
colge [__] about brains and
smarts excuse me man every time you got
some DJ khed style [__] I went you gotta
say some [__] no you're a [__] ass fool
[__] end of the show like that all
some [__] that you would normally be
doing but you're not
doing doing what you're not doing you
can't kick flip with those type of
things I just kick flipped the [__] out
of that and you went off on a [__] ass
no I'm not saying no DJ cge [__] you may
recognize John from lots of Tik Tok
videos where they go what do you do for
a living or what you got in the bag and
they go yo GJ khed it's John it's
[__] funny how many times I've seen
him come up my damn Tik Tok page on
other people's random accounts huge
viral
videos you never seen them I've had
people just send it there's like certain
days where like everyone sent it to me
cuz it gets it goes like viral again
everyone sent it to me I'm like I know I
saw this it's like 3 years old it's just
him the guy walked DJ what's up man what
you buy I'm like oh my God and just
John high ass John and Rachel's like oh
my God [__] we the best I tell him every
time yep every time it's I just give
them what I just give them what they
want to hear now you know the [__] yeah
and that's what I wanted and you get I
was wait for this you [__] oh
yeah we're dying our cameras are dying
out here guys about a minute we got
about a minute left it's called let me
help you outro no no no we don't do
stuff like that yo guys let's get out of
here yeah let's wrap it up I call wrap
it up outro is a is a term that we use
when you're not here only
mhm don't be looking at me [__]
French Montana's cousin don't be look at
like that [__] French Montana the
[__] French Montana's cousin
now Cuban cousin no way that's what you
that's you now no okay close it's okay
how about this you're every guy that
I've seen on Tik Tok in New York goes yo
don't be looking at me like that kid you
seen those guys no you know what I'm
talking about don't be disrespecting me
kid he was that the guy if you put a hat
on yo give me a hat New York John never
left from New York [__] youate reality
if
John you know I was born in New York
wait did we talk about that holy [__] we
didn't uh oh my God I'm kidding
[__] I know that I know you
can't tell it's okay he was kick
flipping a no I was actually about to
tail slide I'm not kidding just about to
tell just fell hold
on
baller baller huh hey that's what
happens all right we don't have to be
here like sir your last movie on
amvd you like my last
[__] well we just be talking [__] bless
you at the same time that was crazy I
pretended to blow this [__] make sure
you guys check out the last album I just
dropped what was it called be the best
oh [__] you just biological go
stepfather album's called the doish
shop.com the album's called the dop
shop.com and that's what we're going to
think the dop shop.com and soon thank
you thank you thank you for you coming
out Hash House to Legal
stores wow yes sir
weird awesome but like weird to go and
just multiple States as well it's not
going to be just California really not
the goal is not be just California I
mean right off the bat that we're just
just Laing there there I I could I could
do it rather that I'm going to take it
take it off a little slow but
M okay well I'm saying it's going to be
very odd to like be able to go into a
store oh oh [__] you know it's kind of
crazy like there's
[Music]
displays you get what I'm saying when
you see brma displays has their [__] in
the [__] front of the store that's
going to be wild yeah little trappiest
little house little trappiest little
house oh the Emoji it was the Emoji yeah
it was it was an emoji it was the house
emoji it was incredible Emoji house sh
house emoji house that's exactly what it
was it was incredible um you're you get
deleted so let's just go to your nice
one what's your
Instagram the nice one the real [__]
Hash House that's your Hash House one
the real [__] Hash House yeah what is
your nice one
oh one has a th word [__] with a g in
it I was like my what the hell man I get
it now I told you give me some DJ cge
[__] what the [__] your Instagram name
[__] John did John did John did with
an underscore no no underscores just
John UND did then say it there's not an
underscore so there's no underscore no
there isn't I told you there's
underscore oh [__] you [__] you [__] you
all right Marty you're with me on this
first you didn't say anything about
underscore Marty you're with me there is
an underscore he said he said no and yes
TW we run it back Charlie I know I'm
[__] with you I wasn't sure Jesus I
wasn't sure I wasn't sure dude the TI's
running out dude we're like 2 minutes
left 2 minutes 2 minutes we run these
[__] cards out that's what
we're going to do John uh John did with
no underscore then [__] with
underscore where where is that
underscore located you don't know you
don't know yo you got [__] longitude
longitude on your fingers is that where
the [__] the underscore is John is that
where it's at you Pat this [__] the end
of propos to my wife I know is at the
end it's the Taco Bell on Ventura he
[__] get lot Taco Bell on
V I got a bean and cheese burrito please
yeah that's after I taught him we should
give away we should go to an underground
poker game right now win 10K and do this
outro we have one minute left are you
ready together yeah all right here we go
money here we go John did with
underscore somewhere there oh wait don't
forget about the
Philippines about the toy
drive oh go are we doing another toy job
of course we are are you just saying
that to say it no just oh you're just
saying okay we're going to run out of
the card yeah all right thank you guys
so much we appreciate you um John sat
here for a while did a great job he
didn't poop he did nothing he didn't
even get up do some some people Emoji
I've pooped in that
chair okay today yeah it was earlier
this morning
actually you guys no John you'll be fine
I know I'll be fine Marty finally
4our episode let's go John thank you so
much for being here everybody that sat
in this room thank you so much for
sitting here I can't wait to go like
this and dive into that piece of pizza I
didn't eat all the way that I have out
there it's real cheese oh it's not I'm
so excited thank you guys so much for
being here this has been the do's usual
podcast from Marty DJ khed son John did
and I Hash House the doas shop.com have
a dope ass day have the dopest day ooh I
am [__] high legitimately and I think
the shot got me a
[Music]
little
perfect
[Music]